what better way to improve your python
and pygame skills than by building a
clone of stardew valley christian from
clear code makes amazing python game
tutorials and in this course he will
teach you how to build a clone of this
popular game
[Music]
in this tutorial we will create a stadio
valley style game in python and this is
going to have a ton of stuff like
farming and foraging we can cut down
trees and trade items there's also a day
and night cycle and different kinds of
weather
the entire game was also made entirely
so you can expand it yourself
speaking of i am using the free version
of the sproutland asset pack by cup
noodle
which is amazing there's also a paid
version with more stuff if you want to
expand the game yourself although for
this video you don't need to spend any
money
before i start i do want to emphasize
that this is not a beginner's tutorial
to be able to follow you will need to
have a good understanding of pygame if
you want an introduction or reminder i
would recommend my introduction to
pygame and my video on using delta time
if you have those two you should have a
really solid foundation during the video
i will also mention a couple of videos
that explain some more advanced topics
in detail those can be helpful but you
are not going to need them to follow
along
alternatively i also have a paid course
where you learn all of my game by making
4 pretty cool games check this one out
if you are interested and sorry about
the requirements but if i did this
tutorial from scratch it would easily be
20 hours long
finally the entire project is inside of
one folder and i will be working in the
code subfolder
i will explain while coding when and how
to access elements in here i also saved
the progress for every chapter and you
can find that on github
and with all of that i hope you enjoy
alrighty so let's get started and i
already have a couple of lines of code
ready just to get started let's have a
look at those here i have my code and i
have main.pi and i have settings.pi both
already have quite a bit and i am
working in main.pi for now
if i execute the code with all of this
i can see a black window that doesn't do
anything right now but we do have a
start
and all of the stuff in settings we are
going to use later but well for now
don't worry about it besides these two
lines here
those determine the width and the height
of our window
now if you have a very small or very
large monitor
you could change these numbers to
something else whatever is appropriate
for you the rest of the game is going to
scale with that
at least within reason don't make it 5x5
pixels that would be a weird game
and i guess really quick let's go over
what we have
all the way at the top we are importing
pie game and cis and settings
pie games should be obvious but since we
need all the way down here to close the
game properly other than that we are not
using it
after the imports we are creating a
class called game inside of that we have
an init and a run method
most of the game is going to run inside
of the run method in here we have the
game loop and this one is checking right
now if we are closing the game here and
then we are getting delta time and we
are updating the game
besides that in the init method we are
creating a display surface we are
creating a clock and we are also
initiating pygame so all things
considered a very simple class
and finally all the way at the end we
are checking if we are in the main file
then we are creating an object from the
class and then we are calling the run
method
and this run method contains the loop
that contains our game
so with that we have the main setup
although there's one more change that i
would like to make and that is if i run
the game again
in the top left we have a window title
and right now it says pygame window
which doesn't feel good so i want to
change that one and this could be a
really good exercise for you what i want
you guys to do is to change the title of
the window and if you want to code along
pause the video now and try to figure
this one out yourself
after we are creating the display
surface we have to call pygame dot
display dot set underscore caption
and in there we can type in the name
in my case i want to name the game
sprout land
after the asset pack
although you could name it whatever you
want and if you run out of this now you
can see in the top left we have
sproutland this feels much better
although granted a very small change
but all right with that we have our
setup now if none of the things i've
just talked about make any sense check
out my introduction to pygame this one
is going to explain all of this in much
more detail and if you are lost already
the rest of the tutorial is just going
to get harder so definitely get ready
for it
now there is one more thing that we do
have to start thinking about because
later on the game is going to become
quite complex and i want to keep the
basic main.pie as clean as possible it
shouldn't really do too much
as a consequence inside of this while
loop i want to run another object and
this object actually contains the level
let me actually implement it and then
you see in a second what i mean
basically what i want to do is i want to
create a new file and this one i want to
save as level dot
pi
for this level i want to import pi game
and from
settings import everything
and this level is going to be a class so
class
level
and this class level is going to have
one method that i'm going to call run
this one itself and delta time because
we need delta time available inside of
our game to make everything frame rate
independent
and inside of this i want to for now
just print run game
and this is all we need
in main.pi
i want to from level import level
and inside of the init method of the
class i want to create an attribute
level that is going to be the level
and now inside of my run method of the
game
before i update the display i want
self.level.run
that way we are always calling this run
method here
although don't forget this one needs
delta time the one we have gotten here
if you don't know what delta time is
it's a bit more technical but i've made
a whole video on it so check this one
out you basically are going to need it
to follow along for this video so well
it is getting quite complex
unfortunately there's no way around it
if i run all of this now
we can see run game in the bottom left
so we are continuously updating
this method here and this means we can
run the entire game inside of it
which is helping considerably to keep
the entire game clean and organized and
for a project of this size this is
really important
now before i'm finishing this section
there are a couple more things that i do
want to do first of all when we are
creating this class i want to run a
dunder init method
and in here first of all i want to
create another attribute for the display
surface
in this one i'm getting with
pygame.display.get
underscore surface
this display surface is the same as this
self.screen here
and this allows the level to draw
straight on the main display that we are
going to display to the player which
makes organizing the entire thing much
easier
and let me add comments here to make all
of this a bit easier to follow let's
call it
get the display
surface
now besides that we need sprite
groups
and for now i just want to create one
attribute that i call all sprites
and this is going to be
pygame.sprite.group
groups are a key feature of pygame and
they help us to draw and update any kind
of sprite in the game and sprites is
what you use to basically do anything in
pygame so our player is going to be a
sprite any kind of tree or plant is
going to be a sprite and none of this
works without a group
in my case what i want to do inside of
run i first of all want self.display
surface dot fill
with a black color so we don't
accidentally see the previous frame
after that i want self dot all sprites
dot raw
and in here we need the surface we want
to draw on and in my case i want to draw
on the display surface
meaning this is what we have to pass in
here
i can just copy it and paste it in here
and besides that i also want self dot or
sprites dot update
now this method we are not going to use
for now but later on this is what
updates all of the sprites inside of it
like the player for example
but now back in main.pie i can run all
of this and we cannot see any change
and that is because we haven't really
made any changes to the logic of the
game although if you want to see
something
you could change this black to something
like red
and now we have a red background
although i want to keep this black
and there we go
so with that we have a basic setup so
let's get started with the player
now the player is going to become quite
complex so i'm going to do all of this
over multiple steps
but we do have to get started somewhere
so let's create a really basic player
here we are back in the code and for the
player i want to have a separate python
file
meaning i'm going to create a new one
and save it as player.pie
just as before we have to import
game and also from settings import
everything
once we have that i want to create a
class
layer
and this one needs to inherit from
dot pygame.sprite.spry because it is
going to be a sprite
in here we need a dunder init method and
this one eventually is going to have a
lot of parameters although for now all i
want is self
then i want a position and then i want
the group the sprite is supposed to be
part of
and the first thing we have to do inside
of the indent method is called super and
dunder init
and in here we have to pass in the group
that way as soon as we are creating an
instance of this class the object is
going to be inside of this group which
is super handy
besides that we will need self dot image
this is what the sprite is going to look
like and this needs to be some kind of
surface
now later on we're going to import a lot
of surfaces but for now we don't really
have that available as a consequence i'm
going to create a plane surface
and this i get with pygame dot surface
this one is going to need a width and a
height
and the numbers here don't matter since
we are going to change them anyway but
let me go with 64 by 32
now this image right now is going to be
completely black and since we are
putting this on another black surface as
we can see in the level we are not going
to see anything
you change that i want to fill the image
with a color let's go with green
finally we are going to need a self dot
rectangle and this one would take care
of the position
this rectangle we create with
self.image.get
underscore rect and in here as the
argument we have to pass in where we
want to place it and i want to place the
center of this rectangle wherever the
position is
and this position we are getting from
the parameters
with that we have a very simple player
spread class
now we just have to use it and this is
going to happen inside of level
in here i want from player import player
to keep everything organized inside of
the level i want to create a setup
method this one itself as always and in
here we are going to create an attribute
called self dot player and this is going
to be an instance of the class player
the player we have created here
and this player is going to need two
arguments the position and the group
so let me copy both of them
and paste them in here
for now the position is going to be
completely random but we are going to
need a tuple with an x and a y position
in my case let's go with 640 and 360 the
middle of the screen
besides that we need a group and the
group here is self dot or sprites a
group we have created earlier on and now
we're just passing it in here
we are nearly done the last thing that
we have to do is to actually call the
setup method and this happens inside of
the init method so in here self.setup
and now we should be able to see
something so back in main.pi i am going
to run my code and we can see we have a
green thing
although i realized i confused the width
and the height
so back in my player this should be 32
for the width and 64 for the height
that is looking much better
so now we can see something but we
cannot interact with anything
which means inside of the player
i want to get
some kind of input
and don't forget self that one is really
important
now to get all of the available keys
that are being pressed we need pygame
dot key dot
get underscore
rest
this one is returning a list with all of
the keys that are potentially being
pressed and this i want to save in a
variable let me call it keys
and this list i can access with for
example via keys and then square
brackets
and now
pi game has a couple of predefined names
for example for the up arrow we need k
up
and if that is the case for now let me
just print
up
all that is left to do now is to figure
out when to call this input method here
and for that
we will need an update method then
itself and delta time
how this is going to work is
inside of level we have our all spreads
group and this all spreads group has a
draw and an update method the update
method is the really important part
right now
because this one calls the update method
on all of the children
meaning effectively what is going to
happen is that this update method here
calls this update method
as a consequence
for the level or the group more
specifically we have to pass in
delta time as well the delta time we get
from the parameters here and this delta
time we get all the way at the beginning
inside of main
in just a bit this is actually going to
become useful
but now inside of the player
all we have to do is call self dot input
and this should be working so now if i
go back to my main.pi run all of this
and now if i press up in the bottom left
you can see up
which means i get some input
all we have to do now is to cover the
other directions and then we should be
good to go
and the usual system works like this
if we're not pressing up
then i want to check if keys and pygame
dot k underscore down so we are pressing
the down button and if that is the case
i want to print down for now
and with that we have up and down
besides that let me copy
all of this
i also want to check for right
and i want to check for left
and then obviously the text has to be
right
and it should be left
and with that if i run main.pi
we get left right up and down all of the
four directions
what we now have to figure out is how to
translate all of this into actual
movement
and for that we need a few more
attributes let me put it all the way in
the net method with a comment let's call
it movement attributes
and the ones before let's call them
general setup
for the movement i want to have first of
all self.direction
and this is going to be a vector so
pygame.math.vector2
and this vector is going to have an x
and a y part
depending in which way the player should
move so for example if x is 1 then the
player should move to the right
and by default this vector 2 is supposed
to be empty so it should have 0 and 0.
and this is the default value so i can
just leave it like this
and all that we are going to do inside
of here is change this direction so
basically inside of keys for up i want
to set self.direction
dot y
two
minus one
this i can now copy
and do it four down this one is just
going to be one
for right
we are targeting x
and this one is going to be positive one
and left is going to be
x being negative one
and with that we have the four different
directions
although now we do have a problem and
let me isolate the vertical directions
just to illustrate what the problem here
is right now
later on
we are moving the player in whatever
this direction is pointing at so for
example if y is negative 1 we want to
move up
and this is what we are getting in here
the problem is
in this setup right now once we press up
once
direction.y is always going to be
negative one even if we release the
button and this is obviously not great
because once you move up once the player
never stops moving up which well we have
to change
this fortunately though is very easy to
change because all we have to do is add
another else statement
and let me copy the direction here
because now the direction should be zero
which means now if we're pressing up the
direction of y is negative one
if we are pressing down direction is
positive one and if we are pressing
neither then direction.y is zero so
we're not moving in the vertical axis at
all
and that is all we need here so i can
remove the white space and for the
horizontal axis i have to do the same
thing so in here self.direction.x
is going to be zero
and with that we have our basic
direction what i can do now at the end
of all of this i can print
self.direction
and now in main.pi if i run all of this
and i can have the different directions
inside of my vector this is working
really well
there are two more attributes that we
need to make all of this work the first
one i always call self.pos and this is
also going to be a vector
so let me copy this one here and now we
have another vector
now if you are familiar with pygame you
probably always store the position
inside of the rectangle however the
problem with this approach is that a
rectangle always stores the position as
an integer
but if we want to use delta time so this
one here to move everything in a frame
rate independent way we are very often
getting floating point values which
wouldn't work here at all as a
consequence i am going to store the
position
inside of a vector and this is going to
be what self.pos is for
and this is also what we are going to
move and then at the end we are going to
update the rectangle depending on where
the position is
all of that is going to make much more
sense later on but for now for the
starting position of self.pause i want
self.rect.center
finally i want
self.speed and this is just going to be
how fast the player is
i put this at 200 but just choose
whatever you think looks good
and with that i can get rid of this
print statement here and add another
function or one method and this one is
going to be move and here we need self
and delta time
and essentially what i want to do in
here i want to move myself.pause and how
i want to move it is by getting myself
dot direction
multiplied by self dot speed
multiplied by delta time
and after i have done that i want to set
self.direct.center
to self.poss
and now
after the input if i call self.move
with deltatime
we should be having a moving player so
let's try and run main.pi
and i can move around this is working
really well
and this is also frame rate independent
and this is why this entire system is
really important by using delta time
again check out my video on it if you
want more detail
it does get a bit more technical but if
you didn't do this
and change the frame rate for example in
this self.tick you could set the frame
rate for example with 60 or you could
set a thousand or you could set 10.
with this setup the frame rate doesn't
matter but if you didn't do it then the
movement would be faster or slower
depending on how the frame rate is which
would be a massive problem
all right in this case
we have our basic movement
now there's one more important thing
that we have to do and that is inside of
this move method if i run the code again
if i move left and right or up and down
i have one speed however if i move in
the diagonal direction like this the
player moves noticeably faster and that
is a problem you can see it pretty well
here
now why is that happening and let me
draw on the screen to explain
if the player is only moving in one
direction let's say the player is moving
to the right like this
at a speed of 1. that's not the actual
speed but 1 is a very simple number to
use
and if we only move up we are also going
to have a speed of 1. this is what we're
getting from direction
the problem now is if we're combining
these two numbers we are getting a
different kind of length
so let me rearrange the drawing a tiny
bit and let's say i want to move by one
unit to the right and by one unit up
then the actual distance i am going to
move is going to look like this
and the distance of this
length here is what we are getting from
pythagoras theorem
it is 1 square plus 1 square and then we
are taking the square root of all of
this
the result in this case would be
something like 1.4
and this result means that if we move
diagonally the player would move about
40 faster than if we just move left or
right or up or down
which obviously is going to be a problem
so we have to adjust for that
and the way you adjust for that is
called
normalizing a
vector
and normalizing a vector basically just
means that well we're making sure the
direction of the vector is always one
and this is an inbuilt function into
pygame so you don't have to think about
it too much all we have to do is get
self.direction
and we have to assign it to
self.direction.normalize
don't forget to call it
and we are nearly done
the last problem we have is that we can
only normalize a vector if the vector
has a length and this should make sense
i guess to illustrate what this one is
doing is let's say we have a vector of 1
and 1.
what normalize would now do is convert
these two numbers so that the vector
overall has a length of 1
which in this case would get us the
numbers something like 0.7 and 0.7
i can actually demonstrate this a bit
better so let me print a vector after we
are normalizing it so now i want to
print self.direction
and run all of this again
and we are already getting an error that
we cannot normalize a vector with the
length of zero and this should make
sense
for normalized to work pygame needs to
know in what direction the vector is
pointing but if the vector is 0 and 0 it
doesn't point in any direction so
normalize wouldn't work
but this we can fix quite easily all we
have to do is check if the vector has
any kind of length and this we get with
self dot direction dot
magnitude
don't forget to call it and if this is
greater than zero only then do we want
to do all of this
and now let's try it again if i move
left and right we have a direction of
one if i move up and down it is one as
well but now if i move diagonally it's
0.7 or negative 0.7 and this is
important to keep the speed constant
and all right i hope that makes sense
there is just one more thing that i want
to do before we finish off this part and
that is later on
i have to work with these two lines more
to implement the collision mechanics and
for that i have to separate
these two lines into the horizontal
movement
and into the
vertical movement
so first of all i don't want to update
the entire position vector i only want
to update for the horizontal part the x
dimension
so for example instead of updating
position by itself i only want to update
x
and as a consequence we have to update
the other vector as well and update the
rectangle 2 and this could be a really
good exercise for you to finish off this
section so if you want to code along
pause the video now and try to update
the vector and the rectangle
and see how far you get
for position.x we don't want to get the
entire direction vector instead i only
want to get x of the direction
self.speed and delta time can remain the
same
then for the rectangle i don't want to
set the center i want to set the center
x
and then this should be self.pos.x
and with that we have the horizontal
movement now i have to copy all of this
give me some white space and paste it in
here
and now i basically have to switch
all of these x's to a y
and there we go the result in terms of
if i run main.pi again we are not going
to see a difference
but later on for the collision
we do want to have control over the
horizontal and the vertical movement
individually
but this i will talk about in much more
detail later on for now we have a pretty
solid setup
in this section we're going to import
the player graphics and there's quite a
lot of stuff that we have to import
let me actually
open the folder here we go and inside of
graphics we have the character and then
here we have all of the different
animations for example down is the down
movement and here we have the player
walking down
and well we have to import all of these
different animations
now you could do all of this by hand and
it would be possible but not really
practical because there are way too many
animations
fortunately you don't have to you can do
all of this with python to automate the
entire process so let's have a look at
all of this
here we are back in the code and i want
to work inside of the player and let me
minimize all of the methods so things
are a bit easier to read
for the import i want to add another
method let's call it import
assets
this one itself and nothing else and
inside of here
i basically want to create a dictionary
called self dot animations and this
dictionary
is going to have a ton of key value
pairs for example one key would be up
and this would be up walking
and then the value associated with this
key would be a list with a bunch of
surfaces that correspond to the up
movement
now for that
i have this is something you do have to
copy from the notes this is looking like
this here are all of the different
states the player could be having
we have up down left and right these are
the movement ones then we have all of
those with idle
then with the whole the x and the water
these are all of the animations
and these also correspond if i open the
folder again
here we have all of the different states
and therefore the name corresponds with
the key of this dictionary so we have
down here and we have down here this is
really important
because what this allows us to do
is i can do for animation in self dot
animations dot
ease
don't forget to call it
and in here first of all i'm going to
need a full
path
and the full path is basically i have to
go up one folder then i have to go to
graphics and then i have to go to
character
and don't forget another forward slash
and then i have to add the animation
because the animation name is also the
folder name
let me demonstrate what this means
here is the file setup again and right
now we are working inside of the player
and from there we have to go up one
folder to the project then we go to
graphics then we go to character and now
we have to select all of these different
folders
which is what we're doing with this line
here along with the for loop
and now essentially all i want to do is
get
myself.animations dictionary
target
one
of the key value pairs
and then i have to actually import all
of the surfaces now this i'm going to do
in a separate folder that i called
import folder
and this one is going to need the full
path so it knows what to import
and this import folder i generally put
in a separate file because it's quite a
handy one to reuse so let me create a
new file that i want to save as support
dot pi
and in here we need a function called
import
folder
and this one needs a path as a parameter
but nothing else
and this is what the player so inside of
the player
i want from
support import
everything
so now we have to create this file here
and let me add a bit of white space
and now we can work on it first of all i
want to create what i always call a
surface list and this by default is
going to be empty
and in here we're going to store all of
the surfaces and this is also what we
are going to return at the end of this
function
so now we just have to figure out how to
actually access the folder and for that
we need a specific module
is we have to import but it comes with
python we need from os import walk
and walk allows you to walk through
different folders
let me actually demonstrate what it does
so for let's call it folder in
walk and then we have to pass in the
path
and that is the path we are getting from
the parameters and we're just passing it
through
and i guess in here let me just print
what we get the folder
and now since we're calling this inside
of the player
we just need to make sure inside of the
init method
all the way at the beginning this is
really important
i want to self dot import assets
and this has to be all the way at the
top of the indent method because later
on
when we create the image we need this
self animations dictionary
but now if i run out of this
we are getting a ton of different things
at the bottom
and this is
what work does
it basically returns a list
with all of the contents of the folder
for example the first folder here is the
up folder this one doesn't have any
subfolders and inside of this folder we
have a couple of files they are always
called 0 1 2 and 3.
they all have the same name but they are
different files
and this is what we want to use to
import things now keep in mind a really
important thing here is that all of
these are just names we're not actually
importing anything for pygame we are
just going through a folder and looking
at all of the file names but this is
something we can definitely work with
now first of all since this walk is
returning a couple of things that we
don't need
we can unpack this quite a bit
so the first one we get is the folder
name
the second thing we get is the
always a list of subfolders and the
final thing we get is the actual content
let's call it image files
now folder name and subfolder i just do
not care about so i'm going to replace
the folder name and the subfolder to
underscores
that way i indicate that i don't care
about them
so now let me print the image files and
let's run main.pi again
and now all i get is a list with names
of images and this is what i really care
about
once i have that i need another for loop
because remember image files is another
list so i need four let's call it image
in img files
and now let's keep on printing things if
i now print the image and run this again
i am always getting the name of the
image for each file now this right now
is a bit confusing because the name of
each individual image is fairly
repetitive but these are all different
files in different folders
so all we have to do now is to convert
all of this into a full path
so
now i have to do three things to finish
off this function first of all i need a
full path
and this full path is going to be the
path we already have that's a path to
the folder and then we have to attach
the name of the image itself
after we have that i can create an image
surface so this is the inbuilt pie game
surface that we actually want to create
and once we have that surface i want to
get my surface list and append
wow that is misspelled
i want to append the
image
surface
meaning we have to get the full path and
the image surface
and this i think could be a really good
exercise for you
try to combine the path to the folder
and the image to get the full path and
then for the image surface you have to
import pygame and then use the full path
to import one specific surface so pause
the video now and try to figure this one
out yourself
ready for default path
i want to get the path itself and this
is getting me my folder and to that i
want to add the image remember the image
is just the name of the file not the
actual image
now this would almost work let me
actually comment out these other two
lines and let me print
the full path you might already guess
what the problem with this here is if i
run this
we have the name of the folder let me do
this all the way at the top so up here
for example is the name of the folder
and then 0.png is the name of the file
this is a really good start but we do
need a slash to separate the two
meaning in here
besides the image
we have to add
e
slash
and now if i run this again
we have the whole path towards this one
specific image
so i can remove the print statement and
now i can actually use this full path to
import an image as a surface now for
that to work obviously i need pi game
and what i want to do in here is
pygame.image.load
and now i need the full path
although important here you also have to
add convert alpha
that way we are converting this image to
something that's easier to work with in
pi game as a consequence our code is
going to run much faster now i can
uncomment the append line and we should
be good to go
back in my player
after i've run this for loop i want to
print self dot animations
and let's see what we get
that is looking pretty good we are
getting a dictionary
with a key and a ton of surfaces as the
values now we don't know what each
individual surface looks like but i'm
pretty confident that this is going to
work
all we have to do now if i minimize this
method here
is when we are creating the image i have
to pick one of these surfaces now for
that we need a few more attributes to
make all of this work efficiently
and the way i approach this is i add two
more attributes the first is self.status
and this could for example be up or it
could be down or it could be something
like down x if you want the downwards x
animation
but for now let's keep to down actually
down idle is a good one i suppose
besides that we need what i call the
frame
index
and this by default is going to be 0.
now the frame index is going to make
much more sense once we are doing the
animations in the next bit
for now don't worry too much about it
how we are going to use all of this is
instead of creating a plain surface
i want to get myself dot animations this
is a dictionary with key value pairs
where each key is going to be accessed
via the status
meaning
inside of this i want to access the key
value pairs with self dot status
and this list i am accessing with self
dot frame index
and now i can get rid of the image fill
and we should be seeing the player let's
try
and there we go we have
one frame of the player
now since we don't have animations yet
this doesn't look too impressive but
well what you can do now for example
this could be down
x
and let's try this one there we have the
first frame of the x animation
this could also be
let's say
left
water
and
then we get this kind of animation here
or well it's not an animation it's just
a surface but we do have a very good
start
in this section we're going to animate
the player
now for that we are going to need quite
a bit of logic
so let's go through it one by one
here we are back in the code and i want
to keep on working in the player now for
the animations to work there are two
things we need first of all
inside of
the self.animations dictionary we have
to go through the list of surfaces
because they are the animation
and this is actually a fairly simple
method this we can start with in just a
second
the much more complicated bit is
getting the self.status so we have to
know if the player is moving or idling
or using the x or the water or the hoe
and this is going to determine what
animations we need getting the status is
quite a bit more complicated but let's
start with the actual animation that one
is actually quite simple
i first of all have to create another
method let's call it animate this one
itself and it also needs delta time
and basically what i want to do in here
i want to get myself dot frame index
and increase it in my case i want before
multiplied by delta time
and then after that i'm going to get
myself dot image
so what the sprite actually looks like
and i set this to self dot animations
i get myself dot status
and then i get myself dot frame index
the way you have to think about it let
me open the folder again and let's say
for down inside of down we have four
different images zero one two and three
and we are using self.frame index to go
through them so we have first zero then
one then two and then three
and all i am really doing is i am
increasing self.frame index to pick up
all of these numbers that's literally
all that's happening here
however there are two major problems
here
number one
is that we can only ever take the index
with an integer
but this operation here is going to
return a floating point number as a
consequence this self.frame index has to
be converted to an integer which is very
easily done
besides that the other problem is
that each animation has a finite amount
of frames for example down has four
frames inside
however this line here is going to be
very quickly on a higher number than
four
so we have to make sure that we are
always looping through this and this we
are doing in an if statement if self dot
frame index
is greater or equal
than the length of self dot
animations and in here once again i need
self dot status
if that is the case i want to set self
dot frame index back to zero
so what this one does if i open the
folder again
and let me try to get everything on the
screen
something like this looks good
we are basically starting with
self.frame index being zero which is
getting us this first image here
after that we are increasing the frame
index by a certain number
and then down here we're getting the
integer of that number so at some point
this is going to be one this is going to
be two and this is going to be three
after that we're going to end up with a
number larger than 3. so we are going to
be somewhere down here
which would be causing an error and for
that we have this line here
this one is making sure that this
doesn't happen and instead we're moving
back to zero
and with that we have proper animations
all that's left to do now is to actually
call it so inside of update all the way
at the end i want self dot animate
don't forget to pass in delta time in
here
and now if i run this
now the watering animation isn't great
but the animation for down
does look much better so
there we go this is down movement if i
just move down this is already looking
pretty good
and what i actually want to start with
is down idle
if i run this now there we go we have
the player idling and looking straight
at us this is looking really good
so
this was the easy bit now we have
animations
the one thing we now have to figure out
is
how to set this self.status to capture
all of the different animation states
and there are quite a few different
states we have to account for
all of these
the really easy ones we can get in input
because in here if we are for example
pressing up we know that the player is
moving up which means in this we can set
self dot status
to something like up
then i can copy this and change this to
down copy it again
and change it to right and copy it one
more time
and change it to
left
and with that we already have the
walking directions so now if i start all
of this
i can move left right up and down and we
already have some very basic animations
that look pretty good
really good start
besides that let me minimize input
i want to check if the player is idling
so if we go for example from moving up
and we stop moving
then i want to switch to up idle
which in practice means i have to add
underscore idle to the status of the
player
and to do all of that i want to create
another method
let's put it below input
in here i want to get
stat test
needs self and nothing else
and in here
i want to check
if the player is not moving
then i want to add underscore idle to
the
status
and again if you want to code along this
could be a really good exercise for you
so try to figure this one out yourself
and see how far you get
if you want a tip this should be doable
in two lines of code
first of all we have to figure out if
the player is moving or not and this we
have actually already done this happened
inside of move
because we know if
self.direction.magnitude
so the length of the direction vector if
that is zero we are not moving so i can
just copy it
minimize the move method
and now
if the magnitude is equal to zero
then i know the player is not going to
move
which is covering the first bit let me
put it at the top here
besides that i have to add underscore
idle to the status
which
in a very simplified way would just be
self.status plus equal underscore idle
and don't forget this is supposed to be
a string
all we are really doing for the status
here is we are manipulating different
strings to represent the status of the
player
that's literally all it is
now this is a good start but it would
cause a problem really really quick
let me actually demonstrate so after i'm
getting the input and before i am moving
or animating i want to get
self.get status
and now if i run main.pi
we're getting an error that we have a
key down idle and idle
and basically what happened here is that
if the player is not moving python keeps
on adding underscore idle towards the
status
we're not stopping at one we're adding
more and more and that way we're getting
an error so we have to make sure that we
only ever have a single underscore idle
in the status
which we can get very easily all we need
is self dot status
dot split
and i want to split wherever we have an
underscore and then pick the index 0.
this one here is going to return a list
and the first item of this list is
always going to be the status so this
would be up down left right and so on
and only to that i want to add the
underscore idle that way we will only
ever have a single idle inside of any
kind of status
and this i want to assign i don't want
to add it to the status
and now
the player is idling and if i move
downwards we are walking this also works
with up it works with left
it works with right and this is looking
really good
so now we have some basic animations
that are definitely improving already
so let me get rid of the comments here
and
we have the first bit covered
the other bit we need is the tool use
i guess let me add general comments here
to make this a bit easier to follow
let's call this the movement
actually the idle is better
now for the tool used the code is
getting quite a bit more complex because
besides get status we also have to add
the input and we have to be able to
select different kinds of tools
so
let's do all of this in a separate
section
so let's work on the tools for this to
work we need a few parts that
interconnect quite a bit
so
well let's jump right in and let's have
a look at all of this
once again here i have main.pi and i
want to keep on working inside of player
and specifically i want to work inside
of the init method and in here i want to
add another section let me call this one
tools
and for now i want to add one more
attribute that i call selected
pool
and this could for example be an x
it could be a hoe or it could be water
short for watering can
i guess for now let's stick with the x
that one is really easy to see
and for now we don't have any way in the
game to change the tool that's going to
be in the next section because i do want
to keep things a bit more organized
but well now that we have the selected
tool i want to go to my input and in
here
besides the directions let me actually
add a comment directions
i want to add another section and let me
call this one tool use
and in here first of all i want to check
if we are pressing a certain key which i
get with if keys and then pygame dot
in my case for the tool i have k space
now basically what i want to do in here
is if this condition is true
i want to run
a timer for the
tool use
so for example if the player is pressing
space then we should have half a second
of tool use being activated in some sort
of timer
and if the timer is active inside of get
status we are always adding underscore x
to the status
now for that we need a timer and this is
not inbuilt into pygame so we have to
make it ourself
and this i'm doing in a separate file
and this one i want to save as timer dot
pi
and here as always we have to import pi
game
after we have that i want to create a
class timer
and this one needs it under init method
in here we need self
we need a duration
and then we need a function that by
default is going to be none
the duration should make sense this one
is really simple it's just how long the
timer is going to be the function is
going to be if we want to execute some
code once the timer has run out
something we are going to see in just a
second but for now don't worry too much
about it
inside of this i want to create some
attributes so duration is going to be
duration
and self dot funk is going to be funk so
we're just capturing the parameters
besides that i want to have two more i
want to have self dot start underscore
time this one is zero
and then i want to have self dot active
and this by default is going to be false
and for this timer we have a couple of
methods
we have activate
we have
deactivate
and we have up
date
and all three will need self but no
other parameter besides that
and let me go through how the timer is
going to work we always start at some
kind of start time 0 by default and this
is what we are getting here
after we have declared that we will
continuously check the time which means
we are checking the time here here here
here here here and so on continuously
throughout
and besides that we also have a duration
and the duration could for example be
let me put it here at 300 milliseconds
and now all we are really going to do is
we are continuously checking if these
red dots
are before or after the 300
meaning once that is the case we want to
run some code so let's implement that
first of all for activate this one is
very simple all i want to do in here is
if the timer is active i want to set
active to
true and besides that i also want to set
self.starttime
to
pygame.time.get underscore ticks
this is really important because this
starting time here doesn't necessarily
have to be zero
we could very well start a timer at some
point in our game
so this zero might be something like
1240
which means we started a timer about one
second into the game we're doing all of
this in milliseconds
and if the timer has a duration of 300
then this number here would be 1540.
so these numbers are all relative it's
really important for all of this to work
now besides that if i want to deactivate
the timer i want to set self.active to
false
and just to be sure self.starttime
is going to be 0.
finally inside of update the actual
timer happens
and this is some horrible spelling there
we go first of all inside of update i
want to have my current time
and this i get with pygame.time.get
underscore ticks
the same line we have used up here the
difference now is that this update
method will be called continuously which
means that this program.time.get
will always get our current time
and basically what i want to check is if
my current time
minus my self dot start time is greater
or equal
than self dot do
ration
for example if my current time is
something like 1500 my start time is
something like 1000
and my duration is something like 300
then the result here would be 500 is
greater or equal than 300 which would be
true so our timer should have run out
now if that is the case first of all i
want to self dot deactivate the timer i
want to run all of this here
besides that in case we have defined a
function we want to run if the timer has
run out
i want to check if self.func so if a
function exists and if that is the case
i want to call self.bank
and with that we have a timer class that
we can use inside of the player now for
that first of all we have to import it
which we do with from timer import timer
and with that covered i want to add
another section let me put it before the
tools and this i'm going to call timers
in here i want to create a dictionary
that i call timers
in here we have a couple of key value
pairs the key is just the name of the
timer let's call this one tool use
and now i can create a timer and let's
say for the tool use i want to have a
duration of 350 milliseconds
and once this has run out i want to call
a function that i called self.use
underscore tool
really important here you do not want to
call this function you just want to pass
it into this class
and this one doesn't exist right now so
we do have to create it let me put it
actually right at the top here so things
are easier to see
so
use
tool
and this one needs self and nothing else
now this use tool for now is not going
to do anything all i want to do is print
let's say self dot selected tool
later on this one is going to do quite a
bit more but for now i just want to
minimize it more importantly for now
inside of the input
i want to get myself dot timers
and in here
the tool use timer the one we created
just a second ago
and this timer i want to activate
and now this we can use inside of get
status
and really all i want to do is if
self.timers
and tool
use
if this one is active
then for now let me print
tool is
being used
and let's try if this one is working
so now if i press space
we get tool is being used so something
is happening but this is looking weird
and it never stops
so we do have to make some adjustments
here
now first of all the one thing i do want
to change is the player should not be
able to move once we are using a tool
which means once
this timer is active the player
shouldn't be allowed to do anything else
and for that i want to indent all of
this one level
and i want to have an if statement if
not self dot timers and tool
use
if this one is active
so only if we are not using a tool the
player is allowed to move around
and to use a tool
we couldn't use a tool if the player is
already using a tool
that should make sense
now besides that i also want to set
self.direction
to an empty vector so
pygame.math.vector2
the reason is think of if the player is
moving to the right and then starts
using a tool here
if we didn't add this line here the
player would just keep on moving to the
right while using the tool which would
be very strange
and we wouldn't be able to stop it
because remember the player is not
allowed any kind of input while we are
using a tool so we have to stop the
player otherwise we would get some weird
results
but once we have that
inside of get status
all i really want to do is update my
self.status
so that i have a string that could for
example be
right
and x
so x is going to be
what we are getting from our selected
tool
could also be whole or could be water
but for now i want to keep it with x
meaning this is going to work kind of
like this line here except now we're
adding a different word
after the underscore
which means this could be a really good
exercise for you
copy this line here and adapt it so you
are incorporating the selected tool let
me minimize the input so we can see it a
bit better
if the timer is active
you are supposed to have the status so
up left down or right plus an underscore
plus the x
all right all you have to do is first of
all copy this line here or this part of
the line so we just have up left down or
right by itself
and to that i want to add
an
underscore
and then i want to add self dot selected
tool
and with that we should be good to go
let's try this one now
and now if i press space
we have something
so we do have an animation the problem
is the animation never stops
which i guess is a start but we do have
to work on it the main reason why this
happens is because we don't actually
update these timers what i forgot to do
is to call this update method
continuously
and to do that let's put all of this in
a separate method although it's going to
be a very short one
let's call it update
timers this one itself and nothing else
as always and then here all i want to do
is for timer in self.timers.values
because remember
we have self.timers as an attribute this
one is a dictionary and then the key is
the name and the value is the actual
timer and this is what we are getting
here
and all i want to do is call
timer.update
and now inside of the update method of
the player i want self dot update timers
and now let's try this again
so now
we have a animation that is very
inconsistent though
and the reason why that is happening
is
let me go back to input
here
we have to add one more line
and that line is going to be self dot
frame index is going to be 0.
the reason we need that is let's say we
have our frame index this could be 0 1 2
or 3.
and essentially what we are doing is we
always go from one to the other to the
other and then we are going back to the
start
when we are pressing space so this line
here we want to play a new animation
the problem is frame index doesn't know
that so when we start this animation we
might already be on frame index being
two and as a consequence we are playing
not the first frame but we are playing
one frame that is already maybe at the
end of the animation which would be
looking very strange
and if we add frame index being 0 this
is being fixed we always start the
animation from the start so now let's
try this again
and there we go
we have
a proper x animation this one looking
quite nice
what you could also do
is replace this x with a hole
and now we have the hole
and you could also change it with water
and if i do that we have the watering
can
so with that we have our different tools
although we are not able to change
between different tools and we also
can't see which tool is currently being
selected
i guess let's work on that in the next
major part
in this part we are going to work on
switching between the different tools
and since we already have timers there
isn't actually that much to do
so let's jump right in and let's have a
look at all of this back in the code i
want to keep on working inside of
player.pi
and now first of all i want to check if
the player is pressing a button to
change the tool this happens inside of
input in here
i want to add another section let's call
it change
tool
and for this one i want to check my keys
again and then here pygame dot k
underscore q
so we are pressing the q button on the
keyboard i couldn't really think of a
better one if you can't find a better
key just go with that
if that is the case i want to do
something
now what that something is going to be
is going to be determined inside of the
init method so right now the selected
tool is always going to be one specific
string but i want to make this a bit
more flexible
and what i want is first of all i want
to have an attribute that is called
tools and in here we have the whole
we have the axe
and we have water
and besides that i want to have a seat
index
and this by default is going to be zero
and then when we select a tool
i am not going to get a string instead i
want to have self.tools
and then self dot
this shouldn't be seed this should be
tool index sorry about that
so i want self.tool
index
and right now since our tool index is
zero we are picking the first element
from this list
and what i basically want to do
inside of this if statement here
is i want to self dot tool index
plus equal one
and after we have that i want to update
myself dot
selected tool
and this is just going to be self dot
tools and then self dot tool index
now this is fine in theory but in
practice this is going to break let's
actually try
so may not pi i want to run it and now
if i press q
we are getting list index is out of
range
the reason is
to us pressing q once might just be
pressing q once
to pygame it looks like we are pressing
q for a certain amount of time and it
keeps on adding this one to the tool
index continuously
i can actually visualize this that is
much better than explaining it so
if i print the tool index and run this
again and if i now press q
we are getting
one two and three
and then we are running out of numbers
and i should get rid of the print
statement let me look for it really
quick
let me comment out this print statement
here and let me just add a pass in here
that way it's a bit easier to see what's
going on if i now press q
we're getting one two and three and then
we're getting an error because we are
trying to use these numbers for indexing
and this list doesn't have that many
indexes
as a consequence we are getting an error
and the problem is that pygame tries to
add more and more numbers
the way around that is we need a timer
that after every time we are pressing
the button we want to wait a couple of
milliseconds
now fortunately we already have a very
good system to work with timers so i
want to create another timer and this
one i call tool
switch
and this one is going to be another
timer
and this one has a duration of 200
milliseconds
there's no second argument because we
don't really want to call a function
after this one is over we just care if
this timer is active or not
once we have that
and
not self thought timers and in here i
want tool
switch
dot active
the player should only be able to change
the tool if we are pressing q and if the
tool switch timer is not active inside
of the if statement the first thing that
we are going to do is self dot timers
and tool
switch and this timer i want to activate
that way we are only ever adding a
single number to this tool index and
we're not doing it continuously
so now let's try this again if i press q
we get 1 we get 2 now we get 3 and we're
getting an error
this error we're getting
because even though now i am only adding
a single number we can still add as many
numbers as we want
but what i want to do instead
is that if we are exceeding
the length of this list
i want to set the tool index back to
zero
so if tool
index
is greater than length of
tools
then i want to set the tool index to
zero
and this could be a really good exercise
for you so if you want to code along
pause the video now and try to figure
this one out yourself this should be
doable on a single line of code although
two would also be doable
alrighty basically all i want to do is i
want to set myself dot tool index
and now i want to get
self.tool index by itself
but
this only if a certain condition is true
and that condition is self dot tool
index
is smaller than the length of self
dot
tools
and if that is not the case
so else i want to set tool index to zero
and now let's try this again
now i can press q we get 1 2 0 1 2 and
so on
and i can never go beyond the length of
self.tools
and now
we already have all of the tools
because remember we are updating our
selected tool and this is what we're
using inside of the status so we don't
have to make any more changes this is
all we need so with that we are able to
change our tool
it wasn't actually so bad or at least i
hope this wasn't too difficult
now while we are here we can go in two
different directions now
we can either work on the overlay or we
can work on the seeds
now i think it's best to start with the
seeds because the seeds work basically
in the same way as the tools do
and once we have that we can create the
entire overlay in one go so let's do the
seats right now
and this is going to be
started inside of the dunder emit method
right below tools and here i want to
have my seeds
and for the seeds i want to have
self-doubt seeds and in here
we only have two we have corn and we
have tomato
then we have
self.seed index and this by default is
going to be zero and then we have self
dot
selected underscore seed
and this is going to be self dot seed
index we are basically doing the same
thing we have done for the tools except
now we are storing all of this in
different attributes
which means now the tool use and the
change tool are going to be very similar
as well
we have a seat use
and we have a change seat part
and those are going to be very similar
compared those two as a consequence this
could also be a really good challenge so
try to copy
those two
to update the seed
if you want to start if the player is
pressing ctrl or left control then i
want to use a seat and if the player is
pressing e then i want to change the
seat
so pause the video now and see if you
can figure this one out
and remember here you are going to need
some more timers
all right let's try it together now
first of all i need two more timers
because i have a tool use i have a tool
switch besides that let me actually
duplicate both of those
i want to have a seat use and a seat
switch
and for the seat use i want to have a
method called use
seat
and you could change numbers here i
really don't care about it
now first of all
i have to create another method just
like use tool i need use underscore seed
needs self and nothing else and for now
let me add pass in here
then i can minimize the function
and now
we can work on duplicating these two
lines
and we are very much duplicating them so
let me copy and paste things
first of all if keys and now we are
checking
k
underscore
and the name for the left control button
is l c t r l
short for left control
if that is the case
i want to activate my seed use timer
and the other two lines i want to keep
as they are
after that i want to copy the if
statement for change tool
and this one is going to be k
e
and not
timer's seat switch
if that is the case i want to activate
my seat switch timer
and now the index here
is going to be
for the seat
so i'm basically replacing tool with
seed and that is all we are going to
need in here
now unfortunately there's no animation
for the seed
so instead what i want to do is i just
want to print
let's say for left control
use seed
and then for change seed i want to print
self dot selected seed so we can tell
what's going on and now let's try
and we're getting an error that i made a
typo somewhere
so inside of the indent method
this method here should be used not used
seed so now let's try this again
and there we go if i press left ctrl we
get use seed
and if i press e we get
either corn or tomato
so this is working really well
and with all of that we have a ton of
different inputs for the player without
too much work actually
so let me remove the print statements
and now i can minimize the input this
one is getting quite chunky
okay i'm quite happy with this section
so in the next section we are going to
work on the overlay so we can tell
what's going on
in this section we're going to create
the overlay which honestly isn't all
that difficult all we essentially are
going to do is put some images on top of
the entire game
and then those images are going to
change depending on what the player has
selected both for the tool and for the
seats so let's jump right in once more i
have main.pi open and i want to create a
new python file that i'm going to save
as overlay dot pi
in here i want to import pi game and
also i need from settings import
everything
and now i want to create a class called
overlay
there is no need for inheritance and i
do need a dunder init method
we need self as always and now we also
need the player because the overlay
needs to know what the player currently
has selected
inside of that i want to have a general
setup in here we need two things first
of all i need self dot display
surface
that is the same thing we have done
inside of the level this way we can draw
straight on the display surface and we
can keep all of this inside of the
overlay class
all we need here is pygame dot display
dot get underscore surface
besides that i want to start a player in
an attribute so self
dot player is going to be player
besides that i need to do some imports
because in here i need self.tools and
self dot seeds
and those are not the same seeds and
tools that the player has instead let me
rename it actually these are all
surfaces more specifically they are
dictionaries with key value pairs
for example one key for the tools could
be x
and then the value would be a surface of
an x
now for that we have to import a couple
of images
let me show you what we are going to
import actually
here is the project folder i want to
look at graphics and inside there we
have overlay inside of that we have x
corn ho tomato and water and this is
what we want to import
now here you could import everything
manually but once again that's not
really a pleasant way to work in well
any programming language so i'm going to
use dictionary comprehension
how that is going to work for the tool
surfaces i want to have a tool
and this is going to be the key and then
i want to have a surface as the value
and this i want to do for tool in
layer dot tools
which means inside of player
i want to look at all of these tools and
from this data i want to create a key
value pair
and the tool can actually remain the
same so if we leave it like this the
tool or the key would be hoe x or water
which is totally fine the one thing we
have to change is the surface
what i want to do in here is
pygame.image.load
and inside of that we need an f string
now to keep things a bit shorter i want
to store the path separately so let me
call it path actually let's call it
overlay path that makes a bit more sense
and all this is is a string we go up one
folder we go to graphics
and then we go to overlay and don't
forget the final forward slash
and this i want to use inside of this f
string so overlay path
after that
i want to look at the tool
so the tool could either be x whole
water or could be one of the seeds
and this is also how each of the files
here are named so this is very handy
finally one important thing don't forget
we are looking at png files also really
important you want to convert
alpha all of this
which makes all of this fairly long but
very easy to work with
and once i have that
i can copy the entire thing
and paste it in here and all i really
have to do is to replace tool
with seed make sure you call this
player.seats
and then this tool should also be seed
but other than that we should be good to
go
let me actually print
tool
surface and
seeds surface just to make sure that
this is working oh actually we have to
create the object from the class first
of all
and this happens inside of level
so in level i want from
overlay import overlay
and now when we are creating everything
i want to create self dot overlay
and this is going to be
the overlay class and in here don't
forget we have to pass in self dot
player
now for that to work you have to create
this overlay after the setup method
because inside of setup we are creating
the player
and now once we have that let's run
main.pi
and we are getting an error the name
tool surface is not defined let's have a
look
ah i forgot
self here
now let's try this again and there we go
we're getting
dictionaries with key value pairs that
all look pretty good well i'm very happy
with this
so now we have access
to the player and we have all of the
surfaces that we do need all i have to
do now is to create another method and
let's call this one display
in here we need self and nothing else
and now i want to show the tools and i
want to show the seats
and for this one first of all i need the
tool surface because right now we have a
dictionary with key value pairs but what
we want is one specific surface
we have to select one surface from this
dictionary
and this we get with self dot tools
surfaces
and what i want to select from here is
self dot
player dot
selected
tool
remember here the selected tool could
either be x it could be whole or could
be water
and this is also what we're using as a
key inside of tool surface
and let's actually try so i want to
display this tool
and this i get with
self.displaysurface.lit
and here
i need a surface which is my tool
surface and for now i'm going to place
this at position 0 and 0.
with that covered
i have to make sure i actually call the
display method of overlay and this
happens after we are drawing all of the
sprites
you could just run this line all the way
at the end of the run method so in here
self.overlay.display
and now let's try
and now in the top left i can see my
selected tool and if i change
my selected tool this graphic updates as
well
so this is very nice
the problem is it shouldn't be in the
top left
and for that we have to update these
numbers here
or to have a bit more control i want to
create a tool rectangle
and this one we get with tool surface
dot get underscore rect and in here
since i want the tool to be in the
bottom left i want to place the mid
bottom
and the position here i am storing in my
settings because in there i have overlay
positions
that way it's a bit easier to adjust all
of the settings later on there are a lot
more similar dictionaries in here as
well
so these are the numbers i do want to
use
which is quite simple all i have to do
is i have to get my overlay
positions
let me just double check if i spell this
correctly actually let me copy all of
this
and paste it in here that looks pretty
good
and in here i want to get my tool
and now when i am
using the blit method i want to use my
tool rectangle for the positioning
and now let's run this again and this is
looking really good
and with that all we have to do now is
to copy all of this for the seeds and i
think this could be a really good
exercise for you
basically what you want to do is copy
all of this except now it should be for
the seeds so pause the video now and if
you want to follow along try this one
yourself
just as before
i want to create a seed surface
and this i get with self dot seed
surfaces and in here self dot player dot
selected underscore siege
after i have that for the positioning i
want to get a seed underscore rectangle
and this i get with my seed
surface this should not have an s
and get underscore rect
once again i want to place the mid
bottom
and the position here i can copy it from
the tools
i want to get my overlay positions and
get the key seat
that is going to be this one here
finally all i have to do is self dot
display surface dot
lit
and i want to have my seed surface
and then my seed rectangle
and with that
let's run main.pi and we are getting an
error that i forgot
the square brackets here
now let's try this again and there we go
now on the bottom left we have the seats
and the tools and we can switch between
them this is working really well
and is surprisingly satisfying
all right cool with that we have the
overlay that was all that was needed
now that we have the player we can start
working on the camera and the floor
those two kind of have to come together
because without the floor we wouldn't
see what the camera is doing and without
the camera we wouldn't be able to see
what the floor is looking like in total
and i know i am repeating myself a lot
but for the camera there is a whole set
of logic i will go over the basics but i
have made a whole video on cameras in
detail in pygame so check this one out
if you want to go into much more detail
once again here i have the code and
before i do anything else i want to
close a couple of files we don't need
overlay anymore and we don't need the
timer.pi anymore those two are basically
finished and well we don't have to worry
about them and i do want to keep things
a bit more organized
besides that the level should be right
next to main.pi
because those two files are the most
important ones
and inside level.pi i want to create the
camera this is going to be a separate
class
and let me call it camera
group
and this one has to inherit from
pygame.sprite.group
basically what this one is going to do
or how this one is going to work
instead of putting all of the sprites
into a normal pie game group we're going
to create a special kind of group and
via this group we're going to get the
camera
for that to work though first of all we
have to initiate the
group by itself and this one itself and
nothing else and in here we need the
super
dunder init method
so that the group works by itself
now once we have that i can replace the
group we created like an hour ago
with the camera group and so far
since we have basically created another
group there shouldn't be any difference
meaning if i run main.pi
nothing has changed
which is a good start at the very least
we didn't break anything
but now that we have more control over
what the group is doing we can customize
this thing quite a bit
and one thing you could be doing for
example is get
self.display surface in here as well
with pygame.display.get
underscore surface
that way this camera group can draw on
the display surface straight away
which you could use
by creating a customize draw method and
this one itself and nothing else at
least for now
now the way a normal group draws is
bright so this line here
essentially all that it does is it runs
a for loop with four sprite in self dot
sprites
don't forget to call it for some reason
this is a method
and now in here we are calling
the display surface with blit
and then we are passing in sprite dot
image and sprite dot rect
this is basically all that is happening
inside of a normal group for the draw
method
which is also the reason why every
sprite always needs an image and a
rectangle if you didn't have those you
wouldn't be able to draw the sprite so
they are mandatory
so now that we have a customized draw i
can comment out this draw here and
instead i want to run
self dot all sprites dot customize draw
and let's call it actually let me call
it custom draw that makes a bit more
sense
custom draw that is better
and now if i run this
everything still works just as before
there's no difference
although now we don't have to pass in
the display surface anymore in here
which already is a minor improvement
although not that much of a difference
with that we have a start for the camera
logic although we don't have a camera
yet but well this method is going to
become quite a bit more extensive
although right now we have a problem
because any kind of camera i would
create would be impossible to see
because the background is pure black so
even if we move left or right you
wouldn't be able to see it because it's
well all black
as a consequence we first of all need
some kind of floor so we can see what's
going on
and for that we have to import the floor
now the floor is very simple it is one
big image
if i open the project folder inside of
graphics there we have world and inside
of there we have the ground and i guess
let me open this one all this is is one
big image
and you can see here
we have for example the trader and we
have a whole bunch of objects all the
way over here
and
the rest of the map so all of this stuff
here is really empty
all of this is going to work in detail i
will explain in the next few sections
for now just don't worry about them but
don't worry i didn't make a mistake all
of this is intentional
so let me move this away and this image
we want to import
although for it to work we first of all
need another class to actually use it
inside of pygame
and for that i want to create a new
python file that i want to save
as
let's call it sprites.pi
because in here we are going to have
more than one
and i want to import pygame and from
settings import everything
and for now we just want to create a
very generic class so let me call it
generic and this one is going to be
sprite so pygame.sprite.sprite
in here as always we need the dunder
init method this one itself and besides
that we need a couple of arguments we
first of all need to position
after that we need the surface we want
to import or we want to use
then we want the groups so
this is kind of similar to the player
where we have a position and a group so
where the sprite should start and what
group it should be part of however for
the generic sprite it needs a surface
because we might add different kinds of
images in here
now first of all on here as always you
need the dander indeed method with the
groups inside that is missing something
that's looking better
and now we need self.image and we need
self.rect
the image is just going to be the
surface
which means we're taking the surface
from the arguments and passing it in
here that's all that's going to happen
and for the rectangle we get self.image
dot get underscore rect and now we're
placing the top left wherever the
position is
the position we are again getting from
the arguments and passing it in here
now we just have to figure out how to
use it and this i am going to do inside
of a level
which means first of all i need from
sprites import generic
and now inside of setup
i have to import it by using this
generic class
i want to create an instance of the
generic class and now i need the
different arguments for the various
parameters let me copy them and paste
them in here
and let me use named arguments so this
is a bit easier to see
the position is super easy it's just
going to be 0 and 0.
or the this is terrible formatting
[Music]
let me clean this up a tiny bit
for the surface all we have to do is to
import pygame dot image and load
and now we need the file path which is
one folder up then we go into graphics
then we go into world and then we get
ground dot png
as always don't forget to call convert
alpha on all of this
finally we need the groups and this one
is easy just like for the player we need
self dot all sprites
this one should be working already so
let me try and there we go now we can
see the background and
now we need the camera to see the rest
of the level so right now we can only
ever see the top left of the map which
wouldn't be helpful but this is already
looking much better
however before we can do that there's
one major problem right now the floor
is only behind the player because we are
creating it before we are creating the
player which means if i created the
player
before this generic class and run this
again
we wouldn't be able to see the player
because the player is behind the ground
which is not well good at all
and this leads us to one of the 3d
effects we need for the game if you look
at settings
we have what is called layers all of
this
and this i want to use to draw the
different elements of the map most of
the game is going to happen inside of
main
in here for example we have the player
all of the plants and the trees and
stuff like that
and the ground should be all the way
here
what we are essentially going to do
inside of
this custom draw method we are going to
cycle through
this list
and then draw things one by one meaning
the water will be drawn first then the
ground then the soil then the soil water
and so on and the rain drops all the way
at the end
that way we get a three-dimensional
effect where different things are on top
of other things there's actually going
to be a second three-dimensional effect
but that's going to come later i don't
want to overwhelm you guys
now for all of this to work we first of
all have to assign each sprite
one of these layers
which means right now the sprites
need one layer and the player is going
to need a layer
and let me get started for the player
right below the rectangle i want to
assign what i called z
and z is just going to be layers so the
dictionary from settings
and the player should be on main
so i can just copy it and paste it in
here and now the player has a z position
this means that inside of the game every
single sprite has an x position
we have a
y position and besides that we are going
to have a
z position
x and y are always going to come from
the rectangle here and z is going to be
a separate variable but both of those
work very closely together
now besides that for the sprites we also
have to determine what the z position is
going to be and this might potentially
change
as a consequence i want to have z as a
parameter although here i do want to
have a default parameter
where if we don't get an argument z
should be on the main layer
and don't forget to turn the parameter
into an attribute so self.z is going to
be z
now that being said
for the ground so the ground we are
creating here
the floor is not supposed to be on the
main layer instead
it is supposed to be so z
is supposed to be in layers
and
this key here is called ground
let me copy it and paste it in here
now we have a z position
we just have to figure out how to
actually use it
this is going to happen in here
and this i believe could be a really
good challenge for you
so try to use this dictionary here and
draw elements by the order inside of
this layer's dictionary meaning the
higher the number is the later it should
be drawn
if you want a quick tip this should be a
for loop but pause the video now and try
to figure this one out let's see if we
can do it
the way this is going to work first of
all we have to cycle through the layers
dictionary let's call it for layer in
layers dot values
we don't actually care about the keys
they just don't matter
and all of the drawing is going to
happen inside of this for loop
and all i really want to do is i only
want to draw a sprite so after going
through all of the sprites i want to
check if sprite dot z
is actually the same as the layer the
layer being one of the values of the
layer's dictionary
and only if that is the case
i want to draw this layer
and that should be it let's try
and now i can see my player again
even though the player is being created
before we are creating the floor
which means this logic here is working
just fine cool so with that we actually
already have some sort of camera but not
a real camera yet
let's actually work on it properly now
so for the camera and
once again check out my dedicated video
on camera logic this one is really
important to understand
but first of all what we need here is we
have to create some kind of offset and
this is going to be a vector so
pygame.math.vector2
and how this is going to work think of
this one here is the player and
everything else so all of this stuff
here
is going to be the rest of the map and
how the camera is going to work is if
the player is moving to the right we are
going to shift the entire map to the
left now when i say shifty and time up
to the left i don't mean to actually
move it instead we are going to draw it
in a different position the actual
position doesn't change
which means in practice when we are
doing display surface dot blit
spreader image is going to stay exactly
the same
which means in practice when we are
calling thisdisplaysurface.blit
this one doesn't change the position it
just draws a sprite in a certain
position wherever this rectangle is
going to be but this rectangle you can
move around perfectly
fine and the way i want it to work is by
making it relative to the player
and for that first of all when i do
custom draw i want to look at the player
because this is what the camera should
be following
and now i want to have my offset
dot x and i also want to do this for y
and the logic here let me do it for x
and y together because it's going to be
fairly similar
i want to look at my player.rect.center
and for x is going to be x and for y
it's going to be center y
so right now i am getting the position
of the player
and from that i want to subtract this
green
and then for x this is going to be the
width
and for y this is going to be the height
divided by 2 for both
what that basically means is
the offset is going to be by how much we
are going to shift every single sprite
relative to the player and we have to
figure out by how much we want to move
them
and this logic here ensures that the
player is always in the center of the
camera
if this one here is the player
we always want to have an offset that
points at the top left of the window
which means we want to go half the
screen width to the left and half the
screen width up and then we're ending up
on the point up here this is what we
have to use to draw everything now for
that first of all i want to create an
offset rectangle
and this we get with sprite dot image
dot get underscore rect
and this we get with sprite dot rect dot
copy
and this offset rectangle i actually
want to offset so i want to get the
offset rectangle again and now i want to
move the center by minus equal the
offset
and this offside rectangle is what i'm
going to use to draw the image and now
there's one more thing we need and that
is what i'm calling custom draw
i have to insert the player
fortunately we do have the player inside
of self.player so let me pass it in here
and now let's run all of this
and now if i move around we have a
camera
and this is feeling pretty good we are
definitely making progress
although a lot of stuff is missing right
now and this tends to look a bit weird
but well we're getting there
and i am fully aware that i didn't
really go into detail for this entire
logic so i hope you could kind of follow
along
but if you check out my videos on
cameras this is explaining all of this
in so much more detail so check this one
out if you are interested
the logic here unfortunately gets quite
complex and i don't want this video to
be 20 hours long
but alright let me remove some white
space and then we are basically done for
this part
in this part we are going to import all
of the other elements and we are going
to fake 3d a tiny bit more and i guess
let's go for this one by one and let's
start by importing all of the elements
we have already done this to an extent
but well now we have to do more of that
now there is a tiny bit of theory that i
do have to cover and that is that the
entire game was designed entirely which
is a free program that you can use to
design levels it's really powerful
and i am using another module called
pytmx to import all of this data
now let me go through what all of this
means by looking at tiled here we go
this is all of tiled so in here
i could for example move things around
and
design the level to look slightly
different
and doing all of this took quite some
time there's a ton of things in here so
if you look on the top left there are a
ton of layers that you could be working
with
and well all of this is very complex
and once again i have made a complete
video on all of this so if you want to
have a ton of detail check that one out
i just don't have the time for this
video to go over titled separately all i
am going to do is import all of this
data into pygame
so let's do all of that
once more here i have my python setup
and i want to continue working inside of
level and let me minimize all of the
methods so this is a bit easier to see
and i can minimize the camera group
now first of all i have to import pi tmx
this happens with from pi tmx
dot util underscore pygame
i have to import load underscore pi game
and really important here pitmx you have
to install separately it does not come
with python
so either in the powershell or on the
terminal type pip install pi tmx or pip3
install pi tmx depending on mac or
windows
now this i want to use inside of the
setup method and in here let me add a
bit of white space
first of all we have to load a file
if i open the project inside of data we
have map.tmx
this is what i want to import all of the
data is in here
and this i am loading with load pi game
and in here i need the path to this file
i have to go one folder up then i have
to go to data and in there we have map
dot tmx
and now we have to import a ton of
different things so let's start by
building the house i think this is quite
good to illustrate how this is going to
work
now the house if i go back to tiled the
house
consists of a couple of different layers
let me go through them one by one so if
i hide all of them and zoom in let me
hide all of this as well
we have a house floor
then we have house walls then we have
the furniture at the bottom and then we
have the furniture at the top and all of
these layers we have to import
separately
and really important all of these have
to be on a different layer inside of
pygame
which means back in pygame or the house
we have a couple of different
layers most importantly house bottom is
going to be for the bottom and the rest
of the house is going to be in main and
this is really important
so let's go through it one by one
first of all to access the data i need
to store all of this inside of a
variable let me call it tmx underscore
data and now i can use it
and this has a ton of methods that we
could be accessing the one i want to use
now is called tmx data dot get
underscore layer underscore
by underscore name
and now we need a name of a layer
the one we could be using in here for
example is house furniture bottom
and this if i look at tiled
is this name here house furniture bottom
and what i want to do is to add tiles
after this that way i am getting all of
the tiles inside of this layer and i can
use them inside of a for loop
and
what i'm getting here let me add the for
loop first
so this for loop is going to return a
list that i can unpack right away and
the list consists of x y
and a surface
really quick back in tiled
when i'm only looking at the house
furniture bottom and let me hide
everything else
and this is in house decoration there we
go
in this we have a couple of different
tiles and each tiles is one of these
well little cells inside of a grid i
just want to import
this carpet thingy and this other carpet
thingy here this is all i really want
and each of those is going to have an x
position a y position and then what you
see is the surface this is what we are
importing which means i already have a
class to capture all of this data that
is my generic class
and in here i need a position i need a
surface and i need my groups oh and also
i need the z position first of all for
the position you might be tempted to
just add x and y in here but that
wouldn't be a good idea because this x
and y position is not a pixel position
instead if i return to tiled
and zoom out a bit
there you go
the position we are looking at is the x
and y position on this grid so for
example all the way in the top left this
cell here has the grid position zero and
zero
and the one to the right of it so this
one here is going to have one and zero
but all of these tiles have a size of 64
by 64. so the actual starting position
of this cell here
is not going to be 1 and 0 it is going
to be
64 and 0. we are essentially multiplying
the position by 64 or rather the size of
the tile
and this position we have available in
pie game as well it is inside of
settings all the way at the top we have
the tile size
all i have to do is to multiply x and y
by the tile size
now the surface we already have it is
just a surface we are importing up here
then we need the groups and this one is
also fairly easy because all we need in
here is self dot or sprites
and for z i want to have my layers
and the house furniture bottom
should be
inside of the layer house bottom this
one here
let me copy it and paste it in here
and this should be
all we need
there we go
this should already be working now let's
try
and i do have to walk down a tiny bit
because the house is somewhere down here
there we go there we have a carpet and
it is below the player because of the
layers
that is a really good start
now there's a bit more stuff that i want
to put on this layer and as a
consequence
i'm going to wrap this for loop inside
of another for loop
and what i want to do is four layer in
the list
in here i have
house floor
and then i have the house furniture
bottom
and now
for x and y and surface
is going to be
for the layer
this way i am using the same for loop
for the house floor layer and for the
house furniture bottom layer
now if i try this
we are getting an error because i forgot
the colon so now let's try this
and if i now walk down i should be
seeing the house floor and the carpet
this is looking pretty good
although in here the one limitation is
that this house floor has to come before
the house furniture bottom this house
furniture bottom is only drawn on top of
the house floor because it's being
created afterwards
if we reverse the order here
let me add it like this
then you would not be able to see the
house furniture bottom
let me try it now
and
you can see you well cannot see the
carpet
but we only have two elements here so
this isn't really that much of an issue
this works just fine as it is
with that
we have
two layers out of quite a few
now this entire thing i now want to copy
because there are two more layers that
work in kind of the same way
we have the house walls
and we have the house furniture
top those are going to work in basically
the same way for this line and this line
the one difference is that those two
should be on the main layer
and now let me try
if i now walk to the house
always takes a second
yeah you can see the entire house
right now
it is always below the player but this
we are going to change very soon
but well we have a house admittedly this
setup here could be a bit more elegant
but i don't want to add too many for
loops but you could totally do it if you
want to
there's quite a bit of repetition in
these lines here
alright there is one more thing that we
do need and that is the fence
let me illustrate this entitled
he is entitled and right now everything
is hidden so let me
make most of the stuff visible so we can
see what's going on
the fence i'm talking about is this
fence here this is what i want to import
now
and this is going to work very similar
compared to the house
which means this could be a really good
exercise for you i want you guys to
cycle through the layer is called fence
cycle through this layer and import
the surface with the x and the y
position using the generic class and
this should be inside of its own for
loop
so possibly now and try to figure this
one out
we need for x
y and the surface in tmm
x underscore data
dot get layer by name and the layer we
want to look at is called fence and here
don't forget we need tiles
once we have that we need the generic
class
and in here we need a position we need a
surface we need a group
and we need a layer
or rather a z position
the position is super easy this is the
one we have already done multiple times
let me just copy it from the house so
position this one and surface we also
already have
now for the groups for now we only have
a single spread group so self.all
sprites is going to remain the same
finally for z i do want the fence to be
on the main layer and since that is the
default parameter i can just leave it as
it is as a matter of fact or this line
here i could actually remove layers dot
main because this is what we get anyway
let's do it like this and now let's try
and there we can see the fence this is
looking very nice
righty there are
three more things that we do have to
import we have the water
we have the trees and we have some wild
flowers
and all three of those are going to be
their own class because they are all
slightly different so let's create some
more classes
this is all going to happen inside of
sprite
first of all i want to create a class
called water and this is also going to
be a sprite but the sprite we are
getting from generic which means water
is going to inherit from generic and
since generic is a sprite water is also
going to be a sprite
and in here as always we need it under
init method
and this one needs self it needs a
position
it needs frames not a surface we need
groups and we need z
the major thing about the water is that
the water is going to be animated
and this means we kind of need the same
setup for the animation that we have
seen for the player it's inside of
animate
basically this kind of setup here
so we need a couple of frames like we've
seen in here and then we need an entire
method to loop over all of these frames
and the frames are going to be stored
inside of the method frames
let me add a comment here and let's call
this animation setup in here we first of
all need an attribute with frames and
this is just going to be frames what we
are getting from the parameters
then we need self dot frame underscore
index this is zero by default
and once we have that
we can start with the sprite
setup and in here all we need is this
super
dunder init method
and for this one we need the init method
of the generic class all of these
parameters here
position is what we are getting from the
position from the water and let me use
named arguments here that is a bit
easier to follow i think
for the surface i want to get myself dot
frames and then here self dot frame
underscore index
and this should probably be on multiple
lines otherwise it's kind of hard to
read
for the groups all i want is the groups
i am getting
from the parameters of the water class
and finally for z
all we need here is inside of settings
we have water
this is what i want to pass inside of
the z argument here
and this doesn't animate yet but we do
need a few more things so back a level
let's start creating this thing
and first of all as always i need this
kind of line here so let me just copy it
the name of the layer we need here is
called water
and what i want to do is to create a
water tile although right now we don't
have water available inside of level
meaning besides generic i want to import
water
for this one we need all of these
parameters
position is going to remain basically
the same i can just copy things and
paste them in here
the other easy one is the groups because
once again we only have a single group
so far so this is always going to be all
sprites
the problem we have is we need the water
frames
which if you open the project folder
again are inside of graphics and in
there we have water and we have four
different frames and these we want to
animate
but for that we have to import all of
them
fortunately we already have a function
that imports an entire folder and
converts it into surfaces the same thing
we have used for the player so we can
reuse all of this
for that to work though we first have to
make it available inside of level.pi
which means from support i want to
import everything
and now i can use import folder
and for the water i want to have some
water frames
and this is going to be input folder
and the file path we need here
is one fold up then we have graphics and
then we have water
and these water frames we want to use in
here
and now let's see if this is going to
work already
so if i move over this side there is
going to be some water this is looking
really good
and if i move further down we should be
able to see some more water
there we go so now we have water except
it's all static so now we have to
animate it
that is going to happen inside of
sprites and in here
i want to create an animate function or
well method in itself and delta time
i think we could do another really good
exercise so like for the player
we have to create an animate function so
try to create this one for the water
basically what you have to do is copy
the thing you have seen for the player
and then make sure you're actually
calling it
so try this one yourself and see if you
can figure it out
i think a really good way here is to
look at both of the files next to each
other it's a bit hard to see but i hope
you get the idea we are basically going
to copy all of this so first of all we
need self dot frame index
and we want to increase this by a
certain number for the water i went with
5 and multiply this by delta time but
this 5 here is entirely subjective play
around with this
after that
i want to check if myself dot frame
index is greater or equal than the
length of self dot
frames if that is the case i want to set
self dot frame index to zero
finally i want to update self dot image
and this is going to be
self dot frames and in here don't forget
we need an integer of self dot frame
index
and that is all we need all we have to
do now is to figure out when to call
this animate method and this we are
doing inside of the update method
in here we need self and delta time
and all i really have to do in here is
call self dot animate and pass in delta
time
technically you could just add all of
these lines here and paste them inside
of the update method
it would work perfectly fine but i think
this is a bit more organized it well
it's entirely up to you
but now we should be having animated
water let's try and let's walk to the
water
and there we go we have animated water
this is looking quite nice
so i can minimize the water and now we
can work on the next kind of sprite
i guess a really easy one would be the
class wild
laurer
and this one like the water has to
inherit from generic
and in here we need a dunder init method
and this one needs self it needs a
position it needs a surface and we need
the groups
and after that we need a super and a
dunder init method and once again
we need
these three parameters
we don't need z because all of the
wildflowers are supposed to be on the
main layer
and the wildflowers for now are going to
stay just like that we're not going to
make any more changes although later on
they are going to change a tiny bit
which is why we need a separate class
but now that we have them inside of
level.pi i want to import the wild
flower
and this one
if i copy these two lines here
i want to look at the layer called
decoration
let's have a look at tiled how this
looks
the layer i am looking at is this one
here decoration
and in there if i hide and unhide it
it's all of these small elements inside
of the foresty area
and these i want to import
now there if you look at the layers in
the top right
these are slightly different compared to
the tile layers we have already seen
basically these are objects and this we
can move around easily
whereas these with the square icon are
all tiles
but again check out my original video it
explains all of this in much more detail
the difference honestly isn't that bad
i shouldn't have actually copied this
line instead what i should have been
doing is for obj in tmx data dot get
layer by name
and the layer we are looking at is
called decoration this one doesn't
change
and now in here we are getting an obj
and this obj has an x it has a y and it
has an image and this one is the surface
so this is what we are going to use
and now i want to create a wild flower
and in here let me copy the parameters
we need we need a position we need a
surface and we need the groups
for the position we need obj.x and obj.y
and those are actual pixel positions so
we don't have to multiply them with
anything
for the surface we need obj dot image
and for the groups once again we need
self dot
all sprites
let's run this again and now we can see
a whole lot more stuff on the map
this is already starting to look much
better
finally we are going to need some trees
so i'm going to create a class called
tree
this one is also going to inherit from
generic
and in here we need a dunder init method
with self we need a position we need a
surface we need the groups
and besides that i also want to have a
name of the tree
why that name is going to matter let me
visualize all of this entirely
inside of tiled here you can see all of
the trees and they all have a name the
name you can see here so a tree could be
called small or large
and this is what i want to use for the
name that way i can tell if a tree is
going to be small or large that's
basically all it is
although later on this is also going to
determine where the apples are going to
be on the tree
for example for a larger tree we would
have this entire surface to place apples
or a small tree we would only have this
surface here
and inside of here i want to have a
super dunder init method
and this one is going to need a position
a surface and the groups
all of these we are getting from the
parameters so we can just leave it as it
is
although later on the trees are going to
become quite substantially more
extensive
but for now all we have to do is
or obj in tmx data.get layer by name
and the layer i am looking for is called
trees
and in here i want to create a tree
although first of all i do have to
import it with three
and the arguments we need let me copy
the parameters
the position we can just copy from the
wildflowers this one here
so position is covered
the surface is going to be obj.image
for the groups once again
we have self dot all sprites
and for the name this one we get with
obj.name
[Music]
and now if we run this
here you can see a huge amount of trees
and this is looking really nice
so the entire thing is definitely coming
together
so there's only one more thing that i do
want to cover although for that we need
a tiny bit of theory let's talk about it
i want the various elements to overlap
at the very least the elements inside of
the main layer so for example if the
player is behind in the y-axis it should
be drawn below the other elements for
example if we have the player here and
the player is behind a sunflower the
player should be behind the sunflower or
rather below the sunflower
and if the player is in front and the y
axis the player should be drawn in front
of the other elements so if the player
is in front of it it should be drawn on
top of the sunflower and this effect is
really nice in the game it makes it look
much better
it's also very easy to implement so
let's jump right in back in the code i
want to minimize the setup method
and i want to work inside of the camera
group
i have to work inside of all of this and
this line here in particular is really
important because right now we are just
drawing or well cycling through all of
the sprites and this
i want to sort
and the way i want to sort it let's say
we have two elements like this
i want to sort them by the white
position which means
the further down the center of a sprite
is the later it should be drawn in this
case this right here should be drawn
first and this sprite should be drawn
after that that way this sprite here is
always on top of this other sprite
and since this is going to happen on
every single frame of the game this can
also change to get all of this
we need a key for this sorted function
this always has to be a lambda function
and into this lambda function i want to
pass in this sprite
what i want to look at from the sprite
is
sprite.rect.center y
that is literally all i needed so now if
i run out of this again
you can already see it with the fence
but it's kind of weird but the
sunflowers make it look much nicer
so now
the player
can walk through all of this and it's
looking significantly better
so this is really really nice
and that way the game feels much more
three-dimensional
it also works with the house let me walk
there
so for example here
we can walk through all of this
and well this is very very nice
cool this was a very large section but
we basically imported the entire game so
massive progress
with the level and the player in place
we can work on the collisions and let me
cover a tiny bit of theory how the
collisions are going to work first
because that can be kind of confusing
let's say we have an object here
and we have the player moving in some
kind of direction and we want to check
if the player is colliding with this
obstacle
what we are going to do for that is
we are first going to check if the
player is overlapping with the obstacle
for example the player could be here and
we have an overlap detecting this is
really easy the difficult bit is to
figure out where the collision came from
in this case it might look like the
collision came from this side but it
might have happened that the player was
moving really fast in this direction for
example or the player could have come
down this side here
as a consequence we're going to add a
bit more code to figure out where the
player came from
in this case since the only object that
can move is the player we can check the
player direction so for example if the
player was moving in let's say
this direction here we know the
collision must have happened on this
side because the player was moving in
this direction
and once we have that bit of information
let me clean this up a tiny bit
if we know that the player moved in this
direction and our collision happened
here
then we want to move the player
back to
something like this
and then we have the entire collision
logic
it honestly isn't that bad but you do
need some theory here and one more time
i made a whole separate video on it so
check this one out if you are interested
but other than that let's implement all
of this alrighty here i'm back in the
code and i want to do a couple of things
first before we start with the collision
logic the most important part is that
all of the sprites let me minimize them
there we go all of the sprites and the
player are going to need a hitbox or
some kind of collision rectangle
we could be using the rectangle itself
but that would not be a good idea
for two reasons actually first of all
for the player the rectangle is going to
be really large
if i open the project folder inside of
graphics and let's look at the character
for something like left x
in here if i open this okay it's going
to be very hard to see but if i zoom in
you can kind of see by the shade this
entire surface here has a size of this
this is the entire image and the
rectangle we are creating from this has
the same dimensions and this is much
larger than the actual image the reason
why it is so large is because we have to
capture the entire image and the bunny
has to be in the middle
if that wasn't the case the character
would move around if the size changed so
all of these surfaces have the same size
and that is really important
because of that we couldn't use the
rectangle but what we can do
is create self dot hitbox
and this hitbox is what we actually use
for the collisions
and for this one all i want to do is
self door direct dot copy so we are
copying the rectangle and this i want to
inflate
all that inflate is doing is it takes a
rectangle and it changes the dimension
while keeping it centered around the
well center
as an argument here we need a tuple with
a width and a height by how much we want
to shrink or increase it in my case i
want to shrink it by 126 pixels on the
horizontal axis and negative 70 pixels
on the vertical axis
next up this hitbox has to be moved
along with the rectangle
and this is going to happen inside of
the move method
so in here what i usually do is
after i've moved the position i am
moving the hitbox so self.hit
that is terrible spelling self dot
hitbox
dot center x
is going to be self.pos.x
and then self.rect.centerx
is going to be self.hitbox.centerx
although in here i actually realized i
forgot one important thing and that is
that this self deposited x needs to be
rounded
if we didn't include that pygame would
truncate these values which means a 1.9
for example would be truncated to one
whereas the proper value would be a two
and this is what we get by rounding
which is why we need the rounding here
if you don't do that you are going to
get occasionally wrong behavior
or well incorrect behavior
but all right now that we have that i
have to do the same thing for the
vertical movement so self.hitbox.center
y
is going to be rounded self dot pos dot
y
and now self.record center y is going to
be
self.hitbox.center y
with that we have a hitbox for the
player and now all of the sprites are
going to need a hitbox as well
let's start with generic and in here i
just want to create a hitbox with
self.rect.copy
and this i want to inflate and the
number here i want to be a bit more
flexible so for the wife i went with
negative self.rect.with
and multiply this by 0.2
then i'm going to copy all of this
and then for the height
this is going to be self.rect.height
multiplied by negative 0.75
the numbers here you definitely just
want to play around with it is fairly
subjective it really depends how you
want this to look
mostly for the width you want to have a
fairly small number because you don't
want to shrink it too much on the
horizontal axis
for the vertical axis you do actually
want quite a large number and this again
is because of the overlap let me show
the slide again actually
the overlap for all of this works really
well because when we created this there
was no collision but once we have
collision we really have to be aware
that this
rectangle here shouldn't be too tall
because if the sunflower would have a
collision rectangle that covers the
entire height
the main character would never be able
to go behind it we would always get
stuck on top as a consequence you do
want quite a high negative number for
the vertical axes
all right with that let me minimize the
generic class so we have a lot of space
water doesn't need any hitbox because it
cannot be collided with and next up we
need the wildflower
and this is now the reason why this is a
separate class because in here i want to
have a hitbox and this is going to be
self dot rect
dot let me copy it and then i want to
inflate the entire thing
and i want to inflate this by static
numbers for the horizontal axis which is
negative 20 and for the height i want to
go with negative self.rect.height
and this i want to multiply with
0.9 finally we have the tree
although in here we don't actually have
to make too many changes because the
tree can take the hitbox from the
generic class so this hitbox is still
going to apply
inheritance here makes our life a lot
easier
that covers a lot of the setup there's
one more thing that we need back in
level inside of the init method i need
another group
the group i want to create is called
self dot collision
sprites and this is going to be a plain
pie game.sprite.group
the only reason i'm going to create this
group is because i have to keep track of
what sprites can be collided with so any
sprite the player can collide with is
going to be inside of this group and
inside of this group that way i can
identify them easily which makes my life
a lot easier
and now when we are creating all of the
collidable sprites
that is going to be for example
defense we can collide with so in here
self. all sprites
i want to put in a list and besides that
self.collision sprites
the same is also going to apply
to the trees and to the decoration
so let me target both
and all sprites should be in a list
along with
self.collision sprites
you might be wondering if house walls
and house furniture top also need
collision sprites
the answer is not really but i'm going
to cover that in just a bit
but that's going to come in just a bit
the one thing we need now is that the
player needs to know where all of the
collision sprites are because we are
going to run the collision method inside
of the player
which means i want to pass
self.collisions sprites into the player
i do want to mention here for the player
the player sprite is inside of all
sprites and then besides that the player
is going to have a separate parameter
for the collision sprites but the player
sprite itself is not inside of the
collision sprite we just have a
reference to it whereas the decorations
are both in all sprites and in the
collision sprites this is a
fundamentally different concept here so
i hope you get the difference but now to
make all of this work inside of player
the player is going to need one more
parameter and let's call this the
collision
sprites
and this we have to capture let me put
it below the movement attributes in here
we have collision and i want to get
myself dot collision sprites
as an attribute
and i guess to keep things organized i
could put the hitbox in here as well it
does seem to make sense
and now i can minimize the indent method
and now
inside of the move method
we can work with the collisions or more
specifically i want to create a separate
method that i'm going to call
collide
actually i guess collision makes a bit
more sense
it doesn't really matter and in here i
need self and i need the direction
first of all in here
i want to look at every single sprite
inside of the collision sprites so for
sprite in self dot collision sprites dot
sprites
in here i want to check has attribute
if this sprite i am looking at has an
attribute called hitbox
they should all do but this is a good
way to make sure and that we just skip
any kind of collision if that isn't the
case it well makes our life a bit easier
now once i have that i want to check if
there's any kind of overlap and this i
get with sprite dot hitbox dot polite
rect and now i want to check with self
dot hitbox
if that is the case we know there is
going to be some kind of overlap the
problem is we don't know where the
overlap came from this is why i talked
just a second ago so here we have an
obstacle and the player might be
somewhere here
we know the overlap is here the problem
is we don't know where the player came
from the player could have come from
here the player could have come from
here the player could have even come
from here and moved really fast meaning
we have to figure out where this came
from
and the best way to think about this is
first of all you want to separate the
dimensions so we first have
let me call it we first have horizontal
and after we have done that we are doing
vertical
this is also the reason why down here we
split the movement into horizontal and
vertical movement
in here
the logic gets much easier we still have
an obstacle
and now the player overlaps again
something like this but now we only have
to check if the collision happened on
the left or on the right
now it's still perfectly possible that
the player came this way here and moved
really fast
so i want to check the direction of the
player meaning if the player was moving
to the right
i know that the collision must have
happened on the left because if the
player is moving to the right any kind
of collision has to happen on the left
of the obstacle meaning this side here
and this is what we have to implement
now
first of all i want to check the
direction and if this is horizontal
then i want to check the player
direction so if self.direction.x
is greater than zero if that is the case
we are moving right or the player is
moving right
as a consequence if there is a collision
then i want to set self.hitbox.write
is going to be
sprite.hitbox.left and besides that if
self.direction.x is smaller than zero
this means we are moving left
then self.hitbox.left
is going to be sprite
dot hitbox dot right
there are two more things we need in
here and that is we have to update
self.rect.centerx
so the rectangle the player actually
sees because right now we are just
updating the hitbox we're not updating
the rectangle itself so
where the player appears on the screen
and this should be
whereself.hitbox.centeraxis
finally for the movement we have to
update self.post.x
and this i also want to set
wereself.hitbox.centerxis
and this is the entire logic for the
horizontal collisions
all i have to do now is after we have
done all of the movement for the
horizontal movement then i want to call
self dot
collision
like this
and pass in horizontal in here and now
this should be working let's try
if i now
okay this is getting a bit weird because
we spawned on something but if i just
move left and right
we definitely have some collisions now
if i move up and down this doesn't work
at all but just by itself this is
looking pretty good
which means all we have to do now
is to also check
if direction
is equal to
vertical
let me add a bit of white space here
and this is going to be your exercise
basically what i want you guys to do is
to copy the logic here and apply it on
the vertical axis
so pause the video now and see if we can
figure this one out
first of all i want to check if
self.direction.y
is greater than zero if that is the case
i know i am moving down
which means i want to set
self.hitbox.bottom
to sprite.hitbox.top
i guess let me draw what this means
this line here means we are checking if
the player is moving down so the player
like this is moving down
and now we also know that there has been
some kind of collision
the collision object now is pink i hope
it still makes sense
and now we have to resolve this
collision
this is happening inside of this line
here
we are putting the bottom of the player
this line here at the top of the
obstacle
which means we are moving the player up
by this amount and that way it appears
that the player is on top of the
obstacle
and it appears like that because it
literally is so next up we need
self.direction.y
is smaller than zero and if that is the
case we are moving up
and this means
top self.hitbox.top going to be sprite
dot hitbox dot autumn
besides that we also have to update
self.rect.center y and this is going to
be self.hitbox.center
y
and finally besides that
self.post.y is also going to be
self.hitbox.center y
and with that we have the entire
collision logic
so let's try
and we do have a bit of a problem
because we always spawn outside of this
fence
which causes a few problems
so let me move around here
and now if i just move around the forest
here there's lots of things i can
collide with
and
we do have some problems so
something is not right and i think i
know what it is
because back in the player
i am not calling the collision after the
vertical movement
meaning let me copy the collision here
and this should be vertical
now let's try this again
so now we have the same problem we are
spawning right on top of a fence which
causes weird behavior but other than
that
now we have proper collisions
let's see if this is working this is
looking pretty good
and if i walk through here i can walk
behind the bushes but i cannot walk
through all of the trees
and
this is looking pretty good
so i am quite happy with this
nice this is working very well
there are two problems we have right now
number one is the starting position of
the player meaning inside of setup the
player is just being spawned in a random
position which isn't ideal
and besides that
we need some kind of mechanism to
prevent the player from moving outside
of the map so like this
and let's go through them one by one
the starting position of the player is
the easier thing and for that we need
tiled once more if i open this one
there is an entire layer called player
and inside of that we have a couple of
objects and one is called start this is
a simple node
and this one we can use to set positions
and this is where i want to spawn the
player which means back in my code i
let me add another comment here
player is probably the best name for
this spelling it correctly would also
help
what i want to do in here is for obj in
tmx data dot get layer by name and this
layer is literally called player
and what i want to check is if obj.name
is equal to
start
if that is the case i want to create the
player
and the starting position of the player
is going to be obj
dot x and dot y
if i run this again we are starting
right in the middle of the map so this
is much better
now we have to figure out the other
kinds of collision so let me run the
game again i can for example just walk
through the house which feels a bit
strange
for that if i open tiled again
there is an entire layer called
collision if i make this one visible you
can kind of tell what's going on
i basically drew
a couple of tiles all across the level
and this is limiting the player
this is what i want to import and then
use it for collisions this i am doing
inside of level and let me do it
i guess right before the player makes
sense
and here i want to have some collision
tiles and that is some terrible spelling
collision tiles
since we are now working with a tile
layer again i want for x
y and surface
in
emx data dot get layer by name
this layer is called collision don't
forget we also need tiles
in here i want to create a generic tile
and this one is going to need a position
a surface and a group
what you have to consider here is that
for the group i want to only place it in
self dot collision sprites
this is the one sprite that is not going
to be in all sprites
as a consequence it is not going to be
drawn or updated but it is going to
exist and since this one isn't going to
move we don't really have to update it
that way even though we have a sprite
with a surface it is not going to be
visible
but besides that everything else remains
basically the same so i have x and y
and both of these need
to be multiplied with the tile size
for the surface
all i really want to do is create a pie
game dot surface
and this one should be
tile size and tile size
that way we are creating a empty surface
or well a black surface with the
dimensions of 64 by 64 which is all we
need for this sprite
and with that we should be having
collisions so let me run main.pie again
i am not able to walk through the house
anymore
on top of that if i try to walk on the
water
i can also not do that anymore and if i
walk further to the right
this one also doesn't work
so
this is much better
i guess i can demonstrate what would
happen if we added these generic sprites
to all sprites as well so if i add
this to self
dot all sprites
it would look something like this so
these are the sprites we are actually
colliding with
and well it doesn't feel great but you
can tell what's going on so this is the
entire
religion map of the level
but i do not want to show them so let me
undo all of this
there we go
and now we have all of the collisions
that we need
in this part i want to work on the trees
so that we can hit the trees and the
trees all have apples there are quite a
few different things we need so let's
jump right in
here we are back in the code and i want
to work on my trees
let's get started by giving the trees
some
apples
for that first of all we need an apple
surface this we get with
pygame.image.load
and the file path here let me just copy
it to save me a bit of writing this file
path here
inside of the project folder we are
looking at
graphics and in there we have root and
in there we have if i make it a bit
larger we have the apple this is what
we're importing is simple image
after that we need a list of possible
positions for the apple and this we have
in the settings
let me minimize all of this so it's
easier to read
we have one dictionary
with small and large and the values here
are lists with positions
and these names here refer to small or
large trees and these are positions on
the tree where we could have an apple
this i want to create as an attribute so
self dot let's call it apple pos
is going to be apple underscore pos
that's the dictionary
from the settings file
and from this
i
want to pick the list that is
appropriate and this i'm getting by
using the name remember here the name of
the trees is either small or large and
this is why this works
finally each of the trees is going to
have its own sprite group which i'm
going to call apple
sprites
this is just going to be
pygame.sprite.group
now once we have that i actually have to
use that to create some apples this i
want to do in a separate method that i'm
going to call create fruit we need self
and nothing else and in here
basically what i want to do is
for position in
self.apple
position
i want to have some random number
generator to tell if we want to create
an apple in a position or not now for
that i am going to need randint so from
random import rand
and now all i really want to do is rant
in
generating a number between 0 and 10
and if that number is smaller than 2 i
want to create an apple
and the apple here is just going to be a
generic object this one is going to need
a position a surface and a group
all the stuff we're getting from the
generic class up here let me go through
them one by one because we do have to be
a bit careful here although the surface
is very easy all we need is self dot
apple's surface actually this should
just be uphill
surface because it's singular
for the position you might be very
tempted to just go with position by
itself here because if you look at
settings we have a list and this looks
like a position
and it kind of is but it's a bit
misleading
the way you have to think about it
if this one here is the entire map of
the game
and we have a tree somewhere
here
the position
that is inside of the list refers to the
position on the tree
and the number is the distance from the
top left of the tree not the top left of
the entire game
meaning every time we are creating an
apple we have to add the top left of the
game and then we have to add the offset
of the apple
and let's do this separately for the
variables we have x and y
and this i think could actually be a
really good exercise for you
try to get the actual position of the
apple you want to get the position of
the apple the position we already have
and then add it to the top left of the
tree and see how far you get
all right let's do it for the x and i
want to get position 0. that is always
the x this is let me bring the drawing
back up and let me clean it up a tiny
bit
this position 0 is basically telling me
how far from the left of the tree i want
to go to this i have to add self
self.rect.left
and this self.director left is the left
side of the tree
meaning this
side here is this side or in other words
it is this distance here
combined we are getting this entire
arrow here and this is where we want to
place the actual apple
at least on the horizontal axis
for the y this is going to look very
similar we want pause one and then
self.direct dot top
and this is the actual x and y position
we want this is what i want to pass in
here for x and y
finally for the group
i want to have two groups in here the
first one is easy i want to have self
dot apple sprites
besides that i also want to put all of
these apples into all sprites because
that's the only way to display them to
the player the problem is we don't
really have those available anywhere
inside of this entire python file we
only really have them inside of the
level so this all sprites
now the work around here is
every single sprite has the attributes
of what sprites it is part of and this
we can access with self.groups
and these are all of the groups that
tree sprite is in
this i do have to call and this is going
to return a list and from this list i
want to pick the first element
and this first element if i look at my
level where i am creating the trees
this one here
the first element is going to be all
sprites the second element is going to
be collision sprites
this is what i'm getting with this line
here
so that way i am placing each apple into
apple sprites that's the sprite group of
the tree and then into all sprites that
way they are going to be visible
there's one more thing that we need and
let me put all of this over multiple
lines with named arguments
otherwise this is going to be very hard
to read
this one is groups and finally the one
thing i forgot is we need a z position
fortunately this one is very easy we
need layers
and inside of settings inside of layers
we have
a fruit layer this is where the apples
should be on
every time we are creating the tree i
want to call self dot create fruit
and this should be working let's try if
i now run main.pi and look at a tree
we can see
quite a lot of apples this is looking
very nice
i am very happy with this we are
definitely making progress
next up i want to have the logic that we
can hit the player and let me minimize
create fruit we don't need it anymore
so let me call this the tree
attributes
in here first of all each tree is going
to have an amount of health which i'm
always going to set to 5 but choose
whatever you want in here besides that i
also want self dot alive and by default
this is going to be true if this one is
false the tree for example wouldn't
create fruits but this is going to come
later
besides that i also want to have what i
called self.stump underscore surface and
this is what the tree is going to look
like if the tree was destroyed so once a
life is false we want to display a sum
surface instead of the tree
and this we have to import with pygame
dot image dot load
and in here i want to create an f string
because we have to decide between two
different files so there's one stump for
the small tree and one for the large
tree
for both we have to go up one folder
then to graphics and there's a folder
called stumps and here i want to work
with variables
and this should be
small
if name
is equal to small
and if that is not the case
it should be large
and don't forget this should be png
this is getting really large and i made
a typo so let's put this on a separate
line
let's call this the stump
path
so i want to get this out of here
and paste it in there
and place this stump path in here and
now don't forget we also have to convert
alpha this one there's one more thing
that we do need and that is a timer so i
want to have self dot involve underscore
timer
is going to be a timer that lasts for
about 200 milliseconds why we need this
timer i'm going to visualize in just a
second for now just follow along
but this is basically all we need for
the three attributes
now that we have that i want to create
another method
and this i'm going to call damage
here we need self and nothing else
this method is well damaging the tree so
i want self dot health
minus equal one
and this is going to be damaging
the
three
besides that every time we're hitting
the tree with an x i also want to
remove an
apple but i only want to do that if
there is an apple meaning first of all i
want to check the length of self dot
apple sprites dot sprites
if this list here is 0 there is no point
in removing an apple
so i only want to do this if this list
is greater than 0.
if that is the case i want to pick a
random apple and store it in a variable
and to pick a random apple i need the
choice function and this one i also get
from random so besides randint i want to
import
choice and in here i want choice and i
want self.apple
sprites
dot sprites
and this random apple i want to destroy
with the kill method
so now we just have to figure out how to
call this damage method
and this is going to happen inside of
the player
although for that to work we need a few
more things so let me minimize
everything inside of the player first of
all the player needs to know where all
of the trees are
and for that to work back in my level
let me minimize all of these methods as
well
i want to create another group and this
i called self dot tree
sprites again this is just going to be
pygame.sprite.group
all of the trees that i am going to
create which happens down here each tree
is supposed to be in all sprites
collision sprites and also in
self.3 sprites
really important here
make sure that self.all sprites is the
first sprite inside of the list
if that is not the case then
[Music]
inside of createfruit this line here
would not work anymore so be careful
here
but now that we have that i can minimize
the setup actually i can't because i
have to pass
into my player
this one here
let me put all of this over multiple
lines because this is also getting
really hard to read
we have a position
we have a group i think it was a
singular group right yeah just group
besides that we have collision
sprites
and finally i want to add one more
parameter and this is called trees
and this is going to be self.3
sprites
and now inside of the player in the init
method
i want to create three
sprites
next up i have to convert all of this
into an attribute let me put it all the
way at the bottom here and let me create
another section that i call interaction
there are going to be quite a few things
we need to interact with but in here i
want to have myself dot
three sprites and this is going to be
the tree sprites parameter
now we have to figure out how to
actually target this thing and this is
going to happen inside of use tool
remember this we created
ages ago about 2 hours by now but this
method is being called every time we are
using a tool and in here i want to check
what tool we are currently using so if
self dot
selected tool
is equal to
let's start with a ho
if that is the case i want to pass for
now
besides that i can duplicate this line
i want to check if the selected tool is
an x
and this is what we want to work on in
this part but for now let me add a path
in here and finally
i also want to check
if
our selected tool is water
although in here for now also going to
be a pass
if we are using the x i want to check
for
3 in self dot 3 sprites dot
sprites
don't forget to call it
and now i want to check if we are
actually hitting the tree which means if
3 and now i have to figure out
if we are actually hitting the tree
the problem is i don't really have any
way to know which point i'm actually
targeting
meaning let me comment out all of this
for now and let me run the code
and i'm getting an error
because i didn't import the timer
so
from timer import timer
now let's try this again we are getting
another error that the player
this is probably happening in level
this should be tree
underscore sprites
now it's working
right now i can use the different tools
and this is working perfectly fine for
all of them
the issue is right now we have no idea
which point we are targeting
for example if i'm using the x
i want to know that i am basically
targeting this point here
let me use the x again this looks about
right
and this point i have to get in my code
so back in my player let me minimize the
init method and in here
i want to create another method that i'm
going to call get underscore target
underscore position and all i really
want to do in here is i want to create
another attribute that i'm going to call
self.target
position
this is going to be the same for all of
the tools which makes it quite easy to
work with and the basic logic here is
if this is our player
and this is the center of the player for
each of the tools for example if the
player is looking to the left
then i want the tool to be somewhere
here
a certain distance to the left of the
player and a bit further down
the reason why i have to move it down is
because most of the tools
like the x for example they go in this
direction here
basically what i want to do i want to
get self.rect.center
and then i'm going to need some kind of
offset
and this offset
i am getting from my settings because in
here we have player tool offsets and
these are a bunch of offsets that we can
work with
meaning this is what i want to copy
paste it inside of the player and now we
have a dictionary that we want to take
some information from
notice here
the keys are called left right up and
down which is the same as the status of
the player
which is very handy because now we can
get self.status dot split
and as always we want to split it
wherever there's an underscore and then
pick the index 0 of that list
and this is basically all we need for
this one method i guess importantly do
not forget to call it
right after the timers so self dot get
target position
now the problem is that this target
position is going to be really hard to
see
at least for now for testing purposes we
do need some way to visualize it and i
just realized this should be status not
stats
and since this isn't something the
player is supposed to see
we can just do this really quick so for
testing purposes back in level dot pi
all the way at the end of custom draw i
added a tiny bit more code that looks
like this
if you go for this basically what we are
doing is we are drawing a rectangle
another rectangle and a
circle the result is going to look like
this
this is telling us the red line
is the rectangle of the player the green
line is the collision rectangle and the
blue dot this one here
is the target position
so if i use a tool
you can kind of see where it's going and
this also works with the x and with the
watering can
and well this way you can play around
with this quite a bit more
although for the actual game you don't
need it so
most of the time
you're just going to comment it out or
remove it entirely
but i guess let me keep it for now
because now we know that the target
position so the blue dot
looks pretty good
now with that we can uncomment this part
here
and now for the tree i want to look at
the rectangle of the tree and i want to
check if this tree is colliding with a
point
the point that i want to check is self
dot target position
if that is the case
i want to
get the tree and then run the damage
method
which is this damage method here let's
try if this is working
so back in the game
we are already getting a problem because
even if i don't use the axe the apples
all disappear
which i guess kind of looks cool but not
ideal
also this one should be commented
one of the main reasons why that
happened is if i open the timer again
in here this line is causing the problem
because there is a chance that our
current time minus the start time is
bigger than the duration so this could
run forever
and as a consequence we might trigger
this function by accident
and a really easy way to fix that is to
add another end statement here that we
want to check self dot start time
is different from zero
and now let's run may not pi again
and
now
if i am colliding with a tree nothing
happens
and if i use the x
also nothing happens
let's try different tools okay nothing
happens in general
and the reason why that is happening
inside of timer
every time we are deactivating the timer
we're setting the start time to zero
meaning this is not going to run
the activate has to be after this if
statement
and now
inside of the player
let me just
print
tool
use
just to try if this is working so now if
i use the x i can see tool use in the
bottom left
and i guess now we can try to hit a tree
there we go the apple disappeared
and this is working quite well
and let me close the timer again now we
are done with it
back in the sprites
i want to have
another method that checks if the tree
is still alive so check def
and basically all i want to do is if
self.health is smaller or equal than
zero
then the tree is going to die let me
just print that
we just have to figure out when to call
check def in my case i went with an
update method that needs self and delta
time like any update method and then
here i'm going to call self dot check
def
actually to be a bit better here
we only want to check def if self dot
alive is true
and now
let me run main.pi again
if i hit a tree with my x we get tool
use tool use and now we get that
this is looking really good
which means what we can do in here now
is i can set self dot alive u
volts
although there are a few more things
that i do want to change first of all
self.image so what the sprite actually
looks like should be
self.stump surface
and since we are updating the image we
also have to update
self.rect this i get with
self.image.getunderscorerect
and i want to place the mid
bottom should be
wherever the previous self.rect.mid
bottom was
what that means is if this one here is
the original tree and we want to create
a tree stump that is a bit smaller
we now have to figure out in this line
where we want to place this rectangle
finally we also have to update the
hitbox
and this we get with self.direct dot
inflate actually i think good practice
here is to copy the entire thing
and now
in here we are going to need a width and
a height or an x and a y basically the
same thing for the three stems i always
went with negative 10 and negative
self.direct
and multiply this by 0.6
let's try
so if i now go to a tree
hit the tree a few times there we go we
have a tree stump i can do this with the
other tree as well
and we get a different kind of tree
stump
and this section is getting quite long
so let's finish it now but in the next
section we are going to finish up the
trees
we are nearly done with the trees there
is only one more major thing that i
would like to add and that is some
particle effects so that when an apple
disappears or when a tree disappears i
want to show some white object that
flashes on the screen you'll see in a
second what i mean but it looks quite
nice once more here we have main.pi and
i want to work inside of the sprites
inside of the tree in here
whenever one of the apples disappears
that happens here i want to basically
create a white apple on top of the
disappearing apple
that way we're indicating which apple
disappears
also whenever the tree dies
which happens inside of this method here
i want to do the same thing for the tree
so for a couple of milliseconds we have
a white tree and then we can see the
tree stump
both of these are being created with
another class let me create it right
here and i'm going to call this one
class partic kill
this particle is also going to be a
generic sprite so it inherits like all
of the other sprites from the generic
class
in here
as always we are going to need the
dunder init method
we need self
we need a position we need a surface we
need groups and we need a z layer
for the parent class to work we need the
super and dunder init method
this one for generic
add position groups and the z layer
meaning i can copy them in here
and
most of them we don't really have to
worry about too much
as a matter of fact if you look at this
closely
those parameters and those arguments are
basically identical the only thing i
really want to change is i do not want
to have the default argument now the way
this particle is going to work is it is
going to be a sprite but this sprite is
going to self-destroy really quickly it
basically has an internal timer let's
create this one actually right now
we can use the update method here and
this one needs self and
delta time
just so that we capture delta time
in here
i am let me save it as the current time
the current time i'm getting with
pygame.time.get
underscore ticks
once i have that all i really want to do
is if my current time
minus
some kind of start time we'll create
that one in just a second
is greater than a certain kind of
duration
if that is the case i want to destroy
this sprite that way we are only showing
this sprite for let's say half a second
and then it disappears
besides that this particle is always
going to have the same surface as for
example the tree except it is going to
color the entire thing white
and that way we have some kind of
particle effect it's a fairly minimal
one but it does the job for this game
we need to do two more things we need to
get a duration and this one i should
have put in the init parameters so in
here duration and i do want to have a
default value let's say 200
now that we have all of that i want to
create self.starttime
and this one is pygame.time.get
underscore ticks
i suppose i should mention the
difference between this start time here
and this current time
is that the start time here
is only being taken once
it's basically one point in time
whereas the current time is being
continuously updated meaning from this
point here we are checking another
current time another current time
another current time and so on and at
some point
we are hitting the duration meaning that
this distance here is greater than the
duration and then we are destroying the
sprite
besides that i have to store my duration
as an attribute and this i just get from
my duration
and this is the basic setup besides that
we need to create the white
surface
in this we are doing via a mask for that
i want to create a mask surface
this i'm getting from pygame dot mask
dot from underscore surface
this one needs one surface and the
surface we have is self dot image
now once we have that
i want to create a new surface
and this new surface we get with the
mass surface and then to underscore
surface
this new surface now is going to be a
black and white silhouette of the
original self.image
any pixel that had any kind of color
value is going to be white and any kind
of transparent value will be black i can
visualize this in just a second actually
but what we need to do now is to get rid
of all of the black color values which
we do with new surface and we have to
set a color key
the color we want to get rid of
is going to be black so a tuple with 0 0
and 0.
and this new surface i want to set as
the image of this sprite
there we go and this should be all we
need for the entire class
all we have to figure out now is when to
create it and this happens for example
inside of the tree
for example
when we are destroying an apple i want
to play this particle effect
let's do it right below the random apple
i want to create a particle for this
particle i want to have
not these parameters i want to have
these parameters
i suppose for simplicity we could get
rid of the duration here because we're
not going to need it for now
and well now we have to figure out a
position a surface groups and a z and i
think this could be a really good
exercise try to pass in all of these
arguments and see if you can create this
particle effect it should already be
working once you have created it
let's put them all on separate lines so
i can work with named arguments and that
should make all of this much easier to
read
first of all we need a position we
already have the random apple we want to
destroy i want to get this random apple
i want to get the rectangle of this
random apple and then i want to get the
top left
because this particle should be in the
same position as this apple
along the same lines it should also have
the same surface so random apple dot
image
for the groups we need to do basically
the same thing we have done for the
apples
which means i want to have myself dot
groups don't forget to call it and now i
want to have the element with the index
0.
now looking at all of this since we are
doing this quite often it might be a
good idea
to put a reference to the self.all
sprites inside of the tree
but you can do this in your own time it
isn't going to make much of a difference
finally for the set parameter
i also realized it doesn't really have a
separate layer but you don't really need
one you can put it inside of the fruit
but also be inside of raindrops it
honestly doesn't matter at this point
let's go with fruit i guess it fits in
there quite well
we need layers and in there i want to
have the fruit
and with that we should be having a
particle effect let's try if i run out
of this it still runs that's generally a
good sign
and let's use this tree here and there
we go we have a very basic particle
effect
it is indeed very subtle but it
certainly does work
let me minimize the damage method and
now we want to do the same thing for the
tree once the tree is being destroyed
which we can also do quite easily once
again i want to create a particle
and now
once again let me get all of the
parameters we need
and i guess for this one we can also
change the duration
so in here i want to have all of these
arguments the position is going to be
self.rect.top
left
the surface is going to be self.image
spelled correctly would be good as well
then for the groups once more
self.groups
with the index 0
and for that i want to have
layers
and i guess we can put this on the fruit
layer as well
since this is a slightly larger object
let's go for a duration of 500
and this should be all we need let's try
this one now
and this one is only going to play once
the tree is dead so we have to hit a
tree a couple of times
we go i guess the effect is a tiny bit
long
uh let's go with 300.
let's try this one
although at this point this is quite
subjective so you can just go with
whatever you think looks best
and yeah i think this is okay
and with that we have some basic
particle effects and these we can also
reuse later on for the plans which is
very nice
which means we have covered another
major section
to finish off the tree we have to create
a player inventory so the player gets an
apple or some wood whenever we hit a
tree
which means we have to connect the
player and the tree with each other
which is a fairly straightforward thing
to do so let's jump right in once more
we are in the code and first of all we
have to look at the player specifically
inside of the init method let me put it
above the interactions and right below
the tools and the seats this one i want
to call inventory
because if you want to add something to
the player the player needs to have some
kind of system to store data
and for now the player is only going to
have a single dictionary and this i call
item inventory although later on there's
going to be a bit more
and in here we're going to have a couple
of different key value pairs let me copy
them in actually so you don't have to
watch me right
we have
these four
wood and apple is what the player gets
from the trees and corn and tomato is
what we're getting from the soil
by default all of them are going to be
zero and let me line them up a bit nicer
so
this is looking better
and these numbers we want to increase
whenever the player for example gets a
piece of wood or an apple
which means we have to connect the
player
all of this here
with the tree
and since they are in different files we
have to work via the level to make all
of this work
and let me minimize
everything
so we're not getting lost
right now the level only has three
methods even though it is quite a chunky
class already but i want to add another
method in here
and this one i'm going to call player
underscore add
besides self we are going to need an
item so the item we want to add to the
player
what is going to happen in here is i am
targeting the player i want to get the
item inventory of the player the one we
just created
from the dictionary i want to get the
item
this would be
one of
these key value pairs
and this i want to increase by one
i suppose you could make this a bit more
flexible by adding another parameter
that would be the amount for example but
in my case i would always stick with one
because i do want to keep things simple
and this tutorial is already getting
quite long
this method i have to pass into the
trees
which means inside of setup
when i am creating the trees this
happens here
and once again
let's do this over multiple lines with
named arguments
so we're not getting completely lost
we have the groups and finally this one
was called the name
the one additional argument we want to
add is let's call it player add
and this is going to be self dot player
add
make sure here not to call it because we
only want to call it from inside of the
tree object
which means inside of the tree we're
going to need another parameter
layer add and this one we also have to
store somewhere in the attributes let's
do it here and self dot player add is
going to be player add
now that we have that
when we are damaging the tree
this stuff here i want to
run self dot player add and give the
player an apple
which should be all we need i guess
inside of the level in the run method
all the way at the bottom let me print
self.player.item inventory so we can
tell what's going on
if i run this now
you can see in the bottom left the
inventory of the player
and if i now hit a tree we have one
apple
this i can do multiple times we have two
apples three apples that is looking
really good
so that is basically all we need for the
apples
the one last thing for the tree we have
to do is whenever the tree dies we have
to give the player some wood and this
could be a fairly easy exercise for you
so try to figure this one out yourself
i hope that this one is fairly easy at
this point all you need is self dot
player add and then here you have to add
some wood
let's run all of this again
and for this one i have to hit a tree
multiple times
there we go now we have one wood this is
working very well
with that i can get rid of this print
statement here and minimize the run
method
in fact i can minimize all of these
methods so things are easier to see
and with that we are basically done with
the basic tree although the next section
is we have to make sure that the trees
get new apples once we are sleeping
which means we have to work on the logic
to start a new day
but that is going to be the next section
so let's start to work on restarting the
day for now all this means is all of the
trees are getting some new fruits but
later on there's going to be quite a bit
more besides that we also have to work
on some transitions but let's do all of
this straight in code it isn't so hard
it's more an organizational thing but
let's have a look at all of this
alright once again we are inside
main.pie and let's start by talking
about what we need
basically i want to start a new day when
i stand here or when the player stands
here and presses enter so right next to
the bat
which means we have to check an input
and we need to check if the player is on
top of this carpet or at least inside of
this area
for this i already have some basic setup
inside of tiled let's have a look at
that
here we have tiled if i zoom in
there is one object
that is called bed that is right next to
the pad this is an empty area that i
want to import and if the player is
inside of this area and presses enter
then i want to start a new day
once again if you want more detail
entitled check out the dedicated video
now this i want to import but for the
import i need another dedicated sprite
that sprite
let me put it right here i have called
interaction
once more this inherits from the generic
sprite
although other than that it is going to
be fairly simple we have an init method
as always
and in here we have self we have a
position we have a size we have the
groups and finally we have a name
we do not need a surface in here
for the simple reason that this kind of
sprite is never visible anyway
speaking of we can just create the
surface in here and the surface we are
creating with pygame dot surface
and we are passing the size in here
that is the size we're getting from the
parameters
other than that i have to call
the parent init method with superdunder
init and pass the surface the position
and the groups in here
there's that position really doesn't
matter because again this is not going
to be visible so we can just leave it as
it is
finally we have to get self.name and
store it as an attribute the name if i
open tiled again
is what you can see on the left side
here we have a name
besides the bat by the way this is what
you are going to see in quite a bit
we have the trader meaning if the player
stands inside of this area and presses
enter we want to open some kind of menu
for trading but well that is something
for later but now i just want to work
with the bad
but other than that we have finished the
entire interaction class
it wasn't actually so bad
now we have to import it this happens
inside of level inside of setup
in here this is getting quite extensive
the layer we want to work in is the
player layer
let me add a bit of white space here
because this is the same layer where we
have the player
except now
i want to check if
obj.name
is equal to
that
if that is the case i want to create the
inter
action
sprite for that to work i need to import
it meaning all the way at the top after
tree i want to have the interaction
sprite
now back in here
let me copy all of the parameters we
need we need those four
and all of those should be fairly
straightforward for the position
we need
the same thing we have seen for the
player so obj.x and obj.y
i can just copy paste them and for the
size we're doing something fairly
similar except for x and y we need with
and we need height
for the group i actually want to create
a whole new group
let me do it all the way inside of the
init method this one i've called
self.interaction
sprites
but this is once again just another
pygame.sprite.group
self dot interaction sprites we don't
need self that all sprites here because
again this kind of sprite is not going
to be visible
finally we need the name of this kind of
sprite
you could write just bad in here this
would be perfectly fine
alternatively you could also use
obj.name
you would be getting the same result
and with that we have an area
next up the player needs to know about
this area because right now these
interaction sprites only exist inside of
the level and the player has no idea
about them
as a consequence for the player which is
right on top
i want to add let me call it interaction
and this is going to be self.interaction
sprites that way the player has an
attribute to know where these
interaction sprites are
so with that inside of the player we are
going to need one more parameter
interaction
this i want to store below my three
sprites
and let's call it interaction is going
to be interaction
with that the player knows where these
kind of sprites are
all we have to do now is check if the
player is inside of this area and
presses the enter button
which we are doing
if i minimize all of the methods this is
going to happen inside of input
all the way at the bottom of this method
i need another if statement if keys are
pygame dot a underscore return
this is telling me if the player has
pressed the enter button or not after i
know that i want to know if the player
collided with the bad sprite for example
and this i want to store in collided
interaction
sprite
this we are getting with
pygame.sprite.sprite
or lite
and in here we need three arguments we
need a sprite we need a group and we
need what is called do
kill
the sprite in this example is just going
to be self
and we want to check the sprite so the
player sprite against all of the
interaction sprites which we get with
self.interaction
do kill
is supposed to be false and basically
what it means is if the player
which is self in this example if this
one collides with the sprite inside of
this group do we want to destroy this
sprite which in this case we don't want
to do
which is why this one is going to be
false
and now that we have that i want to
check if collided interaction sprite
exists in the first place
or rather if it is truthy because that
is only the case if it has a sprite
inside
if that is the case i want to check my
collided sprite
the first item inside that can only have
a b1 and of that i want to check the
name
that is the name we have created here if
this name is trader
for now i want to pass but later on we
are doing something else in here
obviously
if that is not the case which means we
have the bad
then
i want to do something else
one thing i do want to do in here is add
self dot status is going to be left idle
the main reason for that is
if
this is the player and we have the bad
here
if the player presses enter i want the
player to point towards the bat
it would be kind of weird if the player
looked to the right then we press enter
and then we start a new day it's kind of
feeling bad
let's try this one actually it should be
working
and we're getting an error that element
property with does not exist do you mean
with
this happened inside of the level and
here we need with
now let's try this again this is looking
better and now if i
look to the right and press enter the
player is looking to the left so this is
working very good
with that we can tell if the player is
next to the bat and pressing enter so
with that we can actually start working
on the day transition
for that we have two elements we need to
cover first of all we have to basically
restart the level in our case this just
means all of the trees are going to get
some new apples if they are still alive
besides that we also have to play some
kind of transition that indicates we
have a new day
let's start by resetting the entire
level
which is going to happen inside of level
and i really want to hide the setup
method this one is really large
and all of the reset logic should be in
a dedicated method called reset
this one doesn't need any parameters
and in here we basically want to reset
everything
which for now is just going to be the
trees
or rather the apples
on the
grease
the way i approach this i first of all
have to get every individual tree which
i get with four tree in
self.3 sprites dot sprites
in here we actually have not too much
work to do because if you look at
the tree
we have a dedicated function if i
minimize everything
we have a function called create fruit
and this one creates all of the fruits
that we need meaning all we really have
to do is call tree dot create
root
although now we do have a problem
because we are not destroying the
existing apples
that however is quite easily done all we
have to do is for apple in
three dot apple
underscore sprites
dot
rights don't forget to call it and i
want to destroy with the kill method all
of the apples
with that we're getting rid of all of
the apples and we are creating new
apples which is basically a reset
what we now have to figure out is when
to call this method
because remember we are updating the
level inside of the player not inside of
the level class itself
which means i have to connect the reset
to the player although there's going to
be another problem
because besides the player this reset
also needs to be connected to a
transition effect
how that is going to work is
basically
the entire screen is going to go dark
then we are resetting the level and then
we are making the screen go back to
normal
inside of this transition reset is going
to be played here
which means we need a system where the
player the level and the transition all
work together
and
this well let's go for it step by step
first of all inside of the player for
the ending method i want to have one
more attribute this i called self dot
sleep
by default this one is going to be false
if the player now presses enter and goes
to bad all the way down here i want to
set self dot sleep who
rue
that way we know if the player is
sleeping or not and this we can use to
start a transition
that is going to happen inside of the
level inside of run
all the way at the end
i want to check if player
this should be self dot player dot sleep
then i want to do something like self
dot transition this one doesn't exist
yet dot
lay
and this one is going to need delta time
now this transition is going to be a
separate class and this class is going
to call the reset method once we are in
a certain point of the transition
animation
which basically means
inside of the init
method i want to create
self.transition this is going to be a
transition class we will create in just
a second
and this one is going to get self.reset
and it's going to get self.player
with that we can actually create this
new class
let me save it as
transition.pi
once again we have to import pygame for
the obvious reasons and we need from
settings import everything
the class we want to create is called
transition
no need for inheritance but i do need a
dander init method because this one
needs self reset and the player
inside of this we first of all need to
get the display
surface
because we want to be able to draw on
the level itself
this one we get with pygame.display.get
underscore surface
besides that we have to capture the
reset
method inside of an attribute
and we have to do the same thing for the
layer
let me call this part here
setup
and besides that we are going to need an
over
lay
image
for the overlay image we are basically
going to create a black image and then
we are going to change the transparency
or rather the blending mode but in this
case this is going to be the same i'm
going to explain this as we implement it
but first of all i need self
dot image
and this is going to be pygame dot
surface
and the dimensions
here we are getting from the settings
because i want to have the screen width
and the screen height
let me copy this screen width
paste it in here
and the second one should be screen
height
this right now is giving us a surface
the size of the entire window that is
entirely black
besides that i also want to have self
dot color this one is 255
by default and then self dot speed
this one is going to be negative two
how these two attributes are going to
work i think the best way to explain
this is let's use them right away
so i want to have some kind of play
method that needs self
and in here i want to
self dot color
plus equal self dot speed
and that information i can use to fill
my image so self.image.fill
and in here i need an rgb tuple we need
red we need green and we need blue
in this case since we only care between
a black and a white color they can all
be the same
color
this image i now want to blit on top of
the entire game which means
self.displaysurface.lit
i need self.image
the top left should be a position zero
and zero
and for now let's just leave it like
this
and play it because you're probably
confused at this point
things are going to make a lot of sense
in just a second or at least i hope they
will
first of all for all of this to work we
have to import from transition import
transition
that means this one here is going to
work
and now inside of the run method
layer.sleep is also going to work
although here that's a time we don't
actually need
now with that let's try main.pi and
let's press enter next to the bat
and we're getting some very strange
effect and we're getting an error
message
let's try it again really quick
if i run this first of all we get white
and then we go darker and darker and
that is exactly what i wanted
the entire logic is going to happen
inside of play
in here
self.color on the first frame is 255
which with the fill method here
means we are turning the entire image
white all of these self.colors are 255
and those are the values for pure white
and if you put this on top of the
display surface we are getting a white
image
however now we are updating in this line
the color
which means on every single frame the
color is going to be a tiny bit darker
because of that we started with a white
image and it became darker and darker
and at some point this self.color got
negative and this is where we got the
error
and this doesn't seem very much right
now but we can make this look much
better by adding another argument inside
of the blit method
the argument we need here is called a
special underscore flags
what we can do with this is set the
blending mode
the one we want is pygame dot blend
underscore rgba underscore mult
and now if i run this
and try the same thing again
now we have a much nicer transition
this blending mode works it basically
gets rid of all of the white values so
the brighter a value is the less visible
it is going to be and the pure white
value is going to be completely
invisible
that way at the beginning we are not
seeing any of this image but the darker
it gets the more we see of it and at
some point it turns the entire screen
pure black although right after that the
entire thing crashes
that we do have to work on
fortunately it's not that difficult all
we have to do is if self dot color is
smaller or equal than zero and if that
is the case i want to set self dot speed
and multiply it with negative one
besides that if self.color
is greater than 255
because now after these two lines
we are increasing the color continuously
and at some point it's going to be
greater than 255
which is also going to be a problem
we do need to limit that one as well
if that is the case at least for now i
want to set self dot
color to 255
and with that we should be having a
transition
let me play main.pi and let's see how
this is going to look
we are still getting an error let's have
a look
i guess the main reason here is that
once we get below zero
we are only changing the speed we're not
changing this number
and as a consequence for this one frame
things are falling apart but that we can
fix quite easily all we have to do is
set self.color to zero
with that it should be working
if i now walk next to the bed
and this is working really well
we are very nearly done
there are three more things that we have
to do let me write them all the way at
the top number one we have to call the
reset method
number two we have to wake up the
layer
and number three
we have to set the speed
to
negative 2
at the end of the
transition
i am pretty sure you can already tell
where this is going this is going to be
your exercise
work through these three parts and try
to implement them yourself and see how
far you get
the reset method i want to call
when we are reaching this point here all
i have to do is call self.reset
because reset we have stored here and
this is the one we created in level.pi
and this is all we needed
let's try this one actually i created it
but never tested it
meaning now let's have a look at some
trees
you can see we have
two apples on most of those trees
and now if i go to bed
and look at the trees again
they are looking different which means
the reset method has worked
next up we have to wake up the player
that should happen once the entire
transition is over all the way at the
bottom self.player.sleep
should be false
on top of that while the player is
sleeping i don't want the player to be
able to move that would be kind of weird
this happens inside of the player
and all the way at the top here
i only want to allow any kind of input
if we are not using a tool and
if we are not self dot
sleep
this one we can also test quite easily
now if i press enter i would try to move
to the left
and i tried and now i can move again
after a couple of milliseconds meaning
this one is working as well
finally we have to set the speed to
negative 2 at the end of the transition
this is also going to happen at the
bottom
all we have to do here is set
speed to negative two with that we are
done
this is the entire transition
i guess we should probably try this a
couple of times
but this is working once if i try again
now
and this is working again and it keeps
on working just fine
with that we have a daytime transition
and this one is going to update all of
the trees as well
later on once we have plans we are also
going to make updates to those
and that i guess we can actually start
working on next
with the trees finished we can start
working on the soil and there is going
to be a ton of logic in here
basically what we have to do is we need
one class that covers all of the soil
and this glass has to be connected to
all of the watering and all of the
plants
which is going to be a very chunky
python file
just to warn you probably for the next
hour maybe two we are going to work just
on the soil you have been warned but for
now just to get started let's create the
very basic logic for the soil so if the
player uses the hole we want to create
one soil tile
once again i am inside my project and i
want to create a new file that i'm going
to call soil dot pi
in here i have to import by game
and i need from settings import
everything
with that covered i want to create a new
class called soil
layer
no need for inheritance but in here i
want to have a init or done the init
method with self and for now all
sprites
because in here each of the soil patches
is going to be a dedicated sprite and to
make them visible we have to attach them
to all sprites
as a consequence we do need them
available inside of the class
inside of this class i want to add
one section let's call it
sprite
groups
and in here i want to have self dot all
sprites
as my all sprites
besides that since i do want to have
easy access to all of my soil patches i
want to create another attribute that i
call self.soil
sprites and this is just going to be
another pygame dot sprite
dot group
after that
we are going to need
graphics
and for now this is going to be
very simple we have a single self.soil
underscore surface
and this is something we are going to
import
here we have the project i want to go to
graphics and there we have the soil
and in there we have a bunch of
different things for now all i want to
import is the file called o
what all of the other files do you will
see in the next major part for now just
don't worry about them it's honestly
better for you meaning all i want to do
is pygame dot image dot load the path we
need here is one folder up then graphics
then we need soil
and in the app we have o dot png with
that we do have a setup but now we do
have a couple of problems first of all
not every single tile in our map should
be farmable
let me demonstrate this entitled
actually
here's the entire level
and i think it should be quite obvious
that not every single tile here should
be farmable in fact
i only want this area here
to be farmable
this is also going to exclude the house
and the path
none of these should be farmable
only the stuff that is inside of this
area i hope you can see what i'm talking
about
for that there is a whole other layer
called farmable if i make this one
visible you can kind of see what i am
talking about only the pure green tiles
here should be farmable meaning this is
what we have to import and then only if
the player hits one of these areas
only there we are going to create a soil
tile
however now we do have another problem
and that is that we have to manage quite
a bit of data and this i want to address
early because is becoming really
important
basically later on for every single one
of the tiles we have to check a couple
of different things let me add a couple
of comments here in terms of what we
need so requirements
for each of the tiles
we need to know
if the area is far mobile that's the
thing you have just seen
besides that later on for the plants we
also need to know if the soil has been
watered
and we have to know if this soil has a
plant already for example if we want to
plant a new plant we cannot plant that
new plant if the soil patch has a plant
already i hope that sentence makes sense
meaning we need to have quite a robust
way to manage all of this data as a
consequence i'm going to store all of
this information in one grid
that for now is only going to store if
we have a farmable area or not
but let's do all of this in a separate
method that i called create soil
underscore grid
in here we don't need any parameters
and in here i want to create one list
that contains other lists and one list
for each tile of the game
let's do this in tiled actually
so when you look at these specific tiles
here each of these cells is one tiled
and in the grid i am going to create
every single tile is going to be one
list and this list is going to contain a
couple of different pieces of
information the one we are going to care
about now is if it is farmable or not
which i'm going to do by just adding a
capital f inside of the list if it is
farmable and well there's not going to
be an f if it's not farmable that way we
can always tell which one we have
although to create this we first of all
have to know how tall the map is
for that i have to import the background
image or the floor this one i get with
pygame.image.low
the file path here is one folder up then
we have graphics then we have the world
and then we have ground dot png
this one we don't have to convert
because we're not going to show it to
the player instead what i want to do i
just want to know how many tiles we
actually have in the entire thing
i want to know how many horizontal and
how many vertical tiles we actually have
this information i get by simply taking
the whole width and dividing it by the
tile size
for example for the horizontal tiles
i want to get my ground and then get
underscore with
and floor divided by the tile underscore
size
this i also need for the vertical tiles
and this i can all do on one line so v
tiles in here
and this one i get with ground dot get
underscore height
although this one also has to be floor
divided by tile underscore size
i guess while we're here let me actually
print the h tiles and the
v tiles
also i do want to call this method here
in the indented method so self.create
soil grid
although first of all i do want to
create this soil file inside of my level
that way i can show you what the
progress is while we are making it that
should make all of this easier to follow
all i really want here is from soil
import soil
layer
this soil layer should become an
attribute let's call it soil underscore
layer
and here soil layer
really important we have to pass in one
argument and that is going to be all
sprites
which we get up here
and now if i run all of this
we can see we have 50 horizontal tiles
and 40 vertical tiles
which if i look at tiled and look at map
and mid properties
we have in the top left
the width and the height and this is 50
and 40. so this one is working just fine
this i can now use to create a list of
lists with every single tile being one
individual list this is going to happen
inside of soil.pi
and what i want to create is self.grid
this one we are going to do with list
comprehension and let me add a bit of
white space in here because this one
gets slightly more complicated
first of all i want to go through every
single one of my columns and i want to
create an empty list for my column in
range
h
tiles
although this is only a single one so
i'm going to put this in another list
comprehension
which is going to be for
row in range v
tiles
now i can get rid of the white space
and let me just print what we actually
get so self.grid
run all of this
and we are getting
a very long list of lists
the entire thing is one long list
inside of this list we have one list for
each row inside of the game
and then inside of this row
we have one more list for each
individual cell
now that we have that we have to
actually check inside of tiled
let me open it again we have to know
which of these tiles are farmable and
for that we need pi tmx again meaning i
want from pi tmx dot util underscore
pi game import load underscore pi game
once i have that
i want to use load pi game and load my
tmx data file
that i get by going
up one folder there we have data in
there we have map.tmx
since we are only going to use this once
i can use a method straight away and
that is get layer
by
name
the layer we need is called farmer bill
and on this one we want to get the tiles
because this one allows us to use all of
this inside of a for loop
meaning in here this is the one we have
already seen we have for x
y
and a surface in load pi game
although for this one we don't really
care about the surface meaning i'm going
to use an underscore to just ignore it
or to indicate that i don't care about
it
what i now have to do is to figure out
which of these grid cells corresponds to
the x and y values and then add a
capital f for each of those
which is honestly very simple all i need
is self.grid
and first of all i need the row which is
the y position this is going to give me
another list and on this list i want to
get the x position which is the column
and now i'm getting a list and i want to
append a capital f to that
that is basically it if i now print self
dot grid
and run all of this
we are getting an even stranger list
what we're seeing in here is every
single cell where we have a capital f
this cell can be farmed
what you should be seeing here actually
is the first couple of lists should be
entirely empty because on the top of the
map there's nothing farmable
and we only get a bit further down
an actual f tile
i suppose we can make this a bit easier
to read by
going for row in self dot grid
and then print the row
if i now run all of this
this is well still very difficult to
read but you can see it a tiny bit
better this one here is the first row
there's nothing and this continues for a
couple more rows quite a few actually
and at some point for this row here we
have a couple of empty cells and then we
start having four cells that are
actually being farmable
if i look at this inside of tiled
you can see
on the first row we have a lot of
nothing and then we have four cells that
are going to be farmable
which is a pretty good sign that this is
going to work
i guess for one double check on the next
row we have a couple more cells that are
farmable and then we have a gap and a
few more cells
let's check this one out
on the next row we have a gap then we
have six thumb cells then we have
another gap and then a few more farmable
tiles so this is looking pretty good
with that we have a grid
that can store at least one bit of
information
it is going to get a bit more
complicated later on actually
what we now have to figure out is how
the player can hit all of those with the
whole
for that i want to create another method
and this i called create hit
rects
no need for any kind of parameters here
and what we are going to do is for every
single tile we are going to create a
rectangle that the player can hit
this i'm going to store in self.hit rex
which is just going to be a list
and now i have to cycle through
myself.gridlist
and convert all of the cells into actual
positions and for that i am going to
need the enumerate method
let's go through it slowly
i first of all want to get for row in
self.grid
and inside of that i want for
cell in
row
let me give a bit of white space here to
explain what is going to happen
we essentially have a list
that is going to contain let me draw it
really quick so we have a couple of
lists and inside of each list we have a
few more lists
the first for loop this one here goes
through all of the lists and then the
inner for loop this one here goes
through these lists here which is
basically horizontal axis
the problem we have right now is we need
to know on what list we are on for
example we have to know that this one is
list 0 this one is list 1 this one is
list two and so on
and for that we need enumerate
i want to put both of these inside of an
enumerate function
that way
we are first getting the index we are on
and then the actual information
let's call this one the index row
and the second one i called the index
column
inside of this we can actually check
every individual cell and i want to
check if f
is inside of this cell
if that is the case
i want to create an x position
i want to create a y position and then i
want to create a rectangle
and this rectangle i want to append to
myself dot hitrex dot append dot rect
and now for the position and the
rectangle i think this could be a really
good exercise i hope you're not entirely
lost at this point
but try to figure out we are now
creating a couple of rectangles and for
each rectangle we have to convert the
position in the grid to an actual xy
position inside of our game
so try if you can figure this one out
we know where each cell is inside of the
grid we also know what the tile size is
if you want a hint but pause the video
now and try to figure this one out
yourself
this is actually fairly simple all we
need for the x position is the index
column multiplying it by the tile size
for y this is going to be the index row
also multiplied by the tile size
finally then for the rectangle we have
pi game dot rekt
and in here we need x we need y
and then we need the tile size and the
tile size
meaning for this rectangle x and y is
the top left and the tile size is always
going to be 64 by 64. and that way
we have a rectangle created for every
single cell that has an f
do not forget to call this one now self
dot create hit rex
and now we actually have something the
player can hit
although i guess for this one we have to
create another method let's call this
one get hit
in here we need self and i want to have
a point and this is the point the player
can hit
in here i want to check for rect in self
dot hit underscore rects
and i want to check for each rectangle
if the rectangle was being hit by the
point we have specified in the parameter
which we get with
rect.collide point
and the point we are getting from the
parameter
if that is the case i have to convert
this rectangle position back into my
grid and that way i can identify if i
have a list with an f or not
and well for that i have to do basically
the opposite i have done here
i need an x
and i need a y position
and for the x i want to get my wrecked
dot x
and floor divided by the tile size
this i also want to do for y except now
it's rect.y
floor divided by the tile size
the way you want to think about it let's
say we have one tile here and another
tile here
the first tile starts at position zero
and zero the second one at position 64
and zero these points here
if we now for example for x have
something like
91
if i floor divide 91 by 64 we are going
to get one
which is going to be
this
tile here
that way i have converted a pixel
position this one here into an actual
tile position that we can use to get
information from this self.grid
and with that i can check if the string
f is in self.grid
and once again we have the entire list
of lists we first want to get y for the
rows and then we want to get x for the
columns
and now if that is the case i want to
print
let's call it farmer bill
what we now have to check is how to call
this self.gethit
my solution to that is i'm going to pass
a reference to the entire soil layer
into the player
which happens inside of the level
inside of the setup method
when i create the player the player is
going to have one more parameter that i
called soil layer this is going to be
self dot soil
layer
that way inside of the player
i can create another attribute
soil
layer
don't forget to turn this parameter into
an actual attribute self dot soil layer
is soil
layer
and now when we are using the tool
i
can get rid of the print statement and
when we're using the whole i want to get
self.soil layer
and that way i can target or use this
method here
which means inside of player i want dot
get
it
and the position is the same target
position we have used for the x
target position in here and now this
should be working let's try
although we're getting an error the
level object has no attribute soil layer
let's have a look
inside of level we need a soil layer and
i think i just called it soil
ah no the problem is i am creating soil
layer after the setup method
that is a very easy thing to fix all i
need is the soil layer before the setup
method
now if i run this there we go and i can
use the whole and we get farmable if i
use this here but if i go further to the
right and use it here we are not getting
anything
and let me make this a bit smaller there
we go
with that we know where we are hitting
something
or more importantly if that is farmable
or not
if that is the case
i want to get myself dot grid
with the y and the x
and append
a capital x
this is telling me that on this tile we
have a soil patch
once i have that i want to run another
method that i call create soil
tiles
this one for now is going to seem quite
weird but it is going to make much more
sense in the next video
but for now
all that this create soil tiles is going
to do
we need self in here as always
i want to get rid first of all of all of
the existing soil tiles which i get with
self.soil
sprites dot empty
after that i want to look through the
entire grid and wherever there is an x i
want to create a soil tile
which means once again i can basically
copy
all of this here
paste it in there
and in here what i want to check is if
capital x is in the cell
and if that is the case
i want to create a soil tile
this one doesn't exist right now let me
minimize a couple of methods so we have
a bit more space
we don't need any of this
although at the top i want to create
another class that i call soil tile
this one is a sprite so we need
pygame.sprite.sprite
after that we have to create a dunder
init method this one itself a position a
surface and the groups it's supposed to
be part of
then we have to call this super dunder
init method
and pass the groups in here
after that we need self.image this is
just the surface we're getting from the
parameters and we need self.rect this
one we are getting with self.image.get
underscore rect
and the top left
should be the position
the position and the surface here are
really important
finally this one is going to need a
self.set position this one fortunately
is very easy because if you look at the
settings
we have a dedicated layer for the soil
this i want to copy and paste it in here
and now we have a basic soil tile all we
have to do now is to pass in all of the
information into the class to create it
for the position this is something we
have already seen inside of create hit
rectangles we basically want to do this
one here again
i guess i can just put it straight in
here
and with that we have the position the
surface we also have that is inside of
the dunder init this soil surface here
this is what we want to paste in there
finally for the groups i want to have
self dot all sprites because they are
supposed to be visible
and then self
but i called this one the soil sprites
soil sprites
and since this is getting quite long let
me put it over multiple lines we have
the position
we have the surface
and we have the groups that is much
easier to read
and with that we should have a basic
start let's try all of this if i now hit
the floor we have a soil tile
this is working really well
and if i hit
some other field
we are not getting anything
with that we have the start of this soil
tile and we also have a really efficient
system to organize our data which is
really important
although this is getting a very long
section so let's finish it for now let's
keep on working on the soil patch
graphics the one really important thing
i want to cover in this section let me
demonstrate it
when we place one patch it looks like
this when we place another one right
next to it it looks like this
which is okay for a basic game but
ideally it should be looking something
like this
that is what we are going to create in
this section
we are going to create our own auto
titling system that creates nice looking
soil patches
this is also the reason if i jump into
my code
inside of soil layer
we have this weird setup here that every
time the player is hitting the soil we
are getting rid of all of the soil
sprites and then drawing them from
scratch
what this allows us to do is to draw all
of the soil patches together
and that way we can control different
graphics depending on the position of
each soil patch or rather if one patch
is next to another patch then they
should get a specific kind of graphic
that is what all of this here is for
although for all of this to work we are
going to need a whole lot more graphics
this is going to happen all the way at
the top
right now we only have a single soil
surface
instead what we need if i open the
folder again inside of graphics inside
of soil
we have to import all of these different
elements this is what i've shown earlier
and now
basically what all of them do
i guess i can't really make them larger
but if you look at them individually
for example here we have the left tile
this is going to be placed if there is
one tile to the right of this tile
we also have a tile called lr short for
left and right this one we want to place
if there's a tile to the right and
another tile to the left
there's also a file called x all the way
at the bottom and this one is supposed
to be placed if we have tiles all around
it
so i hope the logic here makes sense
basically each of these tiles is going
to be placed relative to where the other
tiles are
but for that we have to input all of
them
now this i want to save in self.soil
underscore surfaces
and in here you might be tempted to use
the support file this one here and use
import folder that however would not
work because we need to know which file
we are working with in all of the
examples so far we didn't really care
about what specific image we had we just
used all of them but for this one we
need to know which tile we are working
with
as a consequence
i want to create another function in
here i want to create import folder
dictionary
we again need a path
although now we want to create a surface
dictionary
what i want to have in here is obviously
a key value pair with the value being a
surface one of the surfaces we are going
to import however the key should be
something like right it should be left
it could also be something like x or lr
and this is what we are getting from the
folder so i want the key to be the name
of each of these files and the file
itself the value
and that is what we have to create in
here
and this i believe could be a really
interesting exercise look at this logic
here and adapt it so that we are
creating a dictionary with key value
pairs and at the end of it return the
entire thing
pause the video now and try to figure
this one out
a lot of the stuff i can just copy the
first three lines are going to remain
identical
because in here we are just accessing
every individual file path that we are
going to need so no change so far
as a matter of fact the surface is also
going to remain the same so a lot of the
stuff remains identical
the one difference now is when we are
getting the surface dictionary i don't
just want to append something instead i
have to get a specific key or rather i
have to create a specific key
this i want to be the file name which i
get with image and the image right now
would be something like l dot png
the png i do want to get rid of
that i'm getting with split
i want to split it wherever we have a
dot
and then i want to get the index 0 of
this list
this is always going to give me the name
of the file without the file ending
this is going to be my key and the value
is going to be the image surface
and that is all we needed all we have to
do now is to return this surface
dictionary and we are good to go
now back to soil.pi and in here i have
to import from so port
import let's say everything
and now i want import folder underscore
dictionary
and the file path i need is this one
here
i guess just to try if this is working
let me print
self.soil
surfaces
and run the entire thing
the game doesn't crash that is generally
a good sign and now we are getting what
i wanted
we have a key with for example b this
stands for bottom
and we have a surface associated with it
in this we have multiple times these are
all of the files that we wanted
with that i can close the support file
because we are not going to need it
anymore
i can also get rid of the print
statement here this one isn't needed
either
and with that we are coming to the
really fun part basically what we now
have to do is to create the entire auto
tiling option so let me go through step
by step first of all i want to add let
me call it tile options
in here i'm going to determine what is
to the left to the right to the top and
to the bottom of the current cell
which means we are going to cycle in
here through every single cell in our
grid one cell could look like this
i have to know
what is on the right on the left on top
and on the bottom
this is going to determine what graphic
we are getting in here
so first of all i want to have easy
access to all of these options
which i'm going to store in a variable
we have top we have right we have left
and we have bottom
i want to check if we have a capital x
in for example for the top self.grid
and then usually we went with y and x
although those we don't have available
right now but we do have the index row
and the index column those we can use
index column is basically x this one we
can use like this
and y is going to be the index row
this we can use here
although for the index row since we do
want to have the cell on top of our
current cell
this needs to be negative one
and i guess while we are here we can
also do the bottom because this one is
very similar
we can basically copy the entire line
and instead of a negative one we have a
positive one
for right and left we are also checking
for a capital x except now we are
checking in
the row
and we're checking
index
column
-1
this is working because we have the row
quite easily accessible and this we can
use this i want to copy one more time oh
and i just realized right should be plus
one and left should be minus one
and with that we know for each of the
tiles what the neighbors are doing now
this system is still fairly simple
because if i open the graphic again
for most of the tiles we are only
checking the four directions but there
are four more we have the top right the
bottom right the bottom left and the top
left i am not going to check any of
those because that would become
incredibly complex and i don't really
need it
but if you want to have a proper auto
titing system you would have to do it
which would lead to a ton of if
statements
but let's go through it one by one now
first of all i need to get some kind of
tile type
and this by default is going to be an o
if i open this thing here again o is the
default one the one we have already seen
and this is a nice default one if
everything else fails having this one
probably isn't going to be too bad
and now this we can use inside of soil
tile because in here we have a surface
this i want to replace with soil
surfaces
which is a dictionary and this
dictionary i can access with my tile
type and let's try this one right now if
i run main.pi
and use the whole everything works just
as before that is a good sign
and what i can do now i could for
example change this to an lr
run main.pi again
and now we are getting a different kind
of tile
all we have to figure out now is to make
all of this a lot more flexible
which is going to involve a huge amount
of if statements
let's start with the really easy one all
sides this one should illustrate the
logic here quite well
basically what i want to check is
all of these are either true or false
and i want to check if all of them are
true
this could for example be if l and b
and
r and l
if that is the case
i want to have the tile type
to be
an
x
this should be an equal sign and now
let's try this one
so here we have the center tile and i
want to create tiles to the left and to
the right and now to the bottom and
there we go the thing updated
this was the easiest kind of side
although this we can clean up a tiny bit
this we're doing with the all function
and the all function checks if all
values inside of an iterable like a list
are true meaning in here we can pass t r
b and left
and we should be having the same result
also let me put all of this on the same
line
because we are going to have a lot of
lines
let's try this one again
it should still have the same result
and it does this is looking really good
that is covering all of the sides so
next up we can start working on the
horizontal tiles only
this means i want to check if i have a
tile and if there is a tile to the left
or to the right or to
both sides
meaning we are going to have three
different if statements here
the first one we want to check if l is
true so there's a tile left and not any
inside of top right and bottom
any kind of works like all except now we
want to check if any of those is true
for all to work all of them have to be
true for any to trigger
only a single one in there has to be
true
and let me illustrate the logic here
let's say we have a tile like this
and we only want to check if there is a
tile on the left of it this is what we
are doing in here
if this is true we would ideally want
some kind of graphic that would look
something like this
this would be working by itself but we
also have to check that there are no
tiles on top to the right or at the
bottom of this tile which is what we are
doing here if that was the case we would
be needing some kind of other condition
which we are going to do in a bit but i
do not want to confuse the different if
statements here
each of those should be unique
if that is the case though i want to
have my tile type and now the tile
should be right
which means if a tile only has a tile to
the left and nothing else we want tile
type to be right
let's try this one
i have a tile here
and if i had another one this one is
going to be to the right
i can continue doing this
and now you can kind of see the one to
the right works really well but the one
in the middle gets a bit confused
but that is something we can work on
although first of all i can cover the
right side which is kind of simple all i
need is if r is true
and now
this should be t
l and b
we are basically doing the inverse of
this one here and this one should be l
then i can copy this one more time
and now i want to check if we have a
tile to the left and to the right
which means i want to check if r is true
and if l is true
and if we don't have
top and bottom
if that is the case
the tile type i want is left and right
with that i should be having the
horizontal logic
if i run this now
i can create some tiles here and this is
looking very good
although if i go down we are getting
some weird results
but that
we can start working on in the next part
which is going to be vertical only
in here i want to check if we have a
tile on top and not any tiles inside of
the list right left and bottom
if that is the case the tile type i want
should be
autumn
i can copy this one more time because
now we can check if we have a tile at
the bottom and i also want to check if
we have no tiles to the right to the
left and to the top
if that is the case i want to have a
tile with the type t
finally one more time now i want to
check if we have a tile on the bottom
and on the top
and
not
do the right to the left and that is it
if that is the case
the tiles i have are t and b
with that we have the vertical tile
types let's try this one so now if i
only go down
this is also looking really good
and i can still use
the horizontal ones as well
although now if i connect them we are
again getting weird results
which means we need some more if
statements
let's go with the corners for this one
if this is the tile i for example have
to check if there is a tile to the left
and the tile to the bottom
if that is the case this should be a
corner like that
which if you could follow along so far
should be fairly doable
it's going to look kind of similar
compared to these lines at the end here
let me copy it actually
for this one i want to check if we have
a tile to the left and a tile to the
bottom
and i do not want to have a tile on the
top and the tile on the right
and if all of that is the case i want to
have a top right tile
this logic is going to continue like
that so let me just copy from my notes
it's going to look like this
these are all of the different kind of
corners we could possibly have if i try
this one now i can go down
and now if i go to the right we have a
corner
the thing we are still missing though
are t shapes because if i do this things
are falling apart once again
which is going to be another section and
this is going to be t shapes
in here for example i want to check if
we have a tile and there is another tile
on the top on the bottom and to the
right
if that is the case i want to have this
kind of t shape
which means in here i want to have if
all
and the tiles i want to look at are
let's start with top bottom and right
also i have to check and not
left
if that is the case i want to have a
tile type of
ebr let's try this one
now i have my tile and i have a tile to
the top
to the right
i'm at the bottom and to the right and
there we go we have a t piece and now if
we add one more direction we have an x
piece so this is working just fine
this i now have to copy a couple of
times because we have to cover the other
sides as well
next up would be top bottom and left and
not right if we have that we have a
title called tbl
copy it one more time
now we have
left
right and top
and not
bottom
if that is the case the tile i want to
use is called
lrb
finally the last one
i want to check if we have left right
and bottom and not the top
and if that is the case i want to have
lrt
and with that we should have a proper
auto titling system so let's try the
entire thing now
i can just go around create more tiles
this is looking pretty good
and yeah i'm quite happy with this
although you can probably see there are
some minor thingies
these
little bits here
they exist because the auto titling
system here is not perfect for example
this tile here
is technically a corner tile where we
have a tile to the bottom and to the
right
and corner tiles always have this kind
of bit here at the end
this we could get rid of by adding a bit
more logic for this tile to also check
if there's something for the bottom
right
although in my case i think this looks
fine and if we added more logic here
this would become even more complex
and i think this is already quite a lot
of if statements so i'm going to leave
it as it is
and now i can minimize all of this and
we have definitely made a ton of
progress
for this part we are going to work on
the watering logic
which with the current system in place
isn't all that difficult to do
let's jump right in and let's do it step
by step
once more we have the entire project and
i want to start inside of the player let
me minimize everything
and we already have the use tool method
here
inside of there we have selected tool
being water
if that one is being triggered i want to
once again get myself the soil layer
remember here the player has access to
the entire soil layer this we have also
used for the whole however now i want to
use a method called water which doesn't
exist right now but will in just a
second and here once again we need our
target position
and with that we can return to the soil
file and all we have to do now is to
create another method let's do it
below get hit i call this one water in
here we need self and the target
position
what i want to check in here is if this
target position hits any of the soil
sprites any of those here
oh also i forgot the soil surface we can
get rid of because we don't need it
anymore for the water i want to check
for soil
sprite
in self.soil
sprites and there's already typo in
there
dot sprites
i want to check if soil sprite
dot wrecked dot
light point
and in here i can add my target position
and let's try this one first if that is
the case i want to print
soil tile watered
and the rest should already work let's
try i want to create a water tile change
to the watering can and now use it and
we get soil tile
watered
which means
this here is already working
this means i have to do two things
number one i want to add an entry to
this soil red
which means i want to add a capital w to
the cell
besides that number two i want to create
a water sprite this is going to indicate
that there is water on this tile
let's start with number one in here we
have the same problem again we have a
position for this soil sprite but we
need a cell position
which means we have to do some
conversion
we need an x position and a y position
and what we need in here is the soil
sprite
dot rect.x floor divided by the tile
size
this i want to do again for y let me
copy the entire thing except now this
should be rec dot y
that way i can use these positions to
access the grid
which i get with self.grid
and now i want to have my y
then i want to have my x
and then i get a list and to this list i
want to append a capital
w
that way we know which tiles have been
watered and which ones haven't
besides that number two i want to create
a water tile to visually indicate that
we have indeed watered this soil tile
this water tile i want to create
inside of this python file which is
class water tile once again this is
going to be a sprite so
pygame.sprite.sprite
we also need a dunder init method for
the obvious reasons this one needs a
position a surface and the groups
and we also need a super dunder init
method
this one gets the groups as well
although this class is going to be
fairly simple all we're going to do in
here is self.image is what we're getting
from the surface
self.rect
is going to be
self.image.getunderscorerect
with the top left being the position
like this
and finally we are going to need self
dot z
this self.set we are getting from layers
and inside of settings
we have a soil water layer this i want
to copy and paste in here
i guess if you're being specific here
this water tile and the generic tile are
basically identical but i do want to
keep things as separated as i can here
but you could be a bit more aggressive
with inheritance here it's entirely up
to you
and with that we have the water tile i
just have to call it now and for this
one we need a position we need a surface
and we need the groups
and that is going to be your exercise
there are a couple of steps to it number
one
copy the position from
the soil sprite meaning this water tile
should be in the same position as this
soil spray here which should be very
easy to get
number two for the surface
i want you guys to import the folder
with the path let me copy it really
quick the path is going to be this one
from this folder
randomly select one surface
finally
i want you guys to create one more group
let's call it water sprites
and the water tile should be in all
sprites and inside of water sprites so
pause the video now and try to work
through all four of those tasks and see
how far you get
i guess to make it easy to read let's
store it in a separate variable but all
we really want in here is the soil
spread itself then dot rect which stores
the position and then top left
that is basically it
for number two we have to import another
folder and this should happen inside of
the init method
let's do it right below graphics it does
seem to make sense here i call this one
water underscore serves
and in here we only want to import a
folder which means import folder
the file path being
this one here
in case you are interested if i open the
graphics part we have soil water and in
there we have three different water
kind of tiles
from those we want to select one
randomly
again let's do that in a separate
variable let's call it surface
and in here i want to use the choice
function which we don't have yet but we
can get it with from random import
choice
and i want to get a random self dot
water surface
and this is going to be part number two
and three actually
finally we need one more group this i am
going to do up here
and i want to create self dot water
underscore sprites i think i called it
yes
this is going to be just another group
so let me copy it and there we go
now when we are assigning the groups
i want to have self dot all sprites and
self.water
sprites
and that is all we needed with that i
suppose i can get rid of all of the
comments because they are getting a bit
annoying
there we go this feels much better
and now
if i run main.pi again
i can still use the hole and if i now
use the water we have a water tile
and i can do a couple more tiles and use
the watering can again
there we go this is working really well
the last thing we need is that once i
restart the game i want to destroy all
of the water tiles and also get rid of
the w for every single tile
that is going to be a separate method
let's call it remove water
no need for any arguments in here and
there are two things that we have to do
number one is we have to destroy
all water
sprites and the second one is clean up
the grid
the first one is really simple all we
need is for sprite in self.water
sprites
dot sprites
and i want to just destroy all of the
sprites
that is going to be the first part
the second part is going to be
for row in self dot grid
and then for cell in row what i want to
check in here is if there is a capital w
inside of this cell
if that is the case i want cell dot
remove
and the capital w
all i have to figure out now is when to
call this method this is going to happen
inside of level.pi
in here once again let me minimize
everything and i want to work inside of
the reset method
there is going to be another section
let's call it soil
and all i have to do is self dot soil
layer and remove underscore water
if i run main.pi again
i can create a couple of soil patches
water them and now if i restart the day
this is still working fine and there we
go this is looking really good
so with that we have the watering logic
we are not quite done yet with the
watering logic because we need the rain
this is going to consist of two
different parts
number one we need the actual rain
animation so that the player can tell if
it's raining or not
besides that if it is raining i want to
automatically water all of the soil
sprites
so that is what we're going to work on
let's jump right in
back in the code i want to create a new
file that i want to save as sky dot
python
in here i want to import pi game and i
also want from settings import
everything
and i want to create a class called rain
there is no need for inheritance but i
do want a dunder init method
although in here all we want is all
sprites
once again so that we can draw in here
without having to leave the class itself
this we have to save inside of an
attribute so self.all sprites is going
to be all sprites
once we have that i want to have a few
more graphic files we need self dot rain
underscore drops and i want self dot
rain underscore floor
both are going to use the import folder
function except with a different path
as a consequence i have to import
from support import let's say import
folder for this one
just to have a look at them inside of
the project i have graphics and in there
i have rain in here we have drops and
floor
drops are very simple raindrops
basically just straight lines
for the floor
we have a whole animation or it's not
really an animation we can just play
them separately but this is what we are
going to import
let me just copy the file path it is
going to be this one
and it is going to be this one
there's one more thing that we do need
and that is we need to know the size of
the entire map basically what is going
to happen
if this here is the entire map
i want to randomly create
little rain animations all throughout it
and for that to work i need to know how
wide the entire map is and how tall the
entire map is
that is information i can get from the
ground image which we have to load with
pygame.image.load
and for this one
let me copy the file path as well it is
this one and this is literally just the
ground nothing else all i want to know
is get size
and this i want to store in self
dot
let's do it via two variables we have
floor w
and self dot floor
h
once we have that we are going to need
two separate methods one for create the
floor
and besides that
we
need
create
drops
and after that i want to have an update
method that is creating both of those so
self.create floor and
self.create drops in here now we have to
figure out what to do in my case all i'm
really going to do is create a drop
class which doesn't exist yet so we have
to create it
and this i want to create inside of this
file as well plus drop
now this is going to be
applygame.sprite.sprite
although i do want this to inherit from
generic to save me a bit of writing as a
consequence i need from
sprites
import generic
i am getting much worse at spelling
essentially what i want to do is to
import this generic class here
we are using this all throughout and you
could even put the drop in here it would
be perfectly fine but i think in here it
does make a bit more sense
all i want is to create another indent
method in here we need self we need a
surface we need a position
we need to know if this one is moving or
not
then we need the groups and then we need
a z position
and how the drop is going to work it is
going to be kind of similar compared to
if i minimize all of this
it is going to be kind of comparable to
the particle
we're going to create the object for a
short period of time and then destroy it
which means we are going to have a timer
for each object and then destroy it
after a couple of milliseconds
now for that i want to have a random
live
time
which i'm getting with randint which we
don't have in here yet meaning from
random import rand int
the duration here i want to go with 400
to 500.
besides that for the timer i want to
have self.start time and this we get
with
pygame.time.get underscore ticks also
let me comment here that this should be
the general setup
because in here i guess this should be
at the top i also want to have a super
dunder init method the arguments we need
for this one are the same that we have
for generic
we need these four
all four of them are going to come from
the attributes that we are passing in
when we are creating the drop so there
isn't anything we have to do right now
although what we do have to do is to
work on the moving part
basically how that is going to work if
we have a raindrop so the things that
are going down those are supposed to be
moving
whereas the raindrops on the bottom so
the round things those are going to be
staying in place
which means i want to have another
attribute that i called moving
and this is going to capture the moving
parameter
if self.moving is true
then we need a position and this is
going to be pygame.math.vector2
and
self.direct.top left
besides that we also need a direction
and the direction here is going to be
pygame.math.vector2
and for the value here i went with
negative 2 and 4. those directions mean
we are going 2 units in the negative
direction and we're going 4 units down
as a consequence our actual movement is
something like this
finally we need self self.speed
which is going to be a random value as
well between 200 and 250.
now these three attributes is the same
thing you have seen a couple of hours
earlier inside of the player
so if i show the init method somewhere
here we have direction position and
speed
these are the attributes you basically
always need to move anything inside of
pygame
finally i want to have an update method
in here don't forget we do need delta
time
and i want to check if self.moving
if that is the case self.pos should be
plus equal
self.direction
multiplied by self.speed
multiplied by deltatime
and once we have that
self.rect.top left
should be
rounded self.post.x
and
rounded self.y
we are basically assigning the top left
of the rectangle to position.x and we're
using round to avoid the truncating that
pygin does by default
this is going to be the movement and
besides that we are going to need a
timer
that i want to destroy this timer if it
has lived longer than the lifetime
and this is going to be your exercise
create the timer that you are destroying
this sprite after the lifetime has run
out pause the video now and try to
figure this one out
all we need here is pygame.time.get
underscore ticks
this is getting our current time
from that i want to subtract
self.starttime
if that difference is greater or equal
than self dot lifetime
we know the lifetime has been exceeded
as a consequence we want to kill this
sprite
and that is all we need for the drop
now we just have to create it inside of
here and inside of here
so
let me copy all of the parameters we
need
and paste them in here
and in here or create floor the surface
is going to be self dot
rain
drops and from this we want to randomly
select one of them for that we need
choice which we don't have yet but we
can import it very easily
for the position i need to have an x and
a y position for x this should be a
number between 0
and the width of the map
that is what we created up here
which means
i need
rand int
that goes from 0 all the way to
self.floor
width
and this i also want to do for the y
position
and this should go from zero to the
floor height
next up we have moving for the floor
tiles this is going to be false
then we have the groups and the groups
are going to be quite simple because in
here all we have is self dot
all sprites
finally we need the set position and for
this one if you look at settings
we have rain floor
this i want to copy
and paste it inside of layers and there
we go
this is all we need for the floor and
now i can basically copy all of this and
do the same thing for the raindrops
it's going to be fairly similar
for the surface we want to have rain
this should actually be raindrops and
here this should be rain floor sorry
about that
the position can remain the same
moving should be true
ropes can remain the same although for
the set position
we have raindrops that's the layer all
the way on top
this i want to paste in here
and there we go this is covering the
entire rain class
so let me minimize the raindrop
and basically everything in here as well
all we have to figure out now is when to
call this rain method here
and that is going to happen inside of
the level
first of all i want from sky
import rain
this i have to turn into an actual
object
let me add another comment here actually
to organize this a bit better let's call
it the sky because there's going to be a
bit more
in here we have self.rain and this is
going to be the rain which needs self
dot all sprites
besides that i want to have another
attribute here that i called
self.raining
and this by default let's say for now it
is going to be true so it's easier to
test but later on this is going to be
random
and now
inside of the run method
before we are doing the overlay let me
add a few comments here actually
transition
overlay
i want to have my rain
all i have to do for that is check if
self.raining is true
and if that is the case i want to have
self.rain.update
that way we are calling this update
method here which is going to generate
raindrops and those drops we are going
to see hopefully in the game
so let's try
and there we go we have the rain
and honestly this is actually a fairly
simple effect
all we are doing is we are creating
random sprites that are either moving
for the rain or that are staying static
on the bottom
and well this is the entire rain graphic
if we go over this it really isn't that
complicated or at least i hope it isn't
with that i can close the sky.pi file
although we are going to see it later
but for now we don't need it
what we need now which is much more
important
we have to update all of the soil tiles
if it is raining
and for that inside of soil.pie let me
minimize everything once again because
this is getting quite extensive
i want to create another method that i
want to call right below water water
underscore all
no need for any arguments in here
and once again i want to go through all
of my grid cells
for that let me copy the nested for loop
again one more time
and paste it in here
i want to check if there's a capital x
in the cell and
w
is not in the cell
already
which basically means we're going
through all of the cells and we are
checking if there's an x meaning there's
a soil tile but this soil tile hasn't
been watered yet
but we do want to make sure that does
get watered which means first of all i
want to append
a w to the cell
and after that i want to create all of
the water tiles again
and in here let me copy it from the
water
we basically want to copy this entire
thing
although we do have to make some changes
because for this one we have a position
inside of a cell and this we have to
convert to an actual pixel position the
main thing you have to understand about
the soil layer is we are working with
two different systems
one is we have all of the positions
inside of the grid and that is basically
a table besides that we have all of the
pixel positions in the actual game
switching between them is really simple
in this case we need an x and a y
position and those we get
for x it's going to be the index column
multiplied by the tile size
and for y it's going to be the index row
multiplied by the tile size
this x and y we now want to paste into
the position for x and y
and we are good to go
the surface is going to be the same
surface we had up here i just want to
pick a random water tile i can just
paste it straight in here
and the groups can remain identical
those work just fine
with that we have a function that can
water all of our soil tiles
we now have to figure out when to call
it
and this has to happen in two separate
places
number one is when we get hit or rather
when the soil gets hit
we are attaching an x inside of the cell
here
if that is the case i want to pass in if
self.raining
which is not something we have yet but
we are going to in just a second
if that is the case i want to call
self.water
all
the problem we have right now is that
the soil layer doesn't know if it is
raining or not this we only know inside
of the level
although that is a problem that is very
easily fixed all we have to do inside of
the init method after we have set the
rain i want to get myself dot soil layer
and set raining
ooh self dot raining
also when we are resetting the day i
have to do the same thing
which means in here in a bit i want to
randomize the rain every time we are
resetting the day
once we have updated that i want to get
myself dot soil layer again and set
raining back to self dot
raining and now we always know if it is
raining inside of this class here
which means if i run main.pi and i use
the whole we automatically get water
sprites this is looking really good
and if i switch off the rain
all the way at the top
here
so raining should be false
let's try this now we don't have rain
and we don't have water at least not by
default
so all right with that we have some
basic rain logic
although what i also want
when we are resetting the day
and it is raining i want to
automatically water all of the existing
soil tiles because right now in the
logic here we are only watering new
tiles we don't water existing tiles
which means when i'm resetting the day
i want
if
self.raining is true
then
self dot soil layer dot water underscore
all
let's try this one
oh and i do have to switch on the rain
and to test this one let's randomize the
rain
meaning when i'm creating the rain
i want to have a random chance to create
a rain which i'm getting with rent int
which i don't think i have available yet
i do not
i need from random import rand int
and in here i'm just creating a number
between 0 and 10
and if this number is let's say
greater than 7 this is going to be true
although for now for testing purposes
i'm going to set this number to a free
which means we're going to have a ton of
rain
this i also want to do down here
actually i can copy the entire line
like
so
and now for every day we have a pretty
high chance to generate rain
if i run this
it's raining right now but we can still
get started and let's go to bed
and let's hope there we go now there's
no rain so there's no water on them and
i guess let me water one of them just
for testing purposes
if i now go to sleep again
[Music]
it's not raining
now it's raining again
and all of the soil tiles have been
watered so this is working really well
very nice
and with that we have the basic watering
logic so another major step forward next
up we can start working on the plans
let's get started with the plans since
we already have a ton of logic in the
soil this shouldn't be so bad actually
but once again let's go for this step by
step
the very first thing we need is inside
of the player we need to know if the
player is planting some seeds
for that we already have a method that
is called use seed right now there's
nothing in there but
that is going to change
i want to get this soil layer once again
and now call a method that i called
plant seed for this one we need two
arguments the first one is going to be
self dot the target position the second
one is self dot selected not tool but
seat
and i hope this makes sense we have to
know what target we are hitting and we
want to know what kind of seat we are
using this is all we need inside of the
player and now in the soil
in the soil layer
i want to minimize all of the methods
and
let me put it
let me put it all the way below the
water in here
i want to have planned underscore seat
we need self we need a
target position
and we need a
and once again we have to check if we
actually hit a soil sprite which we get
before
soil sprite
in
self.soil sprites dot sprites
i want to check if
soilsprite.rect.collide.point
and the point i want to check is the
target position
if that is the case once again i have a
pixel position and this i want to
convert to a position inside of the grid
which means i need my soil sprite or
direct.x
and floor divided by the tile size
i can duplicate this line and change the
x to a y and that way i'm getting my y
position inside of the grid
if that is the case i want to get myself
dot grid with my y and x
this is going to give me the cell and i
want to append a capital p
short for a plant
that way we know we have a plant inside
of this cell
now this should only be possible once
which means i can already
check if a capital p
is
not
in
self dot grid
with
y
and x
and only if that is the case i want to
create a plant now that we have that i
want to create a plant object
this i am creating also inside of this
python file with class
land
and this one is also going to be
pygame.sprite.sprite
i want to have a dunder init method with
self we need a plant
pipe so do we want corn or tomato
then we want groups next up i need the
soil for the positioning and let's say
that's it for now
as always i need the dander init method
with the
roots
i have to convert the plant type
parameter into an attribute so
self.plant type is plant type
and then i have a couple of frames
depending on what kind of plant we have
meaning here's the project i have
graphics inside of there we have fruit
and there's corn and tomato not the best
naming but it really doesn't matter
inside of corn we have these different
files and inside of tomato we have those
this is what we are going to import
this we get with import folder and the
file path here is let me just copy it
right away
we have to go into graphics and fruit
and in there we have two subfolders and
those subfolders i want to get with an f
string
because what we can use in here is the
planned type
besides that we need self dot h
by default this is going to be zero
after that we also need self.max h so
that we know when the plant is reaching
the full h
this we can get with self.
frames and get the length of it and
subtract 1 from that
finally i want to have
self.grow underscore speed
which is telling me how fast this kind
of plant is growing and for that inside
of settings i have a dictionary this is
what i want to use
meaning i can use grow speed in here
and then get the plant type
i guess i should really comment all of
this a bit better to make it a bit
easier to understand
let's call this section here the plant
growing
and this stuff at the top is going to be
the setup
also there's one thing i forgot we have
to turn
the soil into an attribute so self.soil
is going to be soil once we have all of
that we can work on the sprite set up
first of all here we need self.image
this is very easy because we have a
bunch of frames i want to use self.h for
the indexing
besides that i have to create self.rect
this i'm getting with
self.image.getunderscorerect
i want to place the mid
bottom
and the position i'm getting from
soil.rect.mit
although here we have a problem
this is going to be the size of a soil
tile but each plant is going to be about
this tall and since we're placing the
bottom of the plant at the bottom
of this soil tile we're going to be
somewhere here
and i want there to be some kind of
offset
this i created separately and i called
it self dot y underscore offset
this is going to be negative 16 if the
plant
type
is equal to corn and if that is not the
case it's supposed to be negative 8. the
reason here is that the various plans
are very different in size we do have to
account for that
and to use that i have to turn it into a
vector which means pygame.math.vector2
this needs to be capitalized
for x it's supposed to be zero and for y
it is going to be self dot y offset
we are nearly done the last thing we
need is self dot z
in here we need layers as always and for
the plants we actually have two
different layers
the one we are going to start with is
the
round plant
this i want to paste in here and this
means if you look at the settings the
plans are always going to be below the
player
by default i want the plans to be
non-collidable so the player can just
walk on top of them but once they have
grown i want them to be on the main
layer and the player should be able to
collide with them but that's going to
come in a bit i guess for now we have
added a ton of stuff so let's actually
create one of the plans and see how far
we get
so when i create a plant i need a plant
type the groups and the soil
this one should be fairly simple because
the plant type is going to be the same
as the seed
the soil is also going to be very simple
because all we need in here is the soil
sprite
for the groups i do want to have one
group specifically for the plants
this is going to happen in the init
method of the soil layer in here i want
to have self.plan
underscore sprites
once again this is just going to be
pygame.sprite.group
and now for the groups
each plant should be
inside of self dot all sprites
it should be inside self dot blend
not types but sprites
and let me fix this typo here
and let's actually try this
so in the game i can use a hole and now
if i press left ctrl
we get some seeds that we can walk over
and this i can do multiple times
also with e i can change the seed and
now we get a tomato this is working
surprisingly well
cool so i'm very happy with that what we
now have to figure out is how to make
the plants grow
inside of the
we need an update or some kind of an
update method
this one i called grow
there is no need for an argument in here
and now we have a problem because the
plant needs to know if the soil it is in
was watered but this information we
don't have available right now what i
want to happen is that each plant can
access the soil layer and check out
self.grid
know if the tile it is in was watered or
not
and for that i am going to create
another method
that is going to be fairly simple though
i called this one
check
watered
in here we need some kind of position
this position will be entered by the
plant itself
i want to get the actual cell and right
now once again we have a pixel position
this we have to convert into an actual
grid position so we can access the grid
the same thing we have done here
actually
let me copy the entire thing actually
and fix the indentation
there we go
to get the cell all i want is self.grid
and y and then x
once i have that i can check is watered
and is watered we are getting with
capital w
in cell
meaning this could ever be true or false
and that is the information i want to
return so return is watered
now this method i am going to pass into
a plant whenever we create it
which happens down here
each plant is going to have access to
self.js
watered
for this we have to create another
attribute after soil
i want to have check watered
this we have to turn into an attribute
so
self.jackwatered is check watered
and now we can create this grow method
all i have to do is check if self dot
check watered
with self dot wrecked dot center
remember here check water it needs a
position and i'm just going to go with
the center remember here check water did
need a position
if that is the case
i want to add self dot
h plus equal self.grow
speed
and after i have that i can run
self.image is going to be self.frames
and i can use self.h again although now
we do have to be careful because this
age
could be a floating point value which we
couldn't use for indexing but if we turn
it into an integer this is going to work
again and after that i can turn this
into a rectangle
which i am getting with self.image
actually let me copy
this one here
because it isn't going to change besides
that now the main reason why i am
updating the rectangle is because the
image is going to change and we might
have different dimensions
which means we have to get a new
rectangle
but other than that this is the basics
of the grow method
what we now have to figure out is when
to call it
for that inside of the soil layer i
created another method update
plans
all i need in here is for planned in
self.plannedsprites.sprites
i want plant.grow
and this method i now want to call
inside of the level
when we are resetting the day so in here
let's do it all the way at the top
we have the plans
self. soil layer dot
update underscore plants
and that should basically be it i guess
the one thing you want to be careful
about here is that this should be called
before all of this
because for example if we called it
after is raining with this method here
we might water all of them and then
update all of the plants which would be
a tiny bit weird
let's try
so i want to grow some corn
make sure i am watering it and now let's
update the entire day
and we are getting an error that name
soil sprite is not defined
this probably happened inside of here
ah right
jack watered has the problem right now
that this should be
position
zero and
position
one
because what we actually pass in here
inside of the plant is self.record
center which is giving us a tuple with
an x and a y position
now let's try this again next attempt
i want to plan some coin again
and start a new day
and we are getting another error
this one happens down here inside of
plant.grow so let's have a look at this
one
and the problem is happening somewhere
in here
the problem is we don't have the soil as
an attribute this we can fix with self
dot soil
ready next attempt
let's try it again
let's see if i made another mistake
now it's working and there we go this
definitely grew
let me water it by hand
and start another day and there we go
this keeps on growing
and now if i start another day it should
be fully grown there we go now if i
start another day this is going to crash
because we are running out of frames but
this was expected
other than that this is working just
fine we do have a very good start now we
just have to make some more updates to
the plant and then we are nearly done
with the plants and with most of the
game actually
first of all once the plant is reaching
the max age i want the plan to stop
growing which happens inside of grow all
i want to do in here is if self.h
is greater or equal than self dot
max h and if that is the case self.h is
going to be self.max
h
although if that is the case i want to
indicate that the plant is ready for
harvesting
which i am doing via another attribute
that i called harvester bill
and harvestable is going to be true once
this condition here is true so we can
set this to true
with that the game is not going to crash
anymore although what i also want to do
is if the plan starts to grow it should
be on the main layer and the player
should be able to collide with it
this could be a good exercise
if the plant
h is greater
than zero so if we have one and above
then the plant should be on the main
layer
and pause the video now and see if we
can figure this one out
for this one we need an if statement and
i want to check if self.h is greater
than zero
if that is the case i want to update
self dot z
which now should be inside of
layers
and the main layer
although there is one thing you really
want to be careful about because self.h
could be a floating point value and we
only want to do this line here
if the plant is greater than one
which we can get quite easily
with integer if you didn't do this
self.h might be something like
0.7 which would be greater than 0 but
the plant itself would still be a tiny
seed
which the player should walk on top
so integer ensures
that we have a certain kind of plan size
if i run the game now let's hope it
doesn't crash
i can
land something
and if i now update the entire thing it
doesn't crash and now we should be
behind and in front of all of this stuff
so this is working just fine
what we now have to figure out is the
collision mechanic
and for that if i look at the player
again at collision
in here the plans don't have collisions
yet because they don't have a hitbox
which we are checking here
but that we can fix quite easily
once a plant has a certain age it should
have self.hit
box
and this is just going to be
self.direct.com
p
and this i want to inflate
and now i need an x and a y dimension
again
for x is going to be negative 26
and for y it is going to be self
self.rect.height
multiplied by 0.4 and this should be
negative that is all we needed if i now
run main.pi
and let's create a tomato for now
if i plant this one although i think
this takes two days to grow but that's a
good way to double check
so now i can still walk over the tomato
plant
but if i sleep again
now we have a grown plant and there is
no collision yet
and i also know why
the reason is
the plants are not inside of the
collision sprites method
so when i am creating a plant
it needs to be inside of self.collision
sprites
the problem is
the soil layer doesn't have that one
although that we can change
i want another attribute with the
collision sprites
and let me put this right below all
sprites
self.collision sprites is going to be
collision
sprites
now inside of level when i create the
soil layer which happens here
i also want to pass in
self.collision sprites
now let's try this again
i want to plan some corn because that
one is faster and now if i restart the
day
we have something and now we have
collisions
this is looking really good
cool so with that we have the basics of
the plant
although we cannot harvest them but that
is going to be the next section
with the plants being done the last
thing we have to do is the harvesting
part or at least the last thing we have
to do for the plans there is going to be
quite a bit more
let's jump right in and once again let's
go through it step by step
back in the code what i basically now
have to figure out is
if a plant is harvestable so this line
here is true
and i have a collision with the player
so this player here
then i want to destroy the plant and
update the player inventory
all of this is going to happen inside of
level.pi
i want to create let's call it planned
collisions
or collision
there's no need for any parameters in
here first of all i want to check if
there are any plans in the first place
which i get with self dot soil layer dot
plant
underscore sprites
if there are no plans this is not going
to trigger
and then there's no point doing any of
all of this
if there are no plans this would not
trigger in here i want to check for
plant in
self.soil layer dot plant sprites dot
sprites
that way i can access every individual
plant and what i want to check is if
plant dot harvest bill
and
the plant.rect.colliderect
with self.player.hitbox
we are checking if the plan can be
harvested and if the plant is colliding
with the player
if that is the case i want to destroy
this plant
make sure to call this plant collision
right after update which happens here
i want to run self.planned
collision
and now let's try all of this
we're getting an error
that
inside of level
this should be planned sprites
so should this one here
now let's try this again
there we go i can plant some corn and
water this
and now i have to do a
bit of
restarting the day
but the game is definitely coming
together
now it's raining so i can go straight
back to sleep
and now if i collide with this it
disappears cool this is a very good
start
although we do have to a few more things
in here
first of all i want to run self dot
player underscore add
and in here i want to get the planned
and then dot planned underscore type
that way we are updating the player
inventory so there's an actual reason to
harvest something
and this we should probably test so once
again all the way at the end of the run
method i want to print self dot player
dot item inventory
if i run this now
we get the entire inventory and i want
to plant some corn
now i have to restart it's still raining
it's also raining and we need one more
day
and now if i collide with this we get
corn one this is working very well
so let me delete this print statement
here again and now we can keep on
working in here
i also want to create a particle when
the plant disappears which we don't have
available yet
we do not
but i can import it quite easily
i want a particle which we're getting
from the sprites this one here
and now i need all of the arguments to
create it
so let me copy
these ones here
paste them in here
and now we have to figure out all of
them again
for the position i want to have
land.rect.top
left
for the surface i want to have planned
dot image and for the groups this should
be self dot all sprites
for the z layer i want to have the
layers
and in here this should be main
this should be all we need once again
let's try this
and i do hope it starts to rain this is
looking good
raining again one more time
and now we should have a particle effect
and there we go this is looking good
the last thing we need is whenever we
destroy the plant we still have inside
of the grid
let me minimize the plans
the last thing we need inside of this
soil grid
we have to remove the capital p that way
we can create another plant
for this one i need
self.sawyer layer once again
and now we need the grid
the problem is right now we only have an
x in the y position and for the grid we
need rows and columns
which means we need a row and we need a
volume
and once we have that i want to remove
any kind of capital p
and this column is going to be your
exercise
see if you can figure this one out
for the row we are going to need the y
position of the plant which we get with
plant.rect.com
y
and this i want to flow divide by the
tile size
for
the column this is going to work in the
same way except now we need center x
and with that we should be good to go
so now if i run main.pi again
now if i plant some corn
and restart the day
it's raining again we do have to wait
until the thing grows completely
now it should be working and
now we are getting an error because i
made a typo
this should be tile size
okay once again
let's try this again
and
testing a game can be very annoying it's
not raining but i guess all of this is
good way to test all of this
let's try it one more time now it is
raining it keeps on growing and
now it is completely grown
if i touch it it disappears and now i
should be able to create a new plant so
let me plant a tomato
and there we go we have a tomato
i guess
if i restart the date just to be sure
all of this is working
one more time
and it is growing cool so this is
working as well
with that we have the harvesting logic
this honestly wasn't so bad
or at least i hope it wasn't
there isn't actually that much more to
do but there's one thing i did forget to
do and that is the night transition or
the daytime transition let's do this one
next
for the day transition we kind of have
to do the same thing we have done for
the transition between different days we
are basically creating an image on top
of the entire game and then we use
blending modes to merge the two
i probably should have done this a
couple of hours ago when we worked on
the transition but well here we are
back in the code i want to do all of
this inside of my sky because it kind of
fits in there
let me reopen it we need the sky in here
besides the drop and the rain all the
way at the top i want to have let's call
it sky
we need a dunder init method in here
with self and now first of all we need
the display surface
which as always we get with
pygame.display.get
underscore surface
besides that we are going to need an
image that covers the entire window
which i called self.full
surface just surf is fine
and this we get with pygame dot surface
and in here
i can once again from my settings get
the screen width and the screen height
let me copy in the screen width and this
green height
and now we have a full surface
once i have that i want to let me call
it display
in here we need self and we also need
delta time and essentially all i want to
do here is self dot display surface dot
blit
i want to have myself dot full surface
at the position 0 and 0 that will be
covering the entire window and finally
we need a special
blacks which in this case is going to be
pygame dot blend underscore rgba
underscore mult
right now this is going to be entirely
black so there isn't too much point but
let's use it right away also i want to
close the soil at least for now to keep
things a bit more organized
i can also close the sprites because i
don't think we need it at all anymore
inside of the level
i want besides rain also import sky
and the sky has to be an attribute
let's put it right here self.sky is
going to be sky once we have that inside
of the run method
after the rain
i want to have the day
time
like that
and this we get with self.sky
dot display
in here we do need to at a time although
not right now but we do need it to call
the method
if i run this now
everything is going to be black
the reason is we are putting a black
surface on top of the entire window
which well isn't particularly helpful
although what i want to do now is self
dot start
color
and this start color is going to be a
list with the values 255 255 and 255
before i am displaying this surface i
want to fill it with that color so
self.color serve.fill with
self.startcolor
once we have that we shouldn't be seeing
anything we can see the game itself this
is looking as always
but now what we can do with this setup i
could for example change this to a0 and
if i now run this again
we get a bunch of weird colors
and this way we can control how the game
is going to look like
in my case i want to transition from a
pure white color
to myself dot and color
which is going to be the tuple 38 101
and 189
just to illustrate what this one is
going to look like
let me run it in the game it's going to
look like this
this is very much night time
all we have to figure out now is how to
transition from this value to this value
here how this is going to look like is
i'm going to look at every individual
value and subtract it by a certain
amount let's say negative 2.
and this i'm going to do until we're
reaching
this particular point
this point here so you can see it
this is also going to happen for the
second one this is going to go until
this point here and for this one as well
up to this point here
this i am getting with for value in self
dot and color
although in here i do need the enumerate
method because i need to know what index
i am on so i have my index and i have
the value
i want to check if self dot start not
time but
color
is greater than the value and if that is
the case self dot start color
with the index
should be minus equal 2 multiplied by
delta time
also when i am filling all of this this
should be the start color
we are looking at every single color
inside of n color against this we are
checking on this line here
if the corresponding value inside of
start color let's say the first one 255
is greater than the end color 38 in this
case and if that is the case we want to
reduce the start color value by a
certain amount
and this we want to do until we reach
the end point and with that we should be
having a transition let's try now
and we are getting an error
this one here should be start color and
index
and now all i have to do is wait
i guess while i'm doing that i can run
around a bit to check out the entire
level i've been very focused on specific
tasks but well the entire game is coming
together pretty nice
also here you can see the trader and now
since we have a collision block here we
cannot move over him anymore
we're going to work on the trader in
just a second
and everything else is working really
well
okay probably i'm just going to speed up
this entire game because i am running
out of things to talk about so let's
speed it up a bit
alright i think at this point you can
definitely tell things are getting
darker
this is definitely working
all we have to figure out now
is once we have
all of this color here we have to set it
back to the starting position so 255 255
and 255
whenever we are
resetting
the entire day
this is also going to be fairly simple
all we have to do let me add another
comment here sky i want to get self.sky
dot start color
is going to be 255 255 and 255.
that
if i now wait a tiny bit let me speed
all of this up
all right now we can definitely tell
things are getting darker so let me
restart the day
and there we go this is much brighter
with that we have the daytime cycle
really wasn't that bad
and this is literally all we need for
the sky meaning i can minimize it and
close the entire python file
and we are almost done
the last major bit of the game is going
to be the merchant so let's work on that
one there are quite a few different
elements we have to cover here
back in the code first of all the player
is going to need let me minimize
everything
the player is going to need a full
inventory we already have a couple of
things in here we have this kind of
inventory
but we are going to need a tiny bit more
we also need
self.seed underscore inventory and this
one is going to have two key value pairs
we have
corn
and by default let's say we have five
and besides that we have tomato five in
here would also work well
finally besides that we are going to
need self dot money
and for starting value here let's go
with 200 it's entirely arbitrary
this is going to be the inventory for
the player and this is also what we're
going to access when we are doing the
merchant
although before we are coming to that
there's one more thing that i want to do
and that is that the player shouldn't be
able to use a seat once we are running
out of seat
for example the player can only use corn
if this number here is at least one
let me minimize the init method and all
of this happens inside of use seed
all i want to do in here is if self dot
seed inventory
and then i want to pick myself dot
selected seed
and only if this is greater than zero
then i want to plant a seed
besides that inside of here as well i
want to get myself dot seed inventory
get the selected self dot selected seed
again
and subtract it by one
with that we can start working on the
merchant itself
let me explain how it's going to work
here we are back in tiled and the trader
is all the way in the top left
what you can see around the trader is
inside of player we have a trader area
this is going to work kind of like the
bad if the player is inside of this area
presses enter
then we are going to start the merchant
menu
back in the code when we are creating
the level more specifically when we are
running the setup method
in here a bit further down
we are checking for the start position
of the player
if there is a bad and besides that i
want to check
if object
is equal to
trader
if that is the case i want to create
another interaction object meaning i can
duplicate this line here and paste it in
here
with that we are actually done all of
these arguments here can stay identical
since we're getting information from
tiled all of this is going to be done
automatically the only major change here
is going to obj name because this one
now is going to be trader instead of bad
but with that we have the interaction
object
we have to do a tiny bit more inside of
the player
inside of the input method all the way
at the bottom
we have created this line a couple of
hours ago and that is if the player is
inside of the interaction area and we
have trader then we want to do a certain
thing
basically what i want to do is to run a
method called self dot toggle underscore
shop
this one doesn't exist right now but
basically what i want to do is inside of
the level
i want to create another method let me
minimize everything in here so it's a
bit easier to see
inside of the level class
i want to let me do it below player ad
this one i want to call toggle
underscore shop in here we need self and
nothing else and this is a fairly simple
method
all i really want to do in here is self
dot shop
active
is going to be not self self.shop
active
meaning whenever we are running this
method we are switching shopactive
either on or off
this attribute doesn't exist right now
so we do have to create it this happens
inside of the init method in here let's
put it under another section
shop
and by default this one needs to be
false
if this one is true though we are going
to show the shop menu
but that is going to come later first of
all
we have to pass this method here into
the player which happens inside of setup
and in here we have the player and the
player is going to get another parameter
toggle shop
which is going to be self dot toggle
shop
for that to work inside of the player
all the way at the top
let me minimize the input method and
inside of the indent method we need
toggle
shop
and for this one
inside of interaction
i want to create another attribute self
dot
or girl shop is going to be toggle shop
and with that we should be having a
pretty good start
i suppose we can test this inside of
the run method
all the way to bottom
i want to print
self dot
shop
active
and this we should be able to influence
with the player
so let's run the game
and we are getting thoughts right now
that is a very good sign
and if i walk to the merchant
and if i press enter right next to him
we're getting true if i press it again
we're getting false
so this is a very good sign
and with that we can start working on
the actual merchant for that i want to
create a new file
and save it as menu dot
pi
in here as always we are going to need
import pygame and we also need from
settings import everything
after that i want to create a new class
that i call menu
in here we need a dunder init method
this one itself
it needs the player and it also needs
toggle
menu
so we can switch off the menu from
inside of the menu
inside of this i want to have a general
setup
for this i want to turn the player into
an attribute so self.player is player
the same i want to do for the toggle
menu so self.toggle menu is going to be
toggle menu
and besides that i am going to need two
more things first of all i need the
display
surface
this as always i'm getting with pygame
dot display dot get underscore
surface
and besides that i need self dot font
the font we get with pygame dot bond dot
font be careful here about the
capitalization the first font is
lowercase the second font is uppercase
this we want to call and in here we need
a font style and we need a size
the size is easy because we just want an
integer in my case 30.
for the font
we need an actual file
in my case
here's the project folder and we have
font and in there we have a file called
lychee soda this is what i want to
import
the file path for that is going to be a
string
and i want to go one folder up
to font
and then to lichi
so
da dot ttf
and with that i have a font
with all of that covered basically what
i want to do i want to create an update
method that one itself and nothing else
and this is actually going to show the
menu although we do have to do quite a
bit of work to get this one done
for now just to see if this is working i
want to show some blank surface
which means i want self.display
surface dot blit
in here i want to create a surface from
scratch and this one is going to have a
dimension of let's say
one thousand and one thousand
the position here is going to be zero
and zero
the way we are going to call it inside
of level.pi
i want to get rid of print shop active
and instead first of all at the top i
want from menu
import menu
inside of the init method
i want to create an object from the
class so self.menu
is going to be
menu
the two arguments we need here from menu
we need player and toggle menu
layer is really easy because we have
self dot player
toggle menu is also very easy because in
here we have self dot this one is called
toggle shop though but same thing i can
just paste it in here and we are good to
go
inside of the run method i have to do
some reorganizing
the first two lines can stay identical
and let me add a few more comments here
to make all of this a bit clearer
the first two lines are let's call it
drawing logic
after that we have the updates
in here i want to check if
shop
active
if that is the case i want self dodge
menu dot update i think i called it
yeah update i want to call this method
here
and only if that is not the case so else
i want to do
these two lines here
if the menu is active the player cannot
move anyway so there's no point updating
all of the sprites or any of the planned
collisions it's simply not necessary as
a matter of fact i want to stop the
entire game while the menu is open this
is going to include the rain as well
which means it's only supposed to rain
if raining is true and not self dot shop
active
only then do i want to update the rain
the overlay however can stay here
let's put all of this under the weather
section actually
and let me remove these comments i think
this makes the most sense
with that we have the entire run logic
let's try it
so in
it still works and now i want to run to
the shop
and in here i want to press enter
and the game is crashing
because inside of menu this one should
be pi game dot surface
and while i'm here i also realized this
should be
inside of another tuple
now let's try this again
and next to the merchant i press enter
and now we have a big black rectangle
and the rest of the game also doesn't
update which is a very good sign
which means this one is working we just
have to add more logic to it the most
important one for now is that we need an
input method so that we can switch off
the menu as well
this is actually going to be your
exercise
i want you guys to get the input
and then
if the player presses
escape
close the
menu
pause the video now and try to figure
this one out it should be fairly doable
first of all we have to get all of the
keys this we get with pygame dot key dot
get underscore pressed
once we have that i want to check if
keys and pygame dot a underscore escape
if that is the case i want to run self
dot toggle menu don't forget we also
have to call self dot input
but other than that this should be it
back at main.pie let's run this again
and right next to the merchant i press
enter and now if i press escape
the game continues and this i can do
multiple times this is working really
well
so with that we can toggle the menu
with that we can actually start creating
the proper one
and for that i first of all want to have
a couple of options the most important
one for now is self dot width
and this one i set to 400
this is going to be the entire window
and inside of it roughly here
i want to have the menu
inside of the menu we're going to have
individual entries like
so
what with is determining right now is
the width of this entire menu
besides that i also want self dot space
that is the space between the elements
this i set to 10 and then self dot
padding
and this i set to 8. once we have that
information
i want to create the actual menu entries
and for that first of all we are going
to need all of the i call this one the
options
what this is going to be inside of the
player
in the init method we have the inventory
this is going to be what i want for the
options for the menu
and i am going to combine all of those
into one list
self dot player dot item underscore
inventory and i only really care about
the keys here
don't forget to call this and this i
want to turn into a list
this list i want to combine with the
seeds
let me copy it and to combine it to
lists i need plus and copy this list
and i want to have the seed inventory
this one here
to make sure this one is working let me
print what we get self dot options
and now if i run this
and close the game
here you can see we have all of the
different options
apple corn and tomato are the inventory
of the player so the items corn and
tomato are the seeds
although now we do have a problem let me
run it again actually
inside of this list i need to know which
of these items can be sold and which
ones can be bought
the items should be only sellable so
these four items i want to be able to
sell and these two items here i can only
buy as a consequence i need to figure
out where i'm drawing this line here
where we end the selling menu and start
the buying menu for that i created
another attribute that i called cell
border
this is basically self dot player dot
item inventory i am getting the length
of it and from this i'm subtracting
negative one
later on i'm going to cycle through this
list and for every item i am going to
check the index and check if it is
smaller or greater than this border
if it is smaller we are selling if it is
greater we are buying
and with that i can create is self.setup
method
let's do it right below
this one doesn't need any arguments
the most important thing i have to do in
here is to create the text surfaces
all of those are going to be stored in
the list and the list i called text
surfaces
for now it's just going to be an empty
list
all of these items are going to be
created with four item in self dot
options
that is the list we have created up here
all i have to do is to create a text
surface and this i am getting with
self.font.render
in here we need a string
we need anti-alias and we need a color
the color is the easiest bit i just want
to have black in here
anti-alias should be false and the
string should just be the item
once i have that text surface i want to
get myself dot text surfaces and append
the individual text surface
i also just realized this one should be
set up not input
now with that we have a list of surfaces
this we can now use inside of the update
method in here i can get rid of this big
black rectangle and instead i want to do
for text
surfaces in self.text
serves
although remember what i explained
earlier
for this logic here to work to separate
between the by and the cell menu i need
to know the index of every item inside
of this for loop
as a consequence i am going to use the
enumerate method
here and let's call this one text index
i suppose for now all we have to do is
self dot display surface dot blit
we have a text surface
and for the position
let's say we can go with a hundred for x
and for y i want to have the text
index
multiplied by 50.
let's try all of this now
and once again i have to walk to the
trader
here we are at the trader if i run this
we can see the different entries so this
is looking really good we can also end
the menu and this is working very well
very good we are making progress
although now we do have a problem right
now the height is basically random so we
have to figure this out more
deliberately
this is also going to happen inside of
the setup method
besides the text surfaces i want to have
self.total
height
by default this is going to be zero
inside of the for loop i want to get
this total height
and plus equal
self dodge text
surface
and then get underscore height
although don't forget i also want to add
plus
self dot
heading
multiplied by two and this i want to put
in brackets that looks a bit cleaner
each of those text entries let's say we
have three for now
inside of those the text is only one
part in the middle
and there should be some space or some
padding between the top and the bottom
of the text this is what we're getting
with self.padding the entire height
though is what we're getting from
self.total height this is what we're
going to use in just a second to center
the entire menu
although there's one more thing that we
do need
because if i open the drawing again
between each of the entries so this
space here
there should be some more space that is
the space we have set up earlier in here
to get that number
let's do it here i want to get self dot
total height
and i want to add a number number i want
to get the
text surfaces and i want to know how
many items i have so i want to have the
length
right now that number would be free
because we have one two and three
elements
from that i want to subtract one for the
simple reason that we only have one
space for any two elements
as a consequence if we have three
elements in total we want to have two
spaces between them all of this i want
to put inside of another bracket and
this i want to multiply with self dot
space
and now i have the total height
this i can use to calculate self dot
let's call it menu top
this is going to be the top part of the
menu
for this number i need in my settings
the screen height
and this i want to divide by two
from this number i want to get myself
dot total height
and divide this by two as well
this here is going to be the entire
screen and screen height divided by 2
would be roughly this point here
from that i want to subtract self.total
height divided by 2.
that would be
roughly let's say here with this being
the first half and the other half would
be below so one half here that way the
menu is always going to be in the middle
there's one more attribute i want and
this i called self dot main
rect
this is going to be the bounding box for
the entire menu and this is going to be
a rectangle so pygame.rect
in here we need the left the top the
width and the height
figuring those numbers out could
actually be a really good exercise so
try to figure them out yourself and see
how far you get
there are three numbers in here that
should be fairly simple the top is what
we have just done it's just self.menu
top
so i can place this one in here
the width is also very easy that is the
number we have created up here
which means i want to have self dot
width
height is also easy this is just going
to be self dot total height
the only minor complication is the left
side
to get this one we kind of need the same
logic we have used here i first of all
want to get my screen
width
and this i want to divide by two
from that i want to subtract self dot
width and subtract this by two as well
with that we should be having a
rectangle that is in the center of the
window and also is as tall as all of the
text elements
i guess let me minimize the setup method
and try this one
i guess for now we can comment out this
for loop here and instead
i want to pygame.draw.rect
i want to draw on self.display
underscore surface
the color let's go with red
and the rectangle is going to be self
dot main rectangle
and just for testing purposes it's going
to be kind of annoying to always walk
towards the merchant
so inside of the player
let me go to the input method
and then here if the player is pressing
enter i want to toggle the shop already
like this
now if i run the game
i am getting an error
this happens inside of menu inside of
setup
and this self.text surface shouldn't be
yourself it's just a text surface so
we're getting this one here
now let's try this again we're not
crashing and now if i press enter
we're getting a menu in the middle of
the window i can also press escape and
the game continues as always
so this is working quite well
i suppose next up we can start working
on another important ui element and that
is display underscore money
there's no need for any arguments in
here and all we are going to do in here
is first of all we need a money surface
or rather
since we have local variables this can
be a text surface
all i want in here is self.font.render
in here again we need a string we need
anti-alias and we need a color the color
once again is going to be black and
anti-alias is going to be false
it is false here because i have pixel
fonts which don't look good when you
enter and use them
finally for the string what i want to
access is inside of the player in the
init method
i want to access
this money attribute here this i get
with self dot player dot
money
although this i want to put inside of an
f string
like this because that way i can add a
dollar sign before
once i have that i can create a text
rectangle
this is just going to be the text
surface dot get underscore rect
and in here i want to place the mid
bottom
for the position here i want to have
this green
width divided by two so we are right in
the middle and then i want to have this
green height and subtract 20 from here
that way we are slightly off centered
from the bottom of the window
once we have those two bits i can get
myself dot display surface and split the
text
surface and the text
rectangle
and now all i have to do is to run self
dot display money and this should be
working
so inside of main or pi i press enter
and we can see the money in the bottom
center of the window
this is working very well
although there's one more element i want
to add
and that is a background
for this text this i get with pygame dot
draw.rect
and in here i want to draw on
self.display surface
the color for this one should be white
the rectangle i want to use in here is
the text rectangle although i do want to
inflate this one by a tiny bit
let's say 10 and 10 pixels
if i run this now
this is already looking much better
although i do want to have some rounded
borders
this i can also get very easily
i need to add two more arguments
the first one is the border width which
in my case is going to be zero and then
we have to border radius
which in my case is going to be 6 and
this 6 here determines the border radius
or how much rounding we get
if i run this now
we have some rounded borders which makes
the entire thing look much nicer
i guess you can play around with
different numbers here let's try four
yeah i guess this one looks a bit better
but again this is pretty subjective so
choose whatever you think is best
with that we have finished the money
this is all we need in this one
i guess next up we can work on all of
the actual entries and we already have
some good starting points here we have
access to all of the text surfaces and
we know their index
this i can use inside of another method
let me call it show
entry
in here we do need a couple of arguments
i want to have a text surface so the
text i want to show that i want to have
the amount
like so
then i need the actual position and this
is going to be top
with all of that i can start working on
this and first of all in here i need a
background
after that we are going to create the
text and later on we are also going to
show an amount
but let's get started with the
background
in here i want to create a bg rectangle
this is just going to be a pie game rect
and once again we need a left a top a
width and a height
left we can get fairly easily because we
have self dot main rectangle dot left
since this main rectangle is in the
center of the window this makes it very
easy for us to get positions
top is going to be what we're getting
from the parameters this top here the
width is going to be self dot with the
one we have created all the way up here
and finally the height
is going to be text surface dot get
underscore height don't forget to call
it
and to this i want to add
self.heading
multiplied by two
once i have that all i want to do is
pygame.draw.org
and in here self.display surface
the color should be white
i want to draw the background rectangle
and i want to go with 0 and 4 for the
border radius
with that we already have a pretty good
start all we have to do now is inside of
this for loop we have to figure out how
to actually call this show entry let me
add a bit of white space and first of
all in here we need to get the top
and the top is going to be self dot
main rectangle dot top
plus the
text
index
and this i want to multiply with a
couple of things most importantly the
text surface
and i want to get the height of that
although to that i have to add
self dot
heading
multiplied by 2 and i have to add self
dot
space
think of this one here is the main
rectangle this one here
and by default we are getting the top
this line here
and for every item we want to get the
distance downwards
that we get by multiplying the text
index by the height of the text the
padding and the space
for example if the text index is zero
all of this is going to be zero so the
first item is going to be all the way at
the top here
for item number one
we would be somewhere
here
let's say this one could be 100 because
the text height
would be something like 70.
the padding
could be
2 times 10 and let's say for the space
we also have 10
and all of this we want to multiply by
one as a consequence the result here is
going to be 100 and this 100 is going to
be the top of this text entry
and this is what we can use in self dot
show entry let me copy all of the
parameters here
so top is what we have just calculated
text surface is also what we are getting
from here
for the amount for now let's just say 0
we're going to work on this in just a
second
but for now if i run main.pi again and
press enter now we can see all of the
background fields and those are
perfectly centered which is looking very
nice
definitely progress
although let me get rid of
this line here so we're not drawing the
text anymore and also
this drawing here so we don't have the
red background
now if i run this again this is looking
much cleaner cool so with that we can
start working on the text
for this one i want to create a text
rectangle
once again this is going to be pygame
dot rect and again we need a left at top
a width and a height
for this one i want to get the text
surface and get underscore rect
in here once again i want to place the
mid left
i need an x and a y position
or rather i need a left and a top
position to be a bit more specific
for the left side i want to have
self.mainrect dot left and now i want to
have an offset let's say 20.
for the top i want to have the bg
rectangle
and in here i want to have the center y
position
once i have that i can run
self.displaysurface.blit
and pass in the text surface and the
text
rectangle
let's try this one now
and there we go this is looking really
good
finally we need the amount
for this one first of all i want to
create an amount surface
this once again i get with self.font.rna
in here we need some text we need
anti-alias and once again the color
the color
is always going to be black and the
alias is always going to be false and
the text itself is going to be the
amount
although
here this we have to convert to a string
because by default amount is a number
and pygame doesn't like that it always
wants a string for the render method
now that we have that we can create an
amount rectangle
this we get with amount surface dot get
underscore rec
and for this one i want to place the mid
right
again we need a left and a top and for
the left side what i want in here if
this is one text box
or rather one of the bg rectangle
inside of there we have the text
rectangle and the text is somewhere here
ish
with a offset from the left
for the amount surface i want the exact
opposite i want to come from the right
side and have something like this which
means for the left side here we want to
have the right side
of the main rectangle and then go to the
left a bit
which means i want to have self dot main
rect
dot right
and subtract let's start with 20 pixels
although for the top all i want is the
bg rectangle and then center y again
and let me clean this up a tiny bit
there we go all we have to do now is get
self dot display surface dot blit and
pass in the amount surface and the
amount rectangle
if i run this now
this is looking pretty good
although we do have to figure out the
actual numbers for the amount
that however isn't that difficult or at
the very least it's certainly possible
first of all inside of the for loop i
want to get let's call it an amount list
and this amount list is going to be very
similar compared to this options here as
a consequence i can just copy it
and paste it in here except now we don't
look at the keys instead we are looking
at the values
this way if i open the player we are
getting
all of these values here inside of one
list
and this list has the same order
as this list here
as a consequence
we can get the amount
simply by looking at the amount list and
using the text index
and that is what i want to pass in here
if i now run this again press enter we
are getting lots of zeros but then we
are getting five and five those are the
two seats and with that we have the
basics of the menu
although we cannot select anything and
let's do this right now i guess we can
keep the entire merchant in one big
section
for the selection we need a few more
things most importantly let me add this
section here and let's call it
movement
the one thing we need in here is self
dot index
by default zero here is totally fine
and how i'm going to use this when i'm
creating show entry let me minimize
everything else
there's going to be one more parameter
and that is going to be selected
and if selected is true so if selected
then i want to for now just draw a
border around this particular box which
i'm getting with self.display surface
for the drawing the color here should be
black
and i want to get the background
rectangle
although now i want to have a border
width of four and 4 for the border
radius if you specify a border width the
content or the filling disappears for
this rectangle
but let me show what actually happens if
i press enter now
we are getting an error because i forget
to add the argument in here i want to
have either true or
false
and what i am checking is if self.index
is equal to the text index
now if i run this and press enter
now by default the first item is going
to be selected however if i go to my
menu and set this index to let's say a 3
and run this again
now
we have tomatoes selected
and all i really have to do inside of
the menu is to change this index to
select a different item and this i'm
doing inside of input
all i want to do in here is if keys and
pie game dot k underscore up if that is
the case
i want to set self dot index minus equal
one
then i can copy all of this
and change the up to down
and this one should be a plus one
now i can set index back to zero and now
let's try this actually if i press enter
now and press down
something weird is happening the thing
disappears oh well it kind of works but
it moves way too fast
and this is a problem we have
encountered earlier
basically inside of the init method
pygame for this one for example checks
if the down key is being pressed but
pygame checks this about 100 times per
second as a consequence if we are
pressing it down pygame registers this
line let's say 20 times
even though for us it seems like we are
only pressing the key once
and as a consequence we need a timer
this one we already have i want from
timer import timer
and the timer i want to create in here
so self.timer
is going to be
timer for this one we only need a
duration and for the duration for this
one i went with 200 milliseconds
now inside of the input method when i'm
pressing either up or down
i want to activate this timer so
self.timer.activate
but all of this should only be possible
if the timer is not active
meaning if not self.timer.active
finally there's one more thing that we
need and that is we have to update the
timer which i'm doing all the way to the
top of the input method
self.timer.update
i hope you remember the time i actually
recreated this one a couple of hours ago
let me open it actually so inside of the
timer this one here
we have all of this
and this is what i'm using inside of the
menu right now
but with that this should already be
working if i run this now i can open the
menu and i can move up and down this is
working really well the problem right
now is if i move too far up the thing
disappears and also if i move too far
down it disappears
this we want to control for
meaning i want to
clamp the
values
all this really means in practice is i
want to have myself.index and if this
one is below zero
i want to set self dot index
to length of self dot options
minus one
this means if we are going below zero we
we're going to the end of the list
this is also going to work the other way
around that if self.index
is greater than
the length of the list minus one then i
want to set self.index to zero
and now let's run this again
and if i move down this still works if i
move up we are getting to the bottom of
the list and if i move downwards we are
going back to the top
so this is working perfectly fine
okay next up
when we are showing the entry
let me minimize everything once more
the next thing i want to do is that let
me run the game again
and we have what apple corn automator
selected i want to have a cell text
roughly here
for all of these and if we have corn or
tomato selected there should be a by
text here
and this is what i'm going to create now
first of all for that inside of the
setup we have to import or well create
two more things
those two things are going to be the by
or cell text surface
in here i want to have self dot by text
and i want to have self dot cell text
both of those are going to be
pygame.font.render
and again we need three arguments the
first one is the text let's leave this
one empty for now after that we want
folds for the anti-alias and for the
color we want black
for the byte text this should just be by
and for the cell text it should be cell
with that we have two surfaces
we just have to figure out when to
actually show them
that is going to happen inside of show
entry
specifically i only want to show this
when the specific entry is selected
how this is going to work i am first
going to check if self dot index
is greater than self.cell
border this is the border we created in
the init method
right here this one is checking the
length of the inventory so if we are
inside of the length of this border we
want to sell if we are beyond it we want
to buy
let me add comments here this one is
going to be buy and if this one is not
true so else then we want to sell
actually i think this one is a bit
confusing let me do this the other way
around so if we are below this we want
to sell and if we are beyond it we want
to buy
and all we have to do now is self dot
display surface dot blit and in the cell
one i want to display self dot
i called this one
cell
text
for the position let's say for now we
are going to go with zero and zero
and for the buy text this is going to be
by text
and let's try this one although it's
going to look a bit funny
and we have an issue inside of the setup
method this shouldn't be pi game it
should be self.font.render
if i now run this again this is working
and now in the top left you can see sell
sell sell and now we have buy
buy buy
although for the tomato something did go
wrong so we have to make some minor
adjustments here but other than that
this is working pretty good i guess the
problem here is inside of entry this
should be smaller or equal
if i now run this again we get sell sell
sell and buy and buy there we go this is
working just fine
although the position of the buy and
sell text we do have to work on although
the position is looking a bit weird
let's work on that one and for this i
want to create another rectangle let's
call it the position rectangle
in here i want to have self dot for cell
i want to have the cell
text and get underscore rect
for this one i have to place the mid
left and once again i need the left and
i need a top the top is the really easy
part because i get my background
rectangle dot center y
for the left i want to have my self dot
main rectangle dot left
and to this one i want to add 150 pixels
i can place the position rectangle in
here and this should be working let's
try
and we are getting an error that this
should be
yet wrecked with lowercase letters
and now we get cell
in the perfect positions although buy is
still looking a bit weird
but that we can work on
all i have to do is duplicate this one
here paste it in there and now we want
to get the bi-text
surface
but the rest is going to remain the same
meaning if i run this now
we get sell cell and bye bye because i
didn't paste
the position rectangle in here for the
position
now this should be working
sell sell and buy and buy this is
working perfectly fine
cool i am really happy with this
so let me minimize show entry and the
setup all we have to do now inside of
input is to actually make the menu do
something
for that inside of this if statement
here i want to add another if statement
and now i want to check if keys and
pygame dot k underscore space
if that is the case first of all i want
to activate the timer so
self.timer.activate
after that i want to get the item
so i want to create another variable
called current item
and for this one i want to have myself
dot options
and use self dot index
i suppose let me print what we actually
get with current item
and if i run main.pi
if i now press space we get wood apple
corn tomato corn and tomato this is
working just fine
now i have to figure out do i want to
sell or do i want to buy
that is information we can access quite
easily
because i once again want to check if
self.index is smaller or equal than
self dot sell order
if that is the case i do want to sell if
it is not the case so else i want to buy
if i am selling it should be
self.player.item.inventory
and i want to check the current item
if that is greater than 0
i want to do something so this should
all be an if statement
let me copy the entire line here because
what i want to do if this is the case
this should be reduced by 1.
and on top of that i want to get myself
dot
layer
dot money
and i want to increase that amount by a
certain number this number i'm getting
from settings and here i can minimize a
ton of different things
in here we have sale price and purchase
prices
for now i only care about the sale price
this i want to access and i want to use
the current item as the index
this should be all we need for now for
the else i want to add a pass and just
to test this inside of the player let's
give the player a couple of items
like this
and now if i run this again i press
enter i have lots of different items i
could be selling and if i press space
the amount gets reduced and our money
increases
and let me try to sell all of my wood
if i now get to zero i cannot sell
anymore
but i can still sell other things so
this is working perfectly fine
so with that all we have to do is to
check the buy part and we are basically
done
in here first of all i need to get the
seed price
this i'm getting again from settings and
there we have purchase prices
this i want to get and in here i want to
get my current item as the index
now i want to check if the player has
enough money for it which means if
self.player.money
is greater or equal than the seed
rise
then i want to get self.player.seed
underscore inventory
and i want to get the current item again
i want to plus equal one
and then self.player.money
is going to be minus equal the purchase
price of the current item
there we go and this should be it let's
try
so i can still sell things but now if i
try to buy things
my money goes down and
let me hold space pressed and at some
point we should be reaching zero
there we go now we are zero and i cannot
buy any more seats
i can still sell things though and now
that i have money again i can buy some
tomato seeds
until i am running out of money and
there we go this is working fine
so with that we have created the entire
menu
and that finishes basically the main
part of the game all we have to do now
is to add some sounds and then we are
done for the final bit we have to add
the sound let's jump right in this
really shouldn't take too long here we
are back in the code and what i want to
work with let me open the folder
here's the entire project and i want to
look at audio in here we have a couple
of different files that i want to use
the main problem is we have to figure
out when and where to use them
but that really shouldn't be too
difficult
let's start with the axe for this one i
want to look at my sprites so let's open
this one again
in the sprites i want to minimize
everything because i only want to focus
on the tree
basically inside of the tree whenever we
damage a tree i want to play the x sound
let me add another comment here
play
sound
basically all i want to do is self dot x
sound dot play and that is basically it
for that i have to import it
this happens in the init method
let's call this one sounds
all i need in here is self dot x sound
and this is what i get from pygame dot
mixer dot sound
spelled like that
the file path we need here is one fold
up then audio and in there we have a
file called x dot
mp3 and with that we should be ready
if i now run main.pi and walk towards a
tree and hit that one with an x
that is sounding pretty good
so next up we need to sound effect if
the player gets a thing
this is going to happen inside of level
because in here i have the player add
method i basically want to play
something like self.success.lay
this success we have to import and this
happens let's do it all the way at the
bottom
music this i call self.success
and this once again we get with
pygame.mixer.sound
the file once again is one folder up
audio
and the file is called success.wav
although for this one by default i think
it's a bit loud as a consequence
self.success dot set underscore volume
and in here 0.3 i think sounded good
and now anytime the player gets any kind
of item we are playing that sound
so let's run minded pi
and let's say i want to get an apple
that sounds not too bad
and if a tree disappears
this also plays cool so this is working
it's also going to play when we are
picking up a plant but that takes a
while to test so i think we're good for
the next tool i want to work on the hoe
and for that i want to reopen my soil
layer
or soil.pie
and i want to minimize everything in the
soil layer
i want to add sounds
and in here i want to create self.hoe
sound
and this one i get with
pygame.mixer.sound
the file path here is one folder up
audio
and in there i have whole dot wav
this i want to make a little bit less
loud though so
i want to set the volume to 0.4
and this now if i minimize all of the
methods i want to play
whenever the soil gets hit so in here
let's do it all the way to the top
self.hold
and with that we should be having
another sound
so if i now use this one
possibly a bit loud
i want to change the set volume to 0.1
and now let's try this
definitely an improvement
it's going to get better once we have
background music but i'm kind of happy
with this
next up i want to work on the watering
sound this one is going to happen inside
of the player in here all the way at the
bottom
here
i want to add
his sound section and this i called
self.water ring
this once again we get
pygame.mixer.sound
the file path here is one fold up audio
and the file name is called water.
this one is an mp3
and whenever we are using a tool and the
selected tool is water
i want to play self dot water ring
although for this one i also want to
change the
volume so self.watering.set
underscore volume
is going to be 0.2
if i now run main.pi again select the
watering can
that's working just fine cool
there's one more that i forgot and that
is inside of soil besides the whole we
also have self dot plant
and this one let's call it plant sound
actually plant sound
once again pygame dot mixer dot sound
and in here one folder up audio
and this one is called
planned and the file ending is
a dot wav
let me just duplicate it self dot plan
sound dot set underscore volume
let's go of 0.2
[Music]
this one i want to play whenever we are
planting a seed in here so all the way
at the top i want self dot plant sound
dot play
that way this one will only be played if
we are actually hitting the soil if i
run this
i first have to create a soil patch and
now if i plant some seed
not the greatest sound effect but it
certainly works
and all right with that we have all of
the minor sound effects the one last
thing we have to do is to play the
background music and this could be a
really good exercise for you figure out
where you could play the background
music and import it and play it
all of this is going to happen inside of
level i guess theoretically you could
also play it in main.pi but level.pi is
a bit more flexible
in here i want to import music so
self.music
and this we get with pygame.mixer.sound
the file name here is called well we
have to go to audio first and i want to
import music
which in this case is an mp3 file
what we also have to do to play it is
self dodge music dot play and in here
loops needs to be -1 so that we play
this continuously
now for the background music i have been
a bit lazy because you probably want to
change the volume depending on the day
time or play different kinds of music
depending on what kind of weather you
have but well i just have one kind of
background music
but this video is getting long enough
you can work on this yourself but now if
i run this
now before i finish the entire thing
there are some very minor things i do
want to change
first of all inside of the player
if i minimize everything again so we can
see what's going on inside of the input
in here i have to clean up this
self.toggle shop that's the one i forgot
earlier
here we go and now this one is done so
let me close the entire player
besides that in the level
i want to set the rain to something
greater than seven
because the rain really shouldn't happen
that often this i also have to update
let me minimize all of the methods once
more
in the
reset method this one should be like
this
finally inside of the sprites in here
once again i want to minimize everything
and in the tree i created an involved
timer and this one simply isn't
necessary i just mixed up my notes
but now we are done with the entire
thing this was literally all we needed
and let's make sure this is all still
running
[Music]
all right this is looking really good so
well done if you have gotten this part
this was a really long tutorial so i
hope you enjoyed it and i'll see you
around